social media can act as a window for
your products and services social media
marketing can have a great impact on
growing your brand hi guys welcome to
this complete social media marketing
tutorial by simply learn in this video
we'll be covering some of the most
important topics related to social media
marketing now let's have a look at them
our instructor Rob will take you through
how you can start with social media
marketing Facebook advertising some of
the tips and strategies that you can
employ how to rank YouTube videos how to
increase YouTube subscribers how to
increase Twitter followers how to
increase Instagram followers and some
popular social media marketing tools
that you can use the world we live in
now it's highly digital place but that
wasn't always the case until four years
ago so if we rewind letting people know
about your products was a little harder
then so even if you go back say five or
ten years promoting your products wasn't
as easy as it is today I mean people had
to resort to you know good old-fashioned
newspapers putting in an ad or those big
thick books called The Yellow Pages that
usually sat in your closet and wait a
ton I mean those were the ways to get
your product a message out there a lot
of advertising in those Yellow Pages
then you have Billboards you know
driving down the highway you see that
that billboard on the side of the road
you wonder who are those people that are
actually advertising this stuff of
course you have television that's been
around for decades a good source of
advertising but costly and then facts
facts ads uncommonly known way to
advertise by the way who has faxes now
but people did advertise via facts just
a few decades ago so these were all the
ways in which people had to get their
product and service out there it seems
like so archaic looking at it now but
back then that was legitimate that was
the way to do it and then one thing made
our lives a lot easier so if you're a
marketer you're thinking to yourself man
I'm glad I'm a marketer in today's day
and age because it's social media
marketing social media marketing has
made everyone's lives better from the
company that's selling the product or
service to the marketer promoting the
product and service to the end user who
wants to to see that product or service
and engage with that product or service
so social media is a good source of
getting your product and service out
there and it just makes everybody's
lives a heck of a lot easier so we're
going to answer that million dollar
question and what's that million dollar
question it's how can you Rise Above the
Rest and so today's session is going to
be how to start with social media
marketing so you can Rise Above the Rest
leveraging this great platform that we
all take advantage of today so let's
start by asking the question what is
social media marketing social media
marketing involves increasing website
traffic it centers around engagement it
offers you the ability to increase your
brand awareness and it has other
marketing goals you know so you can
create various forms of content for
different social media platforms so
that's really in a nutshell with social
media marketing is so again if we want
to increase our traffic or we want to
increase our engagement like likes or
comments then look no further than
social media marketing if we want to
engage with our users our customers our
potential and prospective customers we
can really put a personalized experience
in place using social media marketing we
want to create different forms of
content like videos and blogs and
infographics and other types of graphics
with the potential to actually go viral
what we mean by viral is spreading like
wildfire one user sending it to another
as rapidly as can be and before you know
it you get you know millions of views
and millions of likes I mean that's the
power of social media marketing so why
do we want to do social media marketing
and I think we just answered some of
those questions but let's dig a little
bit deeper we mentioned in our
definition of social media marketing
that we have the opportunity to really
build our brand awareness and that is no
more truthful than with social media
marketing more so than any other digital
marketing channel social media marketing
allows us to really put our brand in a
good light in a good position in front
of the right eyeballs so it allows us to
really improve our brand by pushing out
the appropriate content in front of the
appropriate people social media is a
great channel for that we can look to
conversion rates so if we are pushing a
product and service in front of the
right eyeballs and we are building up a
funnel of prospective customers who then
turn into customers who then turn into
loyal customers who then turn into
lifetime customers we could see at every
step in the process that our conversion
rates may increase we can certainly
leverage social media marketing for SEO
for search engine rankings it's about
off-page SEO it's about posting content
on social media platforms to build up
some link juice okay so there is some
inherent benefits to working SEO and
social media side by side it's cost
effective well if you're posting content
on Twitter or Facebook it doesn't cost
you anything it just takes a little bit
of time and creativity now if you want
to go ahead and do some advertising on
these platforms yes it's going to cost
you but you'd be surprised not going to
be as costly as say other search
platforms like say Google or Bing where
you're actually paying for keywords and
paying per click for those keywords so
social media marketing can be very cost
effective and then increase top funnel
traffic so it goes all the way back to
Brand experience and brand awareness if
you're putting yourself in position to
get seen by your target audience okay
your target audience goes from senior
brand for the first time to getting to
know your brand a little bit more to
maybe buying a product or service from
your brand then returning to buy another
product in service and then continuing
to buy that product or service I mean
that's increasing the top funnel traffic
and not just the traffic but the
conversions so at every step in the
process social media allows you to build
that funnel depending on where somebody
is whether they're seeing your brand for
the first time or actually returning to
purchase the product or service again so
that's the inherent benefit these are
the inherent benefits of social media
marketing now we talk about social media
marketing what are the channels used for
social media marketing and how can we
use them it's really social media
marketing is a channel in itself so
let's take a look at the platforms
involved with social media marketing now
there are some really popular platforms
so if you can't tell just buy these
logos then you probably have not used
social media marking or or social media
platforms before or Taken part in social
media at all but you know one would like
to think that the majority of your users
out there today know what Facebook is
what the logo looks like what it does
same with Instagram which is owned by
Facebook LinkedIn B2B platform it's
YouTube great very popular video sharing
platform and then Twitter which is
considered microblogging but still
social media so these are the most
popular popular platforms out there but
there are hundreds of social media
Platforms in fact when we talk about
social media marketing it can be
anything from microblogging to video
sharing like YouTube to B2B networks
like LinkedIn to say bookmarking sites
like stumbled upon content sharing sites
like Reddit q a sites like quora so
there's plenty of different types of
social media platforms out there in fact
if you folks have any popular or you
think valid social media platforms that
these listeners here should really get
to know and understand and use then go
ahead and put that in the comments
section underneath this video I'm always
interested in knowing what social media
platforms are out there and what people
are using how platforms are trending
what's popular what's not and ideally as
a digital marketer where my target
audience is so these are the most common
but there are hundreds out there
hundreds so let's talk about the most
popular social media platform and that's
Facebook so Facebook is an average of
2.27 billion monthly active users now
that number is fluctuating because we're
talking about billions billions billions
of monthly active users and that
number's probably trending up 88 of all
users are on mobile so what does that
tell you that tells you that Facebook
has an app and the app is very popular
in fact I tend to use the app more than
I use the web page for Facebook okay so
I don't necessarily really log on via
the Internet on my laptop I go right to
the app it's just easier easier to
disseminate information easier to add
friends comment respond Etc so it's no
surprise that 88 of all users use mobile
now 66 percent of mobile monthly users
use Facebook daily so a lot of recurring
users going back on a day-to-day basis
two-thirds so it's an addiction more
than if anything else because what
Facebook is is really you're getting
information from the people you trust
care about like work with share a group
with share common interest with partake
in the same organization maybe have the
same running group same passions I mean
that's what Facebook is it's a
commonality amongst people and if you
build up a network of that commonality
it's going to be addicting to take part
in that you know the closest Network you
can ever get to is your family so if
your family's on Facebook then likely
you're going to be on Facebook
communicating with your family via this
platform especially if you don't live
close to your family or especially if
you don't live close to your friends I
know in the United States you know
people move a lot for work or people
travel a lot for work and so Facebook
bridges that gap between distance and
you you know you do feel like you're
part of somebody's life on a daily basis
being on Facebook so that's what makes
it The Addictive part so if you think
about it from an end user's perspective
it makes total sense now if you wear
your digital marketing hat you're
thinking hey two-thirds of monthly users
are using it daily and there's billions
of active users then whoever I'm
targeting has to be on Facebook now if
we look closer at the demographics we
could see that a lot more seniors age 65
plus are using Facebook so 60 plus
percent of seniors are using Facebook so
Facebook is trending oh older however 35
percent of the audience is below the age
of 25 so it's not just trending up it's
also trending down so a lot of young
people are still using Facebook and then
Facebook you know is pretty evenly
matched between males and females now if
I'm either slowing old feeling older or
skewing younger on my target audience
and half female half as male then I know
somewhere in there whoever I'm targeting
is going to be on Facebook just based on
these numbers here so your demographic
is likely going to be on Facebook again
depending on your industry depending on
your product or service but considering
the number of people and how it's
skewing older and younger and everybody
in between Facebook has something for
everyone now Facebook allows for video
content so you could post videos all day
long so if you have YouTube videos you
can share those YouTube videos on
Facebook and fact video just like on
most platforms tends to provide better
engagement and the industries that can
really capitalize on Facebook tend to be
food and beverage news and media and
e-commerce meaning you're selling a
product Facebook has you know plugins
and that allow you to really accentuate
what you're trying to sell when I say
that accentuate I mean really
incorporate an opportunity for people to
use the Facebook platform to not only
just engage not only to share but to buy
taking that process a step further so if
you're selling a product you can more or
less set up a a Facebook shop if you
will and sell your product there so
that's why it benefits those that are
are in the e-commerce industry selling a
particular product or in the food and
beverage industry now some of the most
liked pages on Facebook spans across
many many Brands but let's just take a
look at at Coca-Cola for example and
Coca-Cola just pretty much pinpoints
everything great about what you could do
on Facebook I mean you could see here
they have their opening page is a video
and so you can see they're posting
different content about you know this is
about a grant how they're helping the
city of Atlanta you know they're talking
about recycling so to me these are
community-based posts so they're not
necessarily just pushing out their
product per se they're trying to use
Facebook to build up brand awareness so
a huge Fortune 500 company like
Coca-Cola is not necessarily just using
Facebook just to push e-commerce to push
a product they're out there you know
pushing what they're doing for the
community so this is a good example of
you know how you can really leverage
Facebook taking advantage of everything
Facebook has to offer and that means
brand awareness Community Building
you're sharing you know updated
information not only about the company
but in this case Coca-Cola situated in
Atlanta Georgia in the United States so
you know what are they doing with the
community okay so this is a good example
of course it's a big example because
Coca-Cola is a big company they're
worldwide but the great thing about
Facebook is you can always take a peek
at what other companies are doing
whether you have a million plus people
liking your page or a hundred plus
people like in your page you can always
get ideas as to how they're leveraging
Facebook now if you do have a company
you can create a Facebook page for your
business just like Coca-Cola so you want
to be able to separate out your business
from your personal page and like
everything you do whether that's writing
a blog or creating a video you want to
have original content that's relevant to
your audience you want to use Facebook
for some promotion but every post
doesn't necessarily need to be promoting
your product or service you saw what we
just witnessed on on the Coca-Cola page
it was about what they were doing to you
know benefit the Earth with recycling or
what they're doing in conjunction with
the with the city of Atlanta so they're
more community-based posts and so to me
that's original content positive content
that isn't necessarily pushing their
product per se now you could argue hey
it's Coca-Cola they have the biggest
brand in the world and that's true but
just think about your product and
service think about your brand if you're
trying to build brand awareness what
does your brand stand for and if your
brand stands for say the the globe the
ecosystem the environment then you
probably want to be pushing out posts in
that direction if that's what you stand
for as a brand then you want people to
know that because like-minded people are
on Facebook and those like-minded people
are going to be the ones who like your
page who engage with your content and
tell other people about it so you always
want to go original you always want to
be true to yourself and true to your
brand and and then you could take
advantage of user generated content like
sharing a user's experience of using
your product so in other words if
somebody's engaging with you or they've
posted something about your brand and
product you can reciprocate and you can
certainly post something that is similar
to what somebody's doing with your
product or brand so that's a good way to
create some original content by taking
advantage of what the users have
generated so these are just some
examples of how to take advantage of
Facebook I mean there's lots of things
you can do on Facebook plenty of things
if we float back to Coca-Cola page you
know you can see they have you know
careers they have different videos they
have reviews they have community so
nowhere in here do I see an e-commerce
platform now if you are selling T-shirts
then hey you can put something in there
to help you sell that t-shirt but
Coca-Cola's strategy is hey what can we
do to help build up our community what
can we do to find race so if we click on
fundraise you can see they have you know
an N AIDS campaign here if you look at
simply learn just as another example you
can see what simply learns done as well
you could see they have information
about us they have different events they
have a community link as well and so you
can see what they're posting as well and
there you can see they're posting
visitor photos so there's lots you can
do on Facebook you can post polls you
can put your Instagram feed in there you
can add testimonials so there's a lot
you can do on your page you just gotta
get creative and take advantage of
everything Facebook has to offer be true
to yourself and before you know it I
mean you're gonna have you know a number
of likes on your business page as well
so some other tips about Facebook when
it comes to content you want to schedule
your content okay you don't want to just
continue to post back to back to back to
back you want to space your content out
and the another great advantage to
Facebook as I already mentioned about
social media marketing that's
advertising so Facebook owns Instagram
they have a great tool for communicating
called Facebook messenger and so you can
advertise leveraging Facebook Messenger
you can leverage Instagram and what you
need to do is if you go to Facebook's ad
manager and you create a campaign when
you go to create a campaign you're going
to click on placements and depending on
what you're trying to do let's just say
you're trying to build brand awareness
you can actually hone in on you know
Facebook you can hone in on Instagram
you can do a number of different things
within Facebook you have different ads
available to you from single image ads
to video ads to Carousel so you have a
lot of options and the biggest option on
Facebook when it comes to advertising is
your audience who are you targeting so
remember Facebook has old young and
everybody in between between men and
women and so you can specifically Target
interest you can speak specifically
Target gender and age a location so
Facebook really allows you to hone in on
who your audience is if you're
advertising and so that's the great
thing about Facebook they have a lot of
users and you're you have an opportunity
to hone in on a segment of that user
base now Facebook also has metrics that
you can look at to really understand how
people are interacting with your ads how
people are interacting with your post so
let's take a look at that so if we go to
Facebook when you go to your page you
can click on insights and you can
actually see some insights on posts that
have been posted on your page you can
get insights into how many people viewed
it how many people liked it how many
people engaged how many people you
reached with your post okay you have
information about videos followers
Facebook provides recommendations so
this is all part of Facebook insights so
if you're posting on Facebook Facebook
will give you feedback as to how you're
supposed to perform it now if you're
running ads on Facebook you can simply
just view metrics related to how your
ads are performing so you can see how
many people clicked on an ad how many
people the ad reached how much you've
spent okay you can look at it by
demographic you can even see cost per
result so you can get a lot of good
insights into how your ads are
performing as well so if you're running
a campaign targeting a specific audience
on Facebook you can look at the you know
stats and metrics surrounding that
campaign and again for your Facebook
page you have Facebook insights so if
you have any questions you know feel
free we have a video called Facebook
advertising tips and tricks so feel free
to you know take a look at this video on
simply learns YouTube channel for more
information about Facebook and if again
if you have any comments to share about
Facebook feel free to put them under the
comments section okay let's turn our
attention to one of the platforms
Facebook actually owns Instagram so
Instagram is a place where you can
actually promote your brand product or
service through the power of imagery or
video and so the average number of
monthly users on Instagram reaches 1
billion and 32 percent of all internet
users are on Instagram so a lot of users
using it it's very easy platform to use
you just the only prerequisite you need
your mobile phone so you open up that
app it's as simple as just uploading
uploading an image that's why Instagram
is so popular because it's just a simple
tool to use to go ahead and just post an
image with some hashtags so 68 of all
Instagram users are women so unlike
Facebook it does tend to slant more on
the female side and 59 of the audience
is is a bit younger between age 18 to 29
so Slants more women and Slims more
younger and so if these particular
demographic and age groups tend to fit
your target audience then Instagram is a
place you probably want to be for social
media marketing so as I mentioned
content that works best are photos or
videos I would always slant towards
videos if you have them available but
photos you know the rule of thumb is
photos always tell a thousand words a
thousand stories a thousand
interpretations images are just always
the best way to go as well I mean if you
don't have the videos hey nothing to be
sad about if you fall back on imagery so
you can really put your brand in a good
perspective and a good light by posting
images and as you can imagine if 18 to
29 year old women are on Instagram you
know that's skewing towards certain
demographic but in terms of Industry it
is open to most Industries but the ones
that tend to be most successful are
Beauty food and beverage and e-commerce
now food and beverage always tends to
work well when you have video and
imagery likewise Beauty but e-commerce
if you're selling that t-shirt or shoe
you know Instagram allows the platform
to work in a way where people can
purchase that product right within the
platform so that's why it tends to work
well with e-commerce okay there are lots
of channels just like on Facebook lots
of channels on Instagram I mean some of
the most followed brands are Chanel
Starbucks Nike I mean if you have a
product or service that you want to push
out there then Instagram is the way to
go just for brand awareness if you're
selling shoes then why not take images
of and photos of those shoes and get
them posted on Instagram like I said
it's very simple to use all you need is
some hashtags to go along with that
photo of a shoe or photo of that cup of
coffee and Instagram kind of takes care
of itself I mean photos do accentuate
the product if you have them so leverage
Instagram if you're really trying to
build up some brand awareness for a
particular product some best practices
here on Instagram is you know have a
compelling bio a good profile picture
you know add a link to a landing page
and you know leverage emojis if you have
to so set yourself up nicely on
Instagram you know if you're in a
particular industry like food and
beverage follow other food and beverage
Brands like Coca-Cola like Starbucks
depends on what it is you really want to
be related to so just make sure they're
relevant get hashtags can't stress that
enough you know when you post a photo
throw some hashtags in there you could
see what other people are hashtagging on
Instagram and you can ride that wave of
what's trending or you can create your
own unique hashtag I'd probably have two
to three hashtags photo then don't be
afraid to use both photos and videos
videos do tend to work well on pretty
much any platform they tend to work well
on websites and blogs so why not use
them on social media where people can
engage okay so videos and imageries both
work well on Instagram okay you can also
get shout outs from other influencers
you know plenty of influencers on
Instagram especially in Beauty
especially in food and beverage fashion
tends to be another industry that has a
lot of influencers so feel free to reach
out to them reciprocate see how you can
work together where they can actually
you know give you a shout out on your
particular product you want to keep your
Instagram account updated and you can
update those with Instagram stories it's
basically you showing off a particular
product you know over a span of a few
seconds or even a minute that's an
Instagram story they're very popular uh
easy to use you can even run contests to
boost engagement so for example if your
particular product is a particular food
like a hamburger you know hey post a
contest about you know allowing your
followers to post the best good looking
tasty you know Hamburger as an example
or it could be something else in terms
of fashion hey what's your best outfit
on a Friday night before you go out for
the evening you know there's always
things you can do to Spur engagement
especially on a platform like Instagram
where people like to post photos and
then I mentioned this earlier with
Facebook ads you can run Instagram ads
to give a particular post a boost so if
we take a little snapshot of what we
have available in Facebook ads manager
you can choose Instagram as the
particular platform so if you just want
to advertise on Instagram when you go to
your placements you could choose just
Instagram either the feed or the stories
okay so you can choose one of these two
options if you want to wanna boost your
posts get some more eyeballs on that
it's a cost per click platform so
anytime somebody clicks it's going to
cost you but you know just like Facebook
you know the cost per click tends to
slant a little bit lower it really
depends on what you're trying to post
when you're trying to post it who else
is posting but hey the Instagram feed
and the stories could be a good option
if you're really trying to draw
attention to a particular product okay
let's turn our attention now to the B2B
platform called LinkedIn linkedin's a
very powerful popular business to
business platform okay it has 260
million active users monthly and unlike
Instagram or Instagram Slants more
towards women LinkedIn Slants more
towards men 57 so a majority of the
users are men but still you have a lot
of women involved in on LinkedIn so a
nice you know nice mix between both
genders 30 eight percent of the user
base are millennials you know a lot of
young people older people a nice mix
from a business lots of different
business segments different levels of
business different business Industries
and verticals are on LinkedIn so don't
be you know shying away from uh LinkedIn
if you're demographic or target audience
tends to be older just because 38
percent are millennials doesn't mean
anything it means that everybody's using
it just that means that hey you know
more than one-third of the users are
millennials are younger now LinkedIn is
a B2B platform so if you're in the
business of generating business leads
then LinkedIn is the place for you to go
there's opportunities for you to
advertise on LinkedIn okay there's also
opportunities for you to post lots of
different content on LinkedIn so content
that works on LinkedIn could be a Blog
it could be you know particular news
article you know tips and best practices
I've posted videos those on LinkedIn you
know it's good for jobs there's a lot of
content on LinkedIn so if we take a
sneak peek at LinkedIn if I just go to
LinkedIn here you know and I just go to
my home uh the start news page you know
I could see the types of content that's
been posted so somebody just posted
something with an image you know then
you got an article down here okay you
got you know an influencer Like Richard
Branson posting so you got a lot of
different types of posts that you'll be
able to see and you know leverage if you
want to meaning when I say leverage if
you see somebody like Richard Branson
posting something hey stay fit and
healthy you know that's an image that's
something about not about business per
se but you know something interesting
and unique so you can see all sorts of
different types of content based on who
you're following on LinkedIn and who
you're connected to some things about
LinkedIn you always want to create an
engaging profile when I say engaging
first things first make sure it's
complete I mean there's lots of
opportunities to if you sneak over to my
profile here you want to be able to post
a lot of information about yourself so
about what you're affiliated with what
jobs you've held what groups you're
associated with what your interests are
what certifications you have so you want
to be able to you know complete your
total profile you can't create a company
page for your business so if we go back
to LinkedIn we can just do a search for
say simply learn and let's take a look
at you know their business page so if I
just do a search for simply learn here
so if I select their page you can see
just like your profile page if you have
a business page set up on LinkedIn you
want to make sure it's complete you want
to put information about the company
what jobs are available and you want
your company to associate with that
business page anybody who does you know
follow that particular business page
part of the organization is going to be
listed under people so and you want to
be able to post just like on your
personal profile if you have a business
page you want to be able to post unique
content I mean you can see here simply
learn is posting you know some of the
accolades that they have but they're
taking that a step further they're also
posting you know information about you
know upcoming events and webinars so
they're probably seeing a mix of
different content and that's ideally
what you want to do on any social media
platform is mix it up and just like you
can on Facebook just like you can on
Instagram you can you know boost a post
per se okay so you can get that post in
front of some additional eyeballs now of
course you want to optimize your company
page for searches so it really does come
down to how many people are following
you but when you say when we say
optimize your company page just make
sure it's complete with some compelling
content and then increase the number of
followers you have so the great thing
about LinkedIn that I like the most is
that you know you can you know simply
look at other people if I go back to say
the home page you can actually see who's
following what and you know LinkedIn
does give you opportunities to connect
with people okay so if I go to your if
you go to your profile you'll be able to
see other people that have viewed your
particular page and you can connect with
them okay or connect with people who are
like-minded or similar or connected to
people that you know so LinkedIn does a
good job of presenting other people you
can connect with so it makes it easier
for you to increase the number of
followers so having an engaging profile
personal profile you know having an
engaging company page making sure both
your personal and the company page have
all the content necessary have all of it
completed and then increasing followers
posting unique content I mean that's
really the key to LinkedIn now again
with LinkedIn you can use different
media you can News videos SlideShare
presentation images and you can boost
content as I mentioned before you can
boost content on LinkedIn so if you want
to get that content in front of eyeballs
you can do that so let's take a look at
an example of a campaign and what you
could do on LinkedIn in terms of
sponsored content so if you go to
linkedin's campaign manager I mean you
have an opportunity put your ad in front
of a particular audience so it really
depends on again on who you're trying to
Target just like Facebook which Slants
more towards personal LinkedIn is going
to slant more towards business so with
LinkedIn you have an opportunity to
Target a particular industry a
particular company a particular job
title okay so you could Target
everything business related on LinkedIn
so you can go ahead and create an ad the
ads have imagery to support the ad and
so basically when you set up your ad you
set up your target you can choose your
placement you're going going to be able
to see you know who it is you're
actually targeting and you can go ahead
and great thing about LinkedIn is you
have different ad formats and again you
can get really creative with who you
want to Target and just like Facebook
you know LinkedIn has you know some
metrics that you can measure and figure
out how your particular campaign
performed by Impressions by click click
the rate even conversions cost per
conversions and how many leads so
LinkedIn has built-in platform for
measuring campaign success and so the
differentiation between Facebook and
Linkedin is really just the type of
demographics that you have to choose
from you know with LinkedIn you do have
you know different options available
based on business like your job title or
job level or industry or vertical so you
have a lot of examples available a lot
of options available to you on LinkedIn
in terms of advertising okay let's talk
about YouTube now so YouTube has 1.9
billion active users if it was a search
engine it'd be the second most popular
search engine the highest number of
monthly active users in decreasing order
starts at the United States Brazil
Russia Japan and India all big markets
all like to use YouTube but YouTube's
popular across the world just like
Facebook where the app is popular the
app on for YouTube is very popular so 70
of All Views are generated from mobile
so with YouTube being a video platform
you'd definitely need videos now there's
a lot of Industries on YouTube a lot of
Industries in some of the most
successful brands on YouTube you know
range from logo to Coca-Cola you know
pretty much to every brand if you're a
brand you want to be on YouTube because
of the massive reach that YouTube has to
offer coupled with video and how great
video is in terms of Engagement it's a
just a great combination okay so some
best practices here for YouTube you want
to optimize your video for SEO to get
views and so we have a video that we've
created at simply learn how to rank
YouTube videos so if you watch that
video you'll get some really good tips
and strategies about how to you know
optimize your video for YouTube the very
least you want to make sure that you
know using write the right keywords and
the title description and hashtags so
that's a start when we talk about
optimizing your videos you want to
upload regularly and fix the schedule
for your videos because if you're
starting to get followers on YouTube or
subscribers they're going to expect you
to produce more video especially if
you're producing engaging unique
relevant content for that target
audience so we're not saying you have to
have a video once a day or once a week
start small and build up and get on a
regular schedule and then you can
organize your videos in the playlist so
you know if we look at simply learn you
know simply learned does a good job of
organizing their videos into a playlist
so all you have to do is go to
simply learns uh YouTube channel and you
can see how it's broken down into
playlists now YouTube also has the
ability because it is global you do have
the ability to provide translations so
if your target audience is from another
country it probably wouldn't be a bad
idea like Facebook and Instagram or like
LinkedIn you can advertise on YouTube
you would just need to do that through
Google ads so with Google ads you're
going to say Google I want to advertise
on YouTube and you have plenty of
available options to available to you
anything from you know pre-roll to
showing up in the middle of a video to
showing up you know before or excuse me
at the end of a video all the way to
Native content marketing where you know
your ad is showing up next to a video so
you've plenty of options for advertising
on YouTube and then just like on
Instagram there are influencers on
YouTube you know feel free to reach out
to these influencers and see if you can
collaborate in some way where maybe you
post their video on your channel they
post your video on their Channel and
vice versa so you want to be able to
maybe collaborate somehow to get some
views on your video okay let's talk
about Twitter now so Twitter is a micro
blogging platform and so when I say
micro blogging I mean Limited in
characters Limited in how much you can
actually post but it's very popular it
has 326 million active users per month
and it does tend to slant a lot towards
Millennials a lot of young people use
Twitter and a lot of people use it to
get their news so no longer are the days
of grabbing that newspaper no longer the
days of going maybe to a media news site
online you can quickly go to Twitter and
get all your news right there in a feed
an easy feed let's take a peek at
Twitter here you know I can get
everything from you know somebody
posting something specific about their
dog you know all the way to a particular
job you know all the way to Industry
news you know all the way to basically
an advertisement all the way to a
specific news article so it's all here
on Twitter in your feed so Twitter does
offer videos so videos do work well so
if I go back here you could see you know
here's a video of Antonio Brown he's
posting a video of his news conference
and another promotional video so
industries that capitalize on Twitter as
you can guess if a lot of people go
there from their news you'll probably
see a lot of news in media and
entertainment on Twitter so that doesn't
necessarily mean that you can't use
Twitter for your brand it really comes
down to target audience some of the most
influential brands are slanted more
towards you know news and media but you
know you got Cosmetics you got gaming
companies you got everybody's on Twitter
okay it just comes down to does this
platform have your target audience and
given the nature Twitter you know how
can you get your particular brand
product or service out there and so many
characters okay some other advantages
and best practices you can use on
Twitter so I would recommend
implementing Twitter cards and really
all Twitter cards does is allow you to
attach Rich photos or videos and
different media experiences to tweets so
when you can attach you know rich media
like videos and images to tweets it can
help Drive traffic and engagement to
your website all it's going to take is
just a few lines of markup to your web
page and then users who tweet links to
your content will have a quote-unquote
card added to the Tweet that's visible
to their followers so that's how it
works I would certainly look to get
Twitter cards implemented if you are
going to use Twitter as your platformer
choice for social media marketing so it
does enhance the experience for the end
user and because allows you as an
Advertiser or as somebody Leverage in
social media to really enhance your
Tweet and it just provides a better
experience for the end user who's
looking at your Tweet and so like
LinkedIn you can really take a look at
who's trending what's trending on
Twitter so Twitter makes it easy for you
to you know follow so here they'll list
a who to follow so these who to follow
are similar to what you've been posting
or similar to your industry and then
here you can look at Trends you can look
at what hashtags are trending and so if
you click on a particular hashtag you
can you know follow a particular you
know person who or an organization who
tweeted something so you always are
reminded in Twitter who to follow and so
it makes it easier for you to pick and
choose who to follow and build up your
following fairly quickly because Twitter
actually provides you with opportunities
on who to follow just like LinkedIn just
like YouTube just like Instagram there
there are influencers out there people
who have a large number of followers who
tweet on a regular basis who tweet
original content who get high engagement
these are influencers and these are the
people you want to engage with so look
for those people on Twitter follow them
I mean the rule of thumb is if you
follow someone on Twitter you know
generally they're going to follow you
back so if you can engage and follow
influencers you have an opportunity to
see not only what they're tweeting but
the ability to communicate with them and
engage with them as an influencer so
maybe they can retweet one of your
tweets and get that tweet out in front
of their followers so you can advertise
on Twitter and the unique thing about
advertising on Twitter you can you know
promote your Tweet just like you promote
a post on Facebook or Instagram or
LinkedIn but more so I think than any
other platform is the use of hashtags
and so use appropriate relevant hashtags
I always tend to use a unique hashtag
but also depends on what you're tweeting
about if there's something that's
trending and again Twitter will tell you
what's trending in terms of hashtags if
it's something you're tweeting about
then go ahead and use that hashtag as
well you can have multiple hash tags in
a particular tweet and so don't be
afraid to use a unique hashtag along
with a hashtag that's trending because
the whole idea is you want your Tweet to
get noticed and then you can use tweet
chat or some there's some other tools
out there that are available to allow
you to find people to follow and these
people might be interested in your
product or service because you know they
could fit your target audience or you
can connect with like-minded folks who
are in the same industry or have similar
products or interest so tweet chats
available for that reason and you want
to take advantage of these tools because
again with Twitter it's easy to build a
following but you want to build a
following that is going to to engage
with your tweets so let's talk about
what tools are available for social
media marketing so when we talk about
all these platforms available to us okay
we talk about Facebook and Instagram and
we talked about LinkedIn and Twitter and
YouTube I mean those are popular
platforms but at the beginning of the
session I mentioned there's hundreds of
social media platforms out there and if
you're posting content on a number of
them you want to be able to organize
that content you want to be able to
organize it and schedule it you know
where it makes sense and when it makes
sense you want to stay organized and so
there are tools available to help you
stay organized tools like HootSuite
buffer or Sprout social okay some of
these tools are available you know at a
cost of a free trial or at a low cost
per month so regardless of whether using
a free version of one of these tools or
another tool not listed or you're
actually paying for it it's worth the
investment if you're going to partake in
social media marketing and even if
you're on one platform it's still worth
it to have a social media tool available
to help you schedule and not only do
these social media tools help you
schedule they do a lot of other things
too for example they help you measure
the engagement of your post so let's
take an example of one of them like
Sprout social so if I go to sprout
social here I can see for a particular
company I'm able to see you know how my
post and get were engaged okay so I
could see daily engagements on
particular platforms I can also you know
schedule my post so I can go ahead and
pick a time and date to schedule them
and so I can go ahead and post something
and put it in a queue to be published
for example tomorrow or next week or
whatever the case may be so these tools
do a lot for you I mean they help you
discover new followers they give you
in-depth reports they help you stay
organized and so to me it's worth the
investment to look at one of the tools
listed it here you know these are some
of the more popular ones to maybe even a
free version but regardless of how much
you pay and what tool you're using it's
still worth the investment just to make
sure you're scouging your post at the
appropriate time so you're not posting
something back to back as an example and
you're able to measure accordingly so
it's nice to be able to go into a tool
like Sprout social go to reports and
measure you know in one place you know
how Twitter is performing or how
Facebook's performing or how linkedin's
performing and so that's what's a lot of
these tools provide is nice reporting
options and nice scheduling options so
you can find more content you can create
by using these tools again you can
schedule efficiently analyze them and
you can use insights to improve your
campaign so a lot of these tools give
you nice insights to how the post was
actually engaged and you want to be able
to leverage that and some of these tools
if not all of them have social list
listening and social listening is
monitoring what's being posted out there
so what else is posted you can take a
look at and if it's something
interesting or relevant you can go ahead
and follow or take part in that
conversation okay so that's what social
listening allows you to do and a lot of
these platforms have that as a feature
so let's take a look at tips to be a
good social media marketer so some of
the important things you should take
care of are set up a social media
marketing plan when I say set up a
social media marketing plan there's some
questions you want to be able to ask
okay what platforms am I going to use
what's my objective on each platform in
fact and before you choose the platform
you want to figure out what your
objective is in terms of social media so
your objective could be different on
each platform it could be brand
Awareness on Facebook and it could be
promoting a particular product on
Twitter your objective is going to be on
each platform you want to be able to
choose your kpis and align your kpi eyes
with each platform meaning what metrics
are important to your business goals and
you want to be able to figure out okay
what kind of content am I going to post
on these social media platforms so you
want to get organized and put a plan in
place and then you want to create
informative shareable actionable and
relevant content and what I mean by all
that is you want to create unique
content that doesn't mean you can't
Leverage What other people are doing
meaning you know if I'm you know in the
shoe business I can certainly go to Nike
or Adidas or Puma or Reebok and see what
kind of posts they're putting out and
then I could take their cue and do
something similar but I want it to be
unique to me and I wanted to be unique
to my brand and I want to be able to
keep my content visual meaning I want to
be able to use as many photos and videos
as I can that's available to me because
remember videos generate better
engagement I want to be active and
responsive with my customer base meaning
the whole point of social media is to
engage and people are going to respond
they're going to comment they're going
to take part in What you post and so
whatever they do you want to be able to
respond accordingly whether that's
positive or negative and then you want
to measure metrics like conversion rates
and click the rates so that goes back to
putting a plan in place figure out what
your metrics are and then when you're
posting on a particular platform you
want to be able to lean on those metrics
to make sure you're achieving your goals
so you want to have those metrics in
place beforehand and then you want to be
able to use those metrics moving forward
as you post the whole idea is if you're
measuring what you post you're obviously
going to want to lean more towards
what's working versus what's not working
in a world where a lot of competing
different products satisfy the same
requirements you have a lot of
advertisers who want you to try their
product and then you have other
advertisers who want you to try their
product try my product try my product
try my product try note try my product
my product's the best no no no no no my
product's the best try my product well I
want you to forget all that and try my
product forget about those other
advertisers try my product well there's
only one way you can prove your product
is better than the rest and that's with
powerful advertising and one of the best
ways to advertise on the Internet is via
social media and through the largest
social media platform in the world and
that's Facebook so today we're going to
talk about Facebook ads tutorial and I'm
excited to teach this class my name is
Rob Sanders I'm with simply learn and
today we are going to talk about all the
different ads that Facebook has to offer
so introduced back in 2007 the Facebook
ads platform has grown tremendously over
the last few years almost 4 billion
million dollars of Revenue in one year
so what does that mean that means
there's a lot of advertisers why is
there a lot of advertisers because a lot
of people use Facebook it's a popular
platform so not only is it popular but
it's popular with advertisers because if
you're advertising on Facebook you have
the opportunity to share your product
and your brand with users who you think
are going to buy your product or
associate with your brand and on
Facebook you can do that a number of
different ways specifically in
somebody's news feed and specifically
that person's news feed that again is
interested potentially interested in
your brand your product so there's a lot
of ways to advertise and a lot of
reasons why you want to advertise so I
just mentioned one of the reasons hey
it's an opportunity for you to reach out
to people who are targeted who are
specific to your product and your brand
so not only that but you combine that
target audience with the amount of time
that people spend on Facebook okay
people spend a lot of time on Facebook
in fact not only do people spend a lot
of time on Facebook there's a lot of
people on Facebook in fact 2.27 billion
in the third quarter of 2018. and so
when we say spend a lot of time we mean
going to that Facebook profile at least
once a day okay so a lot of eyeballs
throughout the day checking their news
feed on Facebook Facebook also enables
you the advertiser to find the perfect
audience and so that's the great
combination a lot of people on Facebook
and targeted audience so it's a platform
that allows you to put your product in
front of people based on specific
interest specific demographics special
specific location so you're really
really putting your product out in front
of the right people at the right time
and so the other positive and pro about
Facebook is it's lesser spend greater
reach and what do we mean by that well
traditionally Facebook is a little bit
cheaper than other online advertising
models it is definitely a lot cheaper
than your traditional advertising models
and Facebook has been known to have good
return on investment because it's cost a
little bit less than other advertising
models and other advertising platforms
so that's the other benefit to being on
Facebook so if you're into building a
brand you want to be on Facebook why
because it helps you increase your brand
awareness it's going to help you allow
users to know what your brand is all
about because remember you're putting
your brand in front of like-minded
people or people you think that are
going to associate shape with your brand
that are going to associate with your
product so you put your brand out there
you incorporate your your advertisement
in somebody's news feed it's going to
add value it's going to establish trust
and credibility especially if that
person's friend is associated with that
brand so instant credibility if friends
and family members of a person on
Facebook are associated with your brand
so it has the opportunity to really lend
a lot of credence to somebody who is on
Facebook active on Facebook and is your
targeted demographic and the great thing
about Facebook is it also has other
features other advertising features such
as retargeting so you could Target
people who've already expressed an
interest in your service or product but
if they didn't go through the conversion
process meaning they didn't go all the
way through and and buy your product you
can certainly reach out to them again
just like your traditional retargeting
options on say Google or some other
advertising platform Facebook works the
same way we want to be able to reach out
to people who aren't fully committed at
a point in time but we can reach out to
them at another point in time and so
Facebook's advertising platform allows
us to do that so it's a great feature
that we could take advantage of that
will talk about more throughout this
session and then it helps increase
Revenue sales and leads and and that's
primarily what most advertisers are
after you know more Revenue more sales
more leads so Facebook allows us to
educate our audience again a targeted
audience about a specific product we
have to offer so the more our audience
knows about our product especially for
their friends and family members and
colleagues are using the product then
the more likely they're going to
purchase so if you go back to the other
feature higher Revenue less spend this
is the primary reason because you have a
chance to influence somebody who's very
targeted who's very active on the
platform and who may have like-minded
people in in their life associating with
your brand and product so it's a perfect
combination for advertising perfect
combination and so today we're going to
talk about all the different types of
Facebook ads and we're going to start
out with the single image ad in the
single image ad or just single image
advertisements that have an optional
text on top and a link description that
links to the website so single image ads
are probably the most popular you can
see them on probably your own Facebook
feed if you look so in fact I'll just
jump over to my Facebook feed right now
and if I go there what do I see I see a
single image ad here and it's from
Shopify Partners so become a Shopify
partner at eCommerce to your list of
qualifications so Shopify must be you
know a brand that is trying to woo my
business okay so they know that somebody
that I'm associated with or maybe I fit
their demographic so they're targeting
my newsfeed with a single image ad so
that's what a single image ad looks like
it's simply just one single image with
some description and the great thing
about this single image if you haven't
noticed is the pixels are pretty large
it's 1200 by 628 so it kind of stands
out a little bit it's not your
traditional thumbnail it really pops
when you look at the news feed so again
if I go back to my news feed here you
can see it just really stands out within
the news feed so I can't miss it if I'm
a targeted part of their targeted
audience it's hard for me to you know
not see this ad interact in some way
especially again if I know somebody in
my network on Facebook or either that be
a friend or family members associated
with that product okay in addition to
the single image ads Facebook also has
multi-product ads or also known as
Carousel ads and so what the carousel
ads do is allow you and carousel form
allow you to rotate different ads with
different messaging and different call
to action and so here you can see simply
learn has a example of a carousel ad
where they're showcasing their different
courses so this allows users to view a
range of all your different products and
services if you have multiple products
and services to offer then the carousel
ads would be a good option for you so in
addition to the Carousel ads and single
image ads it gets a little bit more
sophisticated in terms of Technology
where Facebook allows us to offer up
video ads and so video ads are
interactive it's a good way to really
showcase your product your brand your
service and the great thing about the
video ads is they can go from just a few
seconds all the way up to you know two
minutes or excuse me all the way up to
120 minutes and so you can really really
put lot of time and effort into the
video ads to really put your brand out
there and so the one thing about video
is it is interactive most people engage
with video and they tend to get about 10
to 30 percent more views than other
forms of ads so the video ads are really
a popular way for you as an Advertiser
to put your brand or product out there
so you can put your brand and product
out there and not just a few seconds but
you know really tell a nice complete
story to get the engagement to get the
person to take the action you want them
to do so that's why video ads have
become very popular because they tend to
get more engagement more interaction
than your traditional single image ad or
say your Carousel ad so Facebook also
allows us to advertise something called
lead ads and what lead ads allow us to
do is obtain user details okay so we can
acquire or get an email address or phone
number from somebody whose interest in
our product or service and that person
doesn't even have to leave Facebook so
if you look here on the example here we
have the ad somebody clicks on sign up
and they get this form submission and
the great thing about the lead ad is
that it can sync up with any CRM or most
of your popular crms I should say for
example Salesforce as a good example of
a CRM where somebody fills that out the
information goes directly to Salesforce
and so lead ads are really good if
you're trying to generate you know leads
for your business and the form itself
the interaction stays right in Facebook
and so that's the great thing about it
they don't really have to leave the
platform another form of advertising on
Facebook are slideshows okay so unlike
the carousel ads which rotate and the
carousel ads remember rotate and
showcase different products or Services
these ads are interactive but they're
rotating different imagery so it allows
you to really put your best images out
there with a really strong call to
action just like you see here with the
simply learn example okay so they're
showcasing you know they're different
classes and then they have the get
started today called to action a really
punctuate the slideshow ad so what's
interesting is you can really gauge a
person's interest by throwing different
products or images out there you know
you can really immerse a user's
experience here by showing different
different images and then the last type
of ad on Facebook is called The
Collection ad and so these ads combine
basically your video your slideshow or
your product images taken from your
product catalog okay so if you're an
Advertiser who wants to advertise
several products at once then this could
be a great option option for you the
collection ad so here you can see the
simply learned example here they're
showing you know not only you know some
some good slideshows and imagery with
some good messaging below that so before
we get into the steps for creating an ad
on Facebook let's talk about some of the
important changes that have happened on
Facebook recently in light of data
sharing so really what Facebook's done
is they've made an important change on
how user data is being used for
advertising and so what Facebook's done
is they remove something called a
partner category and that was an ad
targeting program which the targeting
option was based on data provided by a
third-party partner so if you're an
Advertiser and you had a third party
partner that provided some targeted
options to you that was known as a
partner category in in summary Facebook
has removed that program and so now the
only way you can gain user information
is if they provide that voluntary like
the lead ad for example now you have to
get the data directly from the third
party now so you can't have that third
party give you that targeting option
anymore you could certainly again
capture the data Yourself by relying on
leak capture landing pages as an example
or the lead ads and you can certainly
still Outsource your advertising to lead
gen agencies and media buying companies
okay but the partner category has more
or less gone away
okay so now let's get into
how to create a Facebook app so what are
the steps so the first thing you'll have
to do is set up a campaign so when
you're setting up a campaign you have to
select what kind of spending you want to
do for your advertisement and what you
want to achieve okay so you have to in
other words identify the goal okay so
with Facebook you have two opportunities
at hand here you can jump into an
auction just like Google what you're
going to do is your ads going to enter
and into an auction and so this is where
you can decide how you want to spend
your money to achieve your goals by
choosing an appropriate bid strategy for
the auction so in the auction you're
competing with other advertisers another
option is you could do reach and
frequency and so with reach and
frequency you'll be able to advertise to
your Brand's audience with a fixed cost
so reach a frequency allows you as the
advertiser to better predict the
delivery cost and reach of your branding
campaigns so with auction you have more
choice you have flexibility you have
scalability but not a lot of
predictability okay because again you're
going into an option and your auction is
going to be competing against other
advertisers so it's this option is
available to all advertisers and you can
have pricing that you can change during
the auction price process so that's the
unpredictability part is the pricing so
pricing can fluctuate during the auction
because you have different advertisers
who are trying to achieve the most
prominence for their ad with reach and
frequency you'll be able to plan and set
up your campaigns and actually set it up
so it's more predictable on how the
delivery is going to be done with reach
and frequency so more predictability
when reaching frequency because you
could set everything up in your campaign
okay so again with the reach and
frequency you'll be able to advertise
with a fixed cost auction you're not
necessarily going with a fixed cost
you're going with more scalability
flexibility on cost that can change okay
so once you choose your objective for
your advertisement then you need to
choose the type of advertisement you
want to do and it's based on your
objectives so what's your objective is
its awareness to drive awareness is it
to drive consideration or is it to drive
a conversion so these are the three
objectives uh available to you for your
advertising you want to choose one of
those objectives so let's take a look at
each of these objectives available to
you okay so let's start out with
awareness so awareness can help with
creating an interest for your product or
or your service so when we say where is
where they can maybe brand awareness or
product awareness to get out there in
front of people okay so with
consideration it's a little bit
different than awareness but not so
different in that we're really aiming to
get people to think more about our
product and service and have them take
the next step so with awareness you're
introducing your product and service
with consideration you're getting people
to take the next step and start looking
for information about the product or
service you're advertising and then
conversion is kind of that final step if
you're really after a conversion you
really want that person to make the
decision okay so they're either going to
buy or use your product or service okay
and so that's the conversion objective
so you have to choose one of these three
objectives here is it going to be
awareness is it going to be
consideration or is it going to be
conversion and so let's go back to
awareness okay so if we we look at
awareness under awareness we have brand
awareness and we have reach okay so when
we look at Brand awareness really what
we're trying to do is we're trying to
increase awareness about our brand or
the product in our brand so these types
of objectives I mean meaning awareness
don't really emphasize interaction okay
you're not really trying to get somebody
to purchase or or buy something or opt
into a newsletter really your goal as an
Advertiser with brand awareness is to
get your product out there so people are
aware that it exists okay let alone
forget about buying it or opting into a
newsletter you really your goal with
awareness and brand awareness is to get
people to see that you're existing your
product exists your service exists it's
available and really the aim is to
create high brand recall amongst users
rather than focusing on generating
Revenue so when we say you know High
brand recall what we mean is hey if your
brand is out there and you are really
pushing it out there amongst a large
targeted demographic audience then the
next time that audience sees your brand
they're going to be able to associate
with it okay it's not going to be
foreign to them or the first time
they've ever seen it you really want
them to recall hey I know that brand
I've seen that brand before okay that's
kind of the reaction you want to get
from a brand awareness hey that's a cool
looking logo or man that product looked
interesting now I'm going to take the
next step so that's what brand awareness
really needs to do it needs to create
that recall for that for your audience
okay so let's take a look now at reach
so with reach reach ensures that our
advertisement is seen by the maximum
number of people within our target
audience and budget so with reach we're
really trying to reach or get our ad out
there to as many people as possible
given who we're trying to Target and
given the amount of money we have to
spend so it helps to Target a smaller
audience to visit your website watch
your video or even convert on your
website okay so that's with reach we're
just really trying to get it out there
okay so let's move on to consideration
so we talked about awareness we talked
about brand awareness and reach with
consideration we have you know people
who are willing to take that next step
okay so if we're targeting a specific
demographic and we're looking at
consideration we really want them to do
something with our ad we don't want them
just recall it or see it for the first
time we want them to take that next step
and so with consideration we have
traffic so if we have an ad you know the
least we want somebody to do who's seen
our brand before is at least click on
our ad okay so we want people to you
know click on our ad and go to our
website really that's a goal of
consideration is hey I know that brand
I've seen that brand before let me click
on this and see what they have to offer
so this might involve them listening to
a podcast or reading an article or being
introduced to an app so really you're
setting the stage for further down the
funnel by further introducing them to
something that's on your website so you
really want them to take that next baby
step the next baby step is clicking on
the ad going to your site and further
educating themselves about your
particular product or service so
Facebook shows these advertisements to
people within your target audience based
on their past Behavior okay so that's a
great thing about Facebook it's you can
really really get targeted here with
your audience okay so engagement so we
talk about traffic we're going to talk
about engagement so these types of ads
are useful when we want users to engage
more with our ad for example we can you
know really have an advertisement or
post that will allow people to like it
they can respond or even take advantage
of an offer so that's what we mean by
engagement we really want people to
react positively within Facebook about
our ad or our post okay so it can help
with building engagement meant an
engagement audience for your Facebook
page that can be used for future
advertising campaigns so we're really
getting people to take that next step
and what's that next step if they don't
go to our website they can like what we
have to say and then we can have app
installs so that's another option to us
for consideration so app installs are
great if we want to send users to an app
store for example so they can download
our app so if we're really really
pushing an app that we just developed
then an app install could be a good
opportunity under consideration to allow
that user to take that next step and
download your app so that that at a
later stage they can go and interact
with the app we have video views so
video views are are good advertisements
when you're promoting your product or
service and you really want a high
number of views so remember early on we
were talking about the types of ads
available on Facebook we talked about
video views how they get 10 to 30
percent more engagement well that's
really what we want videos to do under
consideration we really want people to
understand what we're trying to do and
really engage with our product and so
they could turn around and like it they
could turn around and um push it out to
their friends so video we know is high
engaging with an audience and so having
a video allows you to really allow that
video to potentially go viral okay so
video views help users engage and
enables the creation of an audience
which can be used for future
advertisements okay so highly engageable
you know interactive allows people to
you know really really take that next
step with your product or service by
really getting to know what you're all
about okay then we have lead generation
so lead generation is interesting
because remember those leads ads we
mentioned in the when we're talking
about the type of ads that Facebook has
to offer well Lee need ads or you know
if you have a lead generation type ad
really what you could do is you can just
collect the information so really
somebody's interest in your product or
service right away then you can generate
a lead ad and allow them to say hey you
know what I'm interested I'm going to
sign up for your newsletter or yes I'm
interested in your product or your
future any future giveaway or promotion
you have to offer here here's my email
address here's my name here's my phone
number so lead ads are great for
consideration because somebody knows
your ad they've likely engaged with you
they like what you have to say and
they're willing to take that next step
and you can integrate your lead ads with
third-party apps that's tied to your CRM
so for example Salesforce lead ads can
sync up right with Salesforce and then
you can then follow up with that user at
a later point so that's consideration so
we have a lot of good options available
to us under consider duration you know
we could drive traffic video views app
installs just regular engagement you
know and then we got Legion so we got a
lot of opportunities for consideration
if you're really trying to Target people
who are already familiar with your brand
or product or service and then last but
certainly not least we have messaging so
with messages you know these ads aim to
convert a user's interest in a product
to a successful sale or conversion so it
targets people who are more likely to
respond through Messenger so Facebook
Messenger is a service that is
integrated nicely in with Facebook and
so with Facebook Messenger you know you
can communicate with that person
directly just through Messenger okay so
it could be a chat bot or it can be a
rep who can act as customer support or
provide more information about the
product or service so you can use
Messenger to your advantage you can talk
right away to somebody who is really
interested in considering your product
or service so this is kind of the
Capstone of consideration because it
takes into account one of Facebook's
most popular features which is Messenger
it allows you as an Advertiser to use
that feature to engage with your
targeted audience directly let's turn
our attention to the last objective
which is conversion so under conversions
we have conversions product catalog
sales and store visits so for
conversions really this is the end of
the funnel this is really the part of
the funnel where we want people to take
action so ads related to the objective
of conversions really aims to increase
you know whatever the goal is of your
website so if it means sign ups or
registrations for your services or sales
or downloads or any desired action on
your website then that's the conversion
okay so that's what we're aiming to
achieve when we are tying our ads to
conversions okay so you have conversions
and you have you know pure product
product catalog sales so for product
catalog sales these could be ads to help
promote your e-commerce store or other
products in your store portfolio you
know so think of Amazon think about all
the products they have on their website
you know they are probably likely going
to choose you know product catalog sales
because it really will help really push
traffic to the store and really get
somebody to convert either in a for a
particular product or get them to look
at other product categories and buy
something there so it really really
product catalog sales are really great
for future campaigns when you're really
looking for sales and then we have store
visits and so store visits really help
direct traffic to your location and
really helps deliver ads based on your
user's current location okay so if we
really want to get somebody to the store
if you have a brick and mortar store for
example then you can use store visits as
your objective under conversions to
really Drive traffic to that location so
that's what store visits are we really
want people to you know take that next
step get to your store and check out
your store and purchase so that's what
store visits are under the conversion
subjective So within each of these
advertisement objectives we can create
split tests also known as a b testing
and the reason why we call it a b
testing because what you're doing is
you're testing one variable from the
other so really you have two
advertisements that really are the same
except the only difference is there's
one thing that's altered from the other
so in this example we have a with one
promotion and then we have B which is
the same audience same everything except
different promotion so you're really
changing one variable when you do a
split test and so that's available to
Facebook just like any other type of
advertising let's say you do you know
search advertising on Google split
testing is available let's say you do
email marketing split testing is
available with subject clients
Facebook's no different it allows split
testing or allows you to use two
versions of the same ad and able to
change one of those parameters so you
can see really what ads performs best
that's the whole idea behind a split
test okay so if it's the original sales
sale of 25 off then hey so be it you
know it works because you tested it
against another variation and then the
great thing about testing it never ends
so if 25 off works over say two thousand
dollars off then you try something else
to see if that will increase sales
that's the whole idea behind testing is
you only want you always want to see
what works okay so really what it comes
down to is it can be really it can be a
promotional offer or it could be
something as simple as changing the call
to action you know a different color on
the call to action it could be anything
you want to test as long as you're able
to you know figure out what works and
then apply what works so you can
continue to improve your advertising
that's really the whole idea behind a b
testing okay so it really is identifying
an element you want to test and then
really once you identify that element
and you test it and you know what wins
then you can move on to other things to
figure out what else works so if you
tested the promotion then go on to the
CTA so you could test things like colors
and call to actions and imaging and
messaging and positioning and you could
play around with your target audience
and test a segment of a Target on ends
against another so there's lots of
things you could test when you a B test
the most important thing to note though
when you a B test is you always want to
keep in mind what metric you want to
measure the test up against so some of
the metrics you could use are
click-through rate which is CTR cost per
click CPC you can use conversion rate
also known as CR or just clicks the
whole idea is when you do a test and
you're testing a promotional offer
you're testing even the call to action
you need to measure that up against a
metric so that metric is what's going to
determine the winner and so it doesn't
have to be overly complicated it could
be as simple as testing you know one
call to action against another and
determining which one gets more clicks
and if one gets more clicks than the
other then hey you know you have a
winner okay let's go through the steps
of creating a new campaign on Facebook
using Facebook's ads manager so you're
going to log into facebook.com ads
manager and you're just going to click
on the create new campaign button and
when you do that you're going to see a
screen that looks just like this and
you're going to go through a series of
steps so as we presented earlier the
first step is always choosing your
objective so we have awareness
consideration and conversion so recall
that awareness was getting your brand
out there to people who never seen your
brand or product or service before so
it's a matter of trying to reach as many
people as you can to get your brand out
there and so you have brand awareness or
you have reach remember one is
controlled one is uncontrolled okay so
reach is a little bit more control
because you can set your budget okay and
you can control your budget a little bit
better so brand awareness is just
getting it out there having Facebook
plop it in front of the Adam front of as
many people as possible with reach you
are trying to maximize how many people
you show your ad to but it is a little
bit more controlled against the budget
okay either way choosing awareness is
going to set the objective of trying to
maximize your exposure for your brand
your product or your service okay if
somebody has already seen your brand or
somebody's already familiar with your
product or your services then you may
want to choose the objective of
consideration and so these are people
who again are already familiar who you
want to take that next step remember
Facebook is an environment where you're
targeting a specific audience so you're
targeting people you know have likely
seen your brand product or service so
you want to take that next step that's
what you want them to do okay so here
under consideration we have traffic
engagement app installs video views lead
gen or messages all all of these choices
are getting somebody to do something for
you for example app installs you want
them to install your app or engagement
you want them to like or share your post
video views watching your video or
messaging you want them to interact with
you via Facebook's messenger feature so
all of these are interactions of some
sort where somebody's taking that next
step they've seen your brand they're
interested but you they're not ready
quite ready to purchase yet okay so
that's what consideration is then you
have conversion this is people in the
funnel who you know or think you know
want to convert and when I say thank you
now meaning you know you're really
targeting people who you've targeted
before who maybe has purchased from you
before or is exactly the type of
audience you're looking to purchase okay
so you have conversions you have catalog
dog sales and you have store traffic
meaning driving foot traffic to a store
okay so these are people further down
the funnel who you don't necessarily
want to take a smaller action like just
share your Facebook post or provide
their email address and name okay so you
want them to purchase so these are the
three marketing objectives you're going
to choose from okay so we're just going
to choose conversions for the sake of
this example and then when we go to
choose conversions remember we can
create a a b split test okay so that's a
choice you should always choose because
you always want to be testing something
okay in this case we might want to test
the ad we might want to test say the
call to action because we're looking for
conversions so it could be as simple as
having one ad with a buy more and the
other AD that says hey check out our
website so you have that option to a b
split test and then you have budget
optimism station which basically allows
you to set your budget evenly across
your different ads okay and so what
Facebook's gonna do is basically make
sure that the best performing ad is
going to be seen more often so that's
budget optimization you're maximizing
your budget towards an ad or ads that
you want to be able to have more control
over in terms of what's working and
what's not working versus not selecting
this option your ads are just going to
randomly show and there's not going to
be any necessary control over how much
spend each ad gets so that's the first
step in creating your campaign it's
always choosing your objective with a
few options built in
so the next step in the process is AD
set okay and as you can see here before
you even get to ad set what uh Facebook
is prompting us to do is look at
basically how the A B test is going to
work so here they're explaining how an A
B split test works okay so basically
what an A B split test does is serve up
50 50. the original versus A variation
of the original okay so that's more or
less how an A B split test works and so
Facebook is doing us some good by
showing us this messaging okay because
that's what we chose now notice we chose
conversions that are objective okay so
what we're going to be required to do is
put a conversion pixel on our website so
that Facebook can actually track
conversions and so what we want people
to do is purchase
and so what we need to do then is add a
Facebook pixel to our website so that
Facebook can actually track how many
people purchase from your campaign so
this is very important and so if you're
driving traffic to your website and you
want them to convert then you need to
make sure all the tracking is in place
so the next step in setting up your ads
is setting up an offer so if you have an
offer that you want to provide go ahead
and select on because the default is set
to off okay what you could do is you can
associate it with your particular
company page
on Facebook and then you're going to
create your offer so I'm going to put my
offer title I'm going to put a little
bit more details in there I can put an
end date when the offer expires in a
specific time so based on what you put
this is what people are going to see
with the ad and here you have the
Redemption section where you can have
people redeem the offer online or online
and in store so if it's online you need
to provide Facebook with a URL where
people can go and redeem that that
promotion that offer and then you have a
chance an opportunity to add a
particular code so you don't necessarily
have to have a code with your offer it
could be a one-time code or it can be a
unique code okay or unique codes okay
and then you have an advanced option
here and this Advanced option is pretty
important because if you're setting up
an offer and you only want a specific
number of people to see that offer then
and you don't want them to to share that
offer then what you could do is hide the
share option so that way people won't be
able to share the promotion with friends
or family or whatnot now they could
still copy and paste the link of the
offer but they won't be able to easily
do it with the share option and here you
can put some terms and conditions so
that's the offer okay and it's pretty
intuitive in the Wizard
my recommendation is you should always
put out an offer to get people to you
know again your objective is to get
people to convert so an offer always
helps incentivize conversions
okay here we have our variable because
we're testing we're split testing okay
so here we're we're choosing what we
want to split test so if we choose
creative basically what we're doing is
we're telling Facebook we want to test
our creative or ADD and so now what
we're going to do is we're going to
select the audience and so we could
choose a custom audience a look-alike or
all so here you can see we have a
look-alike and a look-alike basically is
basically what Facebook does is they're
trying to find people who are very
similar to your customers okay so that's
who you want to Target people who look
like your customers on Facebook okay so
you can choose the look-alike audience
or you could choose a custom audience if
you already have one
so we're going to create a new custom
audience here
and basically what we want them to do is
website traffic
and we're just going to call it website
traffic and basically it's going to be
all website visitors
okay so we're going to create this
audience here
so we've done that and basically now
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to tell Facebook okay if our audience is
all website visitors where there's
visitors going to come from so we want
to choose a location so it could be
everyone in a particular location
everyone who lives in a particular
location or recently in the location or
traveling in a location okay so here you
can see we have it set to United States
but we can always change that so you can
really pick and choose areas or cities
and even exclude areas
you can even upload locations in bulk so
if you have a specific set of locations
you can upload that
after you choose your location you're
then going to choose your age so here
you have if you look all the way down to
13 years of age and then your range goes
all the way up to 65 years of age then
we have our gender we can choose both
men and women or just men and just women
and then we can Target a specific
language if we want to Target Spanish
people or people who speak Spanish then
we can choose Spanish notice we can add
multiple languages
okay so if we want to do some specific
targeting for example we can do interest
or specific behavior so if I click
suggestions then for example Facebook's
going to offer us up some suggestions so
if we want to Target people who have an
interest in foreign language your
charity and causes or mindfulness or it
could be specific job titles okay so we
can get really detailed with our
targeting we also have connections so
who do we want to Target so are these
people who like our page who are friends
of people who like our page we can also
exclude people who like our pitch okay
so remember your advertising is tied to
a Facebook page however you could still
drive that traffic to your website but
what Facebook does is once you connect
your ad or your campaign to a Facebook
page then they have an idea of the
profile then they have an idea of what
type of community do you have on
Facebook okay so that really helps them
offer you more detailed targeting in the
form of connections okay so when we're
done we could save the audience
so I'm just going to name it uh English
and Spanish click save okay now I have
my audience saved and the important
thing here is that this audience is
saved we can use it at a later date or
if we're setting up a new campaign we
can pull from the same audience under
use a saved audience
so if I just type in English in Spanish
you'll see my audience here
okay and we can always edit it if we
need to
okay so next is the placements section
so here placements is where we want to
show our ads okay so we want to be able
to place our ads in the proper placement
and so what Facebook does is they
actually recommend you do an auto
placement and so Facebook Will based on
your audience show your ad in different
spots or different placements throughout
Facebook based on the people you're
trying to Target the audience okay so in
this case we're targeting both Spanish
and English okay and we're targeting 13
to 65 year olds who live in the United
States and so what Facebook's going to
do then because we have automatic
placement set up is they're going to be
able to place our ads based on our
target audience so this is an option I
always recommend you do and Facebook
recommends as well if you're specific
about where you want your ad to be
placed then you can just just select
edit placements and notice when you
select edit placements here you have
different options not only on Facebook
but on Instagram as well okay and
Facebook's Network and in Facebook
Messenger so you have all these
different options available to you if
you really want your your ad placed in a
specific position so here if I just
scroll over here I can see what it looks
like in a feed and stream video I can
scroll down to Instagram that's what it
looks like in a feed on Instagram okay
uh you have Instagram stories if I want
to go and advertise on Facebook
Messenger then I have some options here
in messenger inbox or sponsored messages
okay so you have a lot of options
available under edit placements meaning
picking your placement specifically but
again I recommend as does Facebook just
go with the recommended placements for
now unless you're really clear and you
really understand how Facebook works and
where these placements are actually
going to be but remember if you choose
edit placements and place it in a
specific position let's just say on
messenger inbox remember your audience
may not be there so going with the
automatic placements you know is a way
for Facebook to help you get your ad in
front of the Right audience here the
next section delivery optimization okay
how much of our ads are optimized and
delivered so remember we chose
conversions here so we're going to
optimize our ads for conversions so what
Facebook's going to do is take into
account each conversion that e-chat is
getting and they're going to show that
ad that's getting more conversions more
often than the ads that aren't getting
as many conversions okay so they're
optimizing the ad delivery based on how
many conversions each ad gets and
there's an option in here as well so you
can put a cost control in place so you
have an average cost per purchase okay
so Facebook will aim to get the most
purchases and spend your entire budget
okay if you put in an average cost per
purchase so for example if I'm selling
T-shirts I may not want my average cost
per purchase to be twenty dollars
because I'm not going to make any money
so I'm probably going to choose maybe
two three four even as high as five
dollars on a cost per purchase because I
want to make sure I'm not spending a lot
of money just to get a purchase so you
have that option available to you to put
in as a cost control
and here we have a conversion window and
so with this conversion window is going
to do is you know help Facebook optimize
your ads a little bit better based on
the number of conversions that happen in
this window
okay so you have some other options in
here you want to do standard delivery ad
scheduling you can run your ads on a
schedule or you can run them all the
time okay and then moving down to the
next option in our ad set is we have
split test and split test budget and
schedule so we have the opportunity to
put a budget in place for our ads okay
and we can schedule the the A B test to
start running immediately if we want to
or we can have the A B test run at a
specific date and we can have it run for
a specific period of time so this goes
all the way back to the first option
where we chose a b split test on step
one so we have a series of options
available to us for the split test okay
once we have all our options in place
okay we're going to click continue and
then the final step is actually setting
up up our ads Okay so
what we're going to do is we're going to
name our ad in this case add a okay it's
going to be tied to a Facebook page it's
going to be tied to an Instagram account
and then we can choose the format of our
ad so remember we have a lot of
different options available to us on
Facebook we have the carousel which
allows us to have multiple images
scrolling horizontally we can have that
single image ad we can have a video we
can have a collection of images
so we have a lot of options available to
us
and then what we could do is we can link
up our ad to a specific page okay now
before we do that we want to be able to
upload our images okay so we're going to
manually choose images videos and links
okay
and then we're going to add some text to
support that image okay and so when we
add text in for our ad we have the
option of setting up a headline actually
it's not an option it's actually
mandatory the description is actually
optional okay but my recommendation is
you want to add a headline that's going
to grab attention and you want to add a
description to support that headline so
I always recommend putting in a
description and then once you do that
you're going to add your destination URL
and then you're going to be able to
preview your ad okay so if we have an
image here okay we can just say hey this
come check out our new product and so as
I add
this information I'll be able to view it
on the right side okay so it looks like
Facebook at this point is not able to
view the image but normally you're able
to see a preview in this case it's on
the mobile news feed so if we drop down
we can see desktop right column okay so
we need to really choose our images so
we're going to change an image here
let's see if I can choose another image
okay I'm going to choose an image here
and so now I can see the image
now I could see the headline
um and and then I could see what it
looks like just by changing the
placement okay so if I want to choose
Facebook Stories whoops that's not
available if I go to for example instant
articles okay here I can see what my ad
looks like on instant articles
so it wasn't available on certain
placements because of the type of AD we
chose but the point being when you set
up your ad you choose your image and you
write your headline and put your
destination URL in then you'll be able
to preview it on certain placements
depending on what type of ads you chose
okay once you're set once you're set up
and remember we're setting up a b
testing so that was add one now we want
to test the second ad or the variation
and so basically what we want to do is
choose the same type of format then what
we want to do is pick a variation what
is that variation going to be it could
be maybe just a different headline okay
or it could be a different URL you need
to decide what it is you're going to
test once you decide what you test
you're going to add that to variation B
once you add that the variation B then
you have both ads set up
once you confirm Facebook is going to
confirm for you whether the ads meet
their criteria okay and if it doesn't in
this case you could see we have some
errors then we need to go back and fix
them so I'm going to go back and choose
single image ad okay so now
I could just choose my one image
so I can browse a library of images I
already have
now here's my single image ad I'm going
to add some text in there a website URL
a headline
remember you want it to be catchy okay
you can change the call to action here
okay you can add multiple languages so
you have a lot of options depending on
the type of format you choose
so remember we chose a B test so we're
going to set up both ads add a and add B
okay and when we do that again we can
have Facebook review it once they review
it we they can confirm this you can see
we still have some errors on add a so
let's go ahead and fix that I'm going to
choose single image because that's what
add B is I'm going to browse my library
maybe I'll just test a different image
I'm going to click continue
and so basically keep everything the
same what I'll test is maybe the image
so you have to go into an A B test
knowing what it is you want to test
ahead of time okay once you do that
you're going to go ahead and continue to
add B and then once you do that
um here let's go ahead and fix this
error here
um the link field so let's just go ahead
and put a link in there
continue to add B
once I confirm then I have two ads ready
to go on specific placements or excuse
me automatic placements and this option
is that's the option we chose and
basically the ads are set to
optimization against conversions we have
a set budget and we're going to be able
to then once our ads go live is look at
some reports to see how they're
performing so that's the steps in
setting up a campaign on Facebook you're
choosing your objective okay then you're
setting up your ad set okay and then
once you set up your ad set with your
target audience then you're actually
going through the motions in this case
we set up two ads because we chose a b
testing okay and if you didn't choose a
b testing then you would just choose to
set up the first ad and once you do that
you confirm and voila your campaign is
set up based on these three steps okay
so let's uh review with some do's and
don'ts of Facebook so we mentioned the
types of ad that Facebook has we
mentioned how to set up a Facebook ad
itself and choosing the right objectives
and so some of the dues involved are
what just what I mentioned we always
want to do a b testing on our ads
whether that's again just changing out
the color we're changing out an image
you always want to do a b testing
because Facebook has you know Carousel
ads and because they have you know ads
that can rotate and you can use even
video with your ads you always want to
take advantage of what's given to you
and so Facebook allows you to do it do
it so if you have the opportunity to
have video ad then use the video ad
highly recommend it remember video ads
have higher engagement so definite do is
use engaging videos and imagery so you
don't necessarily have to use a static
ad or image ad you can use the carousel
for example or the presentation mode
where you could show multiple images to
really showcase your product and service
so with all the advertising that you do
you always want to align your messaging
so use a message that will stay with the
audience okay so use something that's
going to be able to trigger remember it
depends on the funnel and where you're
at so if your awareness or consideration
or conversion that has to align with
your messaging so if you're you know
targeting ads you know and you want
people to convert then your message is
going to be as such you're going to talk
to people as if you want them to convert
as if they're ready to convert and you
want to keep your message consistent and
simple so remember the ads are available
to you and you have so many different
features available to you within Those
ads but that doesn't mean you got to
convolute it with messaging so keep your
message cyst consistent and simple if
it's brand awareness you know definitely
keep your message simple so that people
can understand exactly what it is your
product or service is all about then you
want to alter your reach so that the ads
are shown to the appropriate audience
okay so you always want to keep in mind
who you're trying to Target okay so you
don't want to Target somebody who's not
in your demographic so alter your reach
so that the ads are shown to the
appropriate audience remember you have
you know reach available to you and
reach allows you to really pick and
choose exactly who you're targeting to
and how often remember you want to reach
as many people as possible but you don't
want to reach the wrong people some of
the don'ts to stay some things you want
to stay away from is you don't want to
put all your money on one campaign so
you want to separate out your budget
allocate your budget across different
campaigns and I would even take that a
step further and you know put different
types of ads and different campaigns
just to see what works so again it
depends on where you're at in the funnel
if it's is brand awareness okay maybe
create a campaign for that if it's
consideration create a campaign for that
because in consideration you might have
lead ads in there they say with the
awareness campaign you may just have a
single image ad okay just to introduce
your product to somebody with a simple
message so you want to you know
definitely think about how you want to
separate out your campaigns but don't be
afraid to separate your campaigns by the
type of ads don't put too much
information in the ads remember keep it
consistent and keep it simple that's the
best thing I can say and remember a lot
of these ads are image based so images
tell a thousand words they tell a
thousand stories a video will do the job
if you have to say too much so if you're
saying too much think about a video but
if you're using an image let the image
tell the story okay don't forget to
proofread your ads I can't stress that
enough remember if you're an awareness
campaign this is the first time
somebody's seen your product service so
you definitely want to get the messaging
not only correct meaning consistent and
simple but grammatically correct you
don't want to be so active on your
Facebook page so you know when I say be
don't be so active on your Facebook page
really it depends on where you're at
you're trying to introduce a product or
service so that doesn't mean that you
need to go out and tell everybody to
start buying your product remember these
people may not even know who you are
what product and service you offer so
you want to be able to approach your
audience on your Facebook page in a
manner which is suitable for your
audience and then have an image that
doesn't correspond to the product being
advertised so you you want to be able to
you know have an image that does
correspond so if you're targeting a
specific audience with a specific
product then make sure the image on your
Facebook page aligns with that okay
don't be inconsistent don't confuse the
audience you know be consistent with
your imagery as well as your messaging
okay so those are some of the don'ts see
things you want to stay away from when
you're advertising today we're going to
cover a number of tips to help you gain
a better advantage on advertising on
Facebook so let's get right to it with
tip number one and with tip number one
not all advertisements need to sell
something so remember you have different
objectives on Facebook you can advertise
an event you can promote a customer
story you can send traffic to your
website or you can get them to download
an app so it all goes back to your
objective so if we go to Facebook and I
want to create an ad remember my first
option is to create an objective so you
have awareness you have consideration
you have conversion so depending on what
you want somebody to do that's the
objective you're going to choose so just
keep that in mind when you're setting up
your campaign on Facebook you need to
align your object active with what you
want people to do so tip number two we
want to use Facebook Messenger for
advertising so Facebook Messenger is a
feature that can be used with
advertising on Facebook and it's a good
tool it's a good practice because it'll
allow you to as the advertiser to
commute with individuals directly so
it's a feature that you should take
advantage of because it allows you to
quickly engage with your target audience
so that's the beauty of leveraging
Facebook Messenger with your advertising
the communication tools available and
for you to engage with your target
audience so it's great for not only
interacting but taking care of any other
objections that they have as an on as an
audience or prospective client so you
can answer any concerns they have right
away so it's a lot more personal and
interactive than other forms of
advertising because you're directly
communicating with your audience tip
three use video advertise advisements I
can't stress this enough video is very
engaging in fact it's not only engaging
but it's very easy to use so if we go to
Facebook really Facebook is telling us
for video all we need to do is have
basically a phone handy and an app and
just to be able to upload it so with
Facebook video you can really Drive
awareness and you can really Drive sales
I mean you can really make some really
splashy videos on Facebook all you need
is a mobile camera so with Facebook
videos it's really very easy to create
you just gotta be creative that's really
the key to videos you know they're going
to be engaging to the end user say
something do something that's going to
really grab their attention and get them
to do what you want them to do so these
are just some of the examples you can
see on Facebook and you can see how
creative advertisers are getting you
know clear call to action great video or
great imagery good promotional use so
lot you can do with video and really
make it interactive so I can't stress
video enough as an option for Facebook
it really is one of the better features
of Facebook advertising and really very
limited use of resources all you need is
that web camera an app and the ability
to upload that video that's really it
for video advertisements so keep in mind
and the reason why I'm harping on those
video ads is they tend to outperform
your traditional Facebook image ads and
other formats like the carousel or the
presentation mode so there's other types
of formats on Facebook video tends to
give it that extra Edge because it's
very interactive and in the form of
interactivity comes engagement so in
this example you know people are going
to react they're going to comment
they're going to share the video and
that's what you want as an Advertiser
you want to grab as much reach as
possible towards your target audience
and so video will help you do that it'll
help you not only engage with the person
but allow that video to be shared and
expand your reach towards your target
audience so remember video can range
from a few seconds all the way up to 120
minutes so you're really gonna get more
views regardless of how long the video
is because it's just going to be so
interactive so just keep that in mind it
doesn't have to be full on 120 Minutes
it could be you know anywhere from one
to five minutes you know to me that's
probably a good range but just know that
you have that lead way if you wanted to
so remember video ads always perform
better than single image ads or other
type of image ad formats on Facebook and
they also perform better when they have
subtitle support so just keep that in
mind as well because you may have you
know individuals watching the video from
you know different countries speaking
different languages say tip four when
you're placing your advertisement where
you place your advertising and play an
important role in deciding how many
people come across it so Facebook offers
a number of different options to choose
from so remember you got the news feed
you got instant articles right column
you got suggested videos so you got a
lot of options at your disposal there's
lots of other options too so you can
have Facebook actually automatically
place your ads or you can specifically
tell Facebook where you want to place
your ads and that's all part of the
Facebook setup so if we go to Facebook
and then we go to create your campaign
so if we close ad sets here is where
we're going to be able to choose our
placement if we click on choose
placement we'll be able to you know be
able to allow Facebook to place it or we
can edit the placement specifically so
just keep that in mind you have a lot of
different options here again feeds and
stuff articles in-stream videos yeah
ride com you even have Instagram so you
have a lot of options available to you
so my recommendation and Facebook's
recommendation is always go with the
auto placement but you could
specifically choose your placement if
you want to when you're you're setting
up your campaign so start the
advertising on the news feed could be
recommended the news feed is where
you're probably going to get your most
eyeballs most users spend most of their
time there and it has the highest chance
of grabbing their attention so the news
feed could be a good place to start
again you can have it at Auto placement
and your ads may be there as well or you
could specifically choose just the news
feed or other placements so tip four
just be careful where you place your ad
it's really important you want to place
your ad where you're going to get
eyeballs so tip five Facebook ads also
offer you the option to advertise on
Instagram so you have that option
available to you as I mentioned in tip
four you have the option to advertise
through stories Carousel ads photo ads
and video ads so again that's all part
of the ad setup when you go to choose
your placements here you got Instagram
feed you get Instagram stories and again
with both of those placements on
Instagram you can work with several
different type types of ads including
that Carousel ad including that video ad
so just keep that in mind that Instagram
is an option for you take advantage of
it there's a lot more eyeballs on
Instagram these days and it plays off
nicely with what you're trying to do
with Facebook so go ahead and give it a
try Okay so let's take a quick break
from the first few tips we went over and
let's take a look at an ad so it's an ad
break time so let's take a look at this
ad this is by New Scientist and so what
makes this ad so great well there's been
a lot of shakeup in the world today
about fake news you know what is fake
news so new scientists is actually
playing off of that they're mentioning
hey fake news not in our world so
they're actually playing off of that
that term fake news and so that's an
attention grabber so I think that's what
makes this look so good but this is a
single image ad and you can see here
they're promoting this ad with a
promotion so try 12 takes for just 36
Euros okay so they have a promotion in
there so and you notice they the image
of the you know the magazine they're
also displaying that hey you can look at
this digitally on a laptop a tablet or a
mobile phone so you have other options
as well so they show you that in the
image which is placed on the right side
of their messaging so for me this is a
good ad because of the placement of the
image the type of image they're using
the play on fake news and the promotion
that they're offering up so this is
really a good ad it's very eye-catching
and hopefully the promotion is good
enough to get you to sign up okay so tip
number six so tip number six we want to
continuously do a b testing you want to
always have this option going for you
want to be able to test variation a
versus variation B because you want to
be able to find out what works and what
doesn't work with your audience and on
top of that it helps you really put your
best foot forward by showing your best
ad so by doing a b testing you're
getting feedback from the audience and
turning that feedback into positive
returns so you're then turning your ad
that does work well in front of an
audience and you're going to continue to
do that so A B testing is always a good
option so remember when you're setting
up your ad in Facebook go ahead and
choose to have your A B test set up and
when you do that you choose that option
you're going to be able to then go in
and choose what it is you want to test
without a and then with ADD B so you're
going to again align your test with a
Facebook page you're going to choose an
ad format once you choose your ad format
then you're going to be able to go ahead
and you know put your ad in there and
then you're going to choose your call to
action so the whole idea behind an A B
test is you want to be able to find what
it is you want to test is that going to
be the call to action is it going to be
the messaging is it going to be the add
format so there's lots of things you
could test with Facebook on a b testing
so it's all part of the ad setup so
things you can change again are the
color of the elements Imaging text the
call to action the position of the ad
there's lots of things you could test
that's all part of the Facebook setup so
the thing is you want to continuously
test that's the key continuously test
certain elements of an ad so testing can
be done initially on broader elements
and then smaller finer details like
statements in your ad copy so my advice
is when you're actually setting this up
on Facebook you know think ahead think
what it is you want to choose to test my
advice is maybe start out with a call to
action so if you're in Facebook itself
you know you have an opportunity to test
different call to actions try that
that's an easy way to test and then you
know when you test the call to action
once you find out what works and doesn't
work then you can move on to something
more sophisticated like maybe the image
type or maybe trying different types of
imagery or ad types like the carousel
versus single image so start small start
easy and then work your way up tip
number seven so we want to choose an
appropriate call to action in your
advertisements that will attract
potential customers so what do we mean
well you have different call to actions
available to you you want to choose one
that aligns with your ad so for example
to Simply learn ad about hey learn how
SEO Works search engine optimization so
if you're trying to get somebody to you
know learn or take one of your courses
you're not asking them to actually shop
now you really want them to sign up so
that's the key we want them to sign up
so use a call to action that makes sense
tip number eight choose the Right
audience for your advertisement okay so
what do we mean so for this you can
consider you know website visits
interests it all depends on your
objective okay what is it you want
people to do if it's you know cuss
customers in the buying process then
that's our objectives to get conversions
then we want to move somebody over to a
product page and get them to purchase
you know if it's focusing on just
website visits then maybe it's the
objective of consideration maybe you
just want to get people to your website
to learn more about your product so
that's the whole idea behind you know
choosing uh the right you know objective
because you want to align the objective
with your ad okay so tip number nine
create look-alike audiences and I'd like
lookalike audience because what Facebook
does is they create an audience that's
similar to the audience you already
advertising to or customer base you
already have so in other words Facebook
already has an idea of who your audience
is you can also you know provide them
with additional information like an
email list to give them a better sense
of who your audience is and then what
Facebook does is they take that
information and they'll put your ad in
front of it on and message looks just
like the audience you already have
that's why they call it a look-alike
audience so it's a great feature by
Facebook it really allows you to reach a
target audience an audience is very
similar to the audience you currently
have and one example provide Facebook
with an email list with that email list
they're going to be able to map that
email list and be able to identify an
audience that you could Target so that's
the whole idea behind look-alike
audience it's a great feature by
Facebook definitely recommend taking
advantage of that why because it will
increase the number of people who will
find your advertisement relevant
remember you're targeting people who are
similar to your actual audience to your
the people who are already connected
with your brand or already liking your
page so if they're similar to those
people then the chances of them engaging
with you are going to be greater so
look-alike audiences tend to perform
well because you're targeting an
audience that's very similar to your
actual audience tip number 10 so use the
golden Point rule on your ad creative so
what do we mean by Golden Point rule
well let's take this ad here as an
example so what we want to do is we want
to devote the creative into nine equally
sized boxes so what we want to do is
draw two horizontal lines and two
vertical lines just like a tic-tac-toe
box and so ideally what we want to do is
place the main subject of your ad in the
cross sections of the Drawn Lines and so
what that does is encourages the user to
place their focus on those points the
lines are just simply there as a
guidance to help you position your
messaging so that's the golden Point
rule really is we want to be able to
position our messaging accordingly so
time for another ad break so let's take
a look at another ad here on Facebook
and this one's my blue apron and so of
all the tips we've talked about this
particular ad takes into account a lot
of them okay so this is again they're
using multi multiple images in this ad
here so again what they're doing
promotion they're offering up a 30 off
promotion here and what they're asking
you to do is sign up to get that thirty
dollar off so you can see the call to
action we already mentioned that at one
of our tips the call to action matches
the ad so they're asking to sign up
they're using really good imagery here
and they're supporting that with you
know some good copy and text so this is
what makes this ad so good I mean who
doesn't like good looking food or tasty
food and healthy food okay so they're
definitely taking advantage of the
imagery with a promotion and with a good
call to action and so remember we want
to a B test so blue apron is likely
testing this ad so what they could do
with this is test different imagery or
they could test a different promotions
so there's a lot they can do here on the
a b testing side so for me if I were to
test this yeah I would probably be
testing the imageries because we want to
be able to see what images get people to
sign up alternatively we can also test
the offer as well what offer is going to
get somebody to click on that sign up
button so ideally there's a lot to do
here from the A B test standpoint and
the way they've structured this ad it
makes it very easy to test so that's
what makes this ad really good is shows
good imagery has a good promotion and
aligns the CTA tip number 11 so we want
to place the product in the right hand
of your creative so the right side
should contain our product imagery so
why is that why because there's been a
study called the perceived product
heaviness and package evaluation and
that states that depending on where a
product is placed users would react
differently to it and so the study found
that users tend to react more positively
when the product is placed on the right
side of the ad creative so here you can
see countdown of Black Friday this is an
Amazon related ad and you could see the
product is basically a litter box which
is placed on the right side so it's a
Black Friday ad they didn't place the
image on the left side they placed on
the right side because people tend to
react positively when the product image
is on the right side so keep that in
mind when you're placing your imagery
try to place it on the right side tip
number 12 don't use images that have
more than 20 percent text okay so you
want to use images that are clean
remember that blue apron image we looked
at that was a very clean image of food
no text overlaying the image so we want
to try and stay away from images that
have text on the overlay okay so there's
no limit to how much text you can add to
your creative but you know Facebook and
myself recommend hey the Lesser text you
have the more likely it is for your ad
to have its desired impact meaning
somebody's going to click on that ad
okay so keep that in mind let the image
do the talking for you you don't
necessarily need to oh overwhelm the
image with words or messages tip number
13 so we want to use an ad creative
that's attention grabbing and is
relevant for your business so again
going back to that blue apron ad hey who
doesn't like good looking food good
looking healthy food green food well
Switching gears we're looking at a Nike
ad who doesn't like a good looking shoe
here this is a good running shoe and
Nike is definitely taking advantage of
the opportunity to place the shoe
against a nice looking background so
here the image on the left you got a
nice mauve looking color the shoe on the
right on a nice red background to kind
of really play into the color of the
shoe and so that's attention grabbing so
the colors kind of match and go with one
another and it tends to grab your
attention so Nike's doing a good job
here of just not showing an image of a
shoe really what they're doing is put
the shoe is essential focal point and
supporting that with additional color
and they're really putting the messaging
kind of as the background behind the
shoe so they're making it as a tension
grabbing as possible here the Nike's
done a good job with this ad you know me
personally I'm not the biggest Nike fan
when it comes to shoes but hey this ad
definitely grabbed my attention because
now I could see you know this shoe is
really popping to me we don't want to
use clip art in your ad creative okay
and don't use low resolution pixelated
images as well we want to use high
quality imagery so and use images that
are well lit you know natural lighting
always tends to work well as as well so
when you're doing a placement for
product whether that be food or shoe you
can see here in this plated example
they're putting it on the Right image
they're putting it in a natural
environment on a table on a plate with
some paper next to it you know and then
you can see from the one on the left
it's of a person holding a box with the
image of plate it on it and said to me
that's not stock imagery or clip art you
know that's an actual person holding the
product so it's real life you want to
make it as real life as possible and as
clear and quality as possible so when
you create attention grabbing ads you
know show images of people benefiting
from your product instead of just having
the product itself so that's always a
good idea in the case of Coca-Cola you
know these people are enjoying their
bottle of Coca-Cola well going back to
the Nike ad you know they could have had
a person wearing that shoe or you know
running with that shoe that could have
been an alternative for them as well so
the whole idea is just make sure your
ads are attention getting and they grab
your attention and if you're going to
use people make sure the person's
enjoying it just like on the previous
image it's a person holding the Box we
could see she's got a smile on her face
and she is enjoying holding that box so
to me you want to use people with the
images to the best of your ability and
that means use that person who's
enjoying it so that's really going to
put the product in the Forefront okay
tip 14 don't hesitate to experiment with
your advertisements creative or its copy
okay so what do we mean by that really
we want to be refreshing our text we
want to be refreshing our images okay so
if you're going to place an ad on
Facebook don't let that be the only ad
okay if you're using a single image ad
you know feel free to change out that
single image from time to time
especially if a lot of people have seen
that ad so if you're using reach as your
objective and you're trying to reach as
many people as possible just keep in
mind that if that ad is reaching the
same people over and over again it's
going to get stale and you want to be
able to update that ad so feel free to
change out the imagery changing out the
text is just as easy okay so feel free
to play around with the text even if
you're not doing a b testing you can
always he's changed out the text just to
see hey if changing out the text
actually gets you better engagement or
meets your goals tip 15 plan your
campaigns for the holiday season okay so
can't State this enough you know towards
you know October November December there
tends to be a lot of holidays you know
across multiple religions okay so it's
really the time of year where people are
in full ad mode and audiences are in
full watch mode so advertisers are
really pushing ads that time of year
especially Christmas you know and people
are accepting of that because they're
used to it so you want to be able to
plan accordingly so if you're doing your
ads you can easily engage with your
audience if you're aligning your ad with
that time of year so during Christmas
most people are in the mood for shopping
so it's a time of year where you can
really really really take advantage of
increasing your sales and increasing
your conversions so you want to plan
accordingly and so if you're planning
you know months in advance you don't
have to do a full year but you know for
me if I'm thinking I'm going to do a lot
of advertising during the holiday season
I'm probably going to go out maybe once
summer ends probably August beginning of
September beginning of September seasons
change a little I might start thinking
about the holiday season and when you
could plan appropriately you can come
out with really good ads you can think
about what you want to say and so in
this case you know Target this
particular ad is really promoting Black
Friday so Black Friday is the day after
Thanksgiving in the United States and so
here they're letting you know Black
Friday is here and there's deals to be
had so planning in advance gives you an
opportunity to really really tweak your
messaging and come up with some good
creative ideas so let's take another
break and let's look at another good
looking ad this example we're going to
look at at Dell okay so Dell I've seen
their ads all over Facebook they do a
lot of different advertising types
between videos carousels again this is a
single image ad they're really trying to
do is get you over to the storefront so
you can buy one of these good looking
you know Dell computers okay so you know
here again they're promoting their
latest computer the Dell Inspirion 3000
Series All in One desktop so to them
anytime they create a new product
they're going to go ahead and pull out a
new ad for that product and here they're
putting a little bit of a Different
Twist on it if you notice the ad itself
it's just the image of the product
there's really no promotion here they're
letting the product image speak for
itself they're really showing you hey
look how good this computer looks you
know this is our new model and you know
we got a shop now ctas if you're
interested go ahead and click on that
shop now so they're really putting the
effort into the images self you know
they're not offering any promotion you
know no discounts you know what you see
is what you get with the image and you
click on it you're going to go right to
their storefront so Dell does a good job
of really you know cranking out their
new products whenever they go to market
so tip 16. shorten the amount of time
between retargeting your audience so
Target people have visited your website
within the span of a month or two weeks
so retargeting is reaching out to people
who you've already engaged with so if
somebody has seen your ad or somebody's
went to your website somebody's even
purchased from you before you have the
opportunity to reach back out to that
person so how often you reach out to
that person or how long between their
initial engagement and when you retarget
them really does depend on what it is
you're selling so if you're selling a
pair of shoes if you're Nike then
chances are somebody's looking for a
pair of shoes it's not going to be a
long purchase window meaning they're not
going to wait two three months so if I'm
Nike and somebody's seen my ad I'm
probably gonna Target that person in a
short period of time for retargeting so
it really depends on your product but
you don't want to wait too long between
the time they've been initially engaged
and the time you retarget so really
depends on your product you know again
if you're selling merchandise you know
retail it's probably going to be a
smaller time frame if your Dell
computers you know that's a bigger
purchase somebody's going to take their
time so you know you want to Target
people you know for the Dell computer
probably you know over a longer period
of time okay so just keep the product in
mind you don't want to wait too long you
don't want to keep it too short so you
want to find that nice balance of when
you could retarget someone okay tip
number 17 keep altering the hook of your
ad copy what do we mean by altering the
hook so here you can see a couple of
different options option one you know
we're talking about hey if you're
interested invested in getting some dmca
certification you know this is what you
need to do option two a little bit
different of a hook hey start your
journey to get your DMC CA certification
so you know just altering the way you're
trying to talk to somebody is really
what we're after here on tip number 17.
you have an ad especially the text
remember we always want to refresh that
copy but if you're testing it try
different hooks try different ways to
talk to people okay it always works well
when you can have different types of
messaging because people react to
different messaging so an effective
strategy would be to create multiple ads
with different Hooks and see what
performs best so this is an option for a
b testing okay you have an option to add
messaging go ahead and talk one way and
one option and then you know tweak that
messaging tweak that hook a bit in
option b and see what resonates with
people so that's a good option for a b
testing and is always you know look at
the way you're going to try and you know
get somebody to convert tip number 18
okay respond to lead add responses as
soon as possible so remember one of your
ad formats is a lead ad okay so if you
have a lead ad basically what you're
asking somebody to do is add their name
their phone number and their email if
you get that information don't sit on it
react to it just like the messaging the
Facebook Messenger how it's almost
instantaneous think of the lead ads the
same way okay you have somebody who's
engaging with your ad by providing
information you don't want to sit on it
you want to respond as soon as possible
in fact you know when you do engage with
that person let them know you're
available on Facebook Messenger so they
can actually then reach out to you via
Facebook Messenger just to expedite the
communication but when you get that
valuable information from the customer
you know respond as soon as possible
it's good customer service because the
longer you take to respond the less
likely the customer will want to
continue interacting with you so there's
no real good rule of thumb here except
for do it as soon as possible okay tip
number 19 add scarcity to your
advertisements so what do we mean by
that well in this example we could see
the top 100 registrations get free
access so by putting this into your ad
copy we're hoping your prospects are
more inclined to buy your product due to
that there that they're not going to be
one of the first 100 registrations okay
so it allows you to really put some
sense of urgency in the ad to get
somebody to react so that's what we mean
by you know scarcity okay so by doing so
it could affect the long-term
credibility well you know we don't want
to come across as fear-mongering by any
means but hey if your promotion is the
first 100 registrations get free access
then why not you know go ahead and put
it in there some other examples could be
you know only three three days left to
register or first 50 get 50 off for you
know hurry now there's only two days
left so there's other language you can
put to play around with the language but
if you only have certain slots available
or a certain amount of days left there's
nothing wrong with putting that in the
ad copy to get people to react and so
that's the whole idea behind you know
the scarcity is you want to be able to
let people know hey there's a limited
edition going on here if you're
interested go ahead and take advantage
tip number 20 keep track of your ad
relevant scores so your ads do get
scored so the score ranges from one to
ten okay so what that score does is it's
an indicator to signify the quality and
engagement levels so you know if your
score is between one and six then the ad
isn't reaching the relevant audience and
your audience isn't reacting to it
however if your relevant score scores
between seven and ten then your ads are
reaching the appropriate audience and
you're getting a lot of interaction so
keep an eye on that you know the lower
the number that means hey we're not gay
our ads not getting to the Right
audience and if it's not getting into
the Right audience our audience isn't
going to react to it so it all starts
with making sure you're reaching your
audience with your ad when your ad is
reaching your audience and you're doing
a b testing your audience is going to
react to one of those two ads so that's
always going to help your relevant score
so keep an eye on that relevant score
okay so let's take another break here
and let's take a look at an ad here by
Blue Bottle Coffee okay so I'm a big
coffee drinker myself I frequent blue
bottle in San Francisco a lot and so
here this is a nice image a nice
close-up image of coffee and I really
like this notice there's really no call
to action here okay so they're putting
their website URL the domain
bluebottlecoffee.com they're saying hey
we Source great coffees we roast them to
Perfection and get them to you fresh so
I can vouch for that really putting
their brand out there okay so this is
more of a brand awareness type app
that's their objective their objective
is if you're going to drink coffee at
some other location or with some other
brand hey take a look at ours you know
we got good coffee too we roast them
pretty good and and we make sure that
you get them fresh that's what they're
trying to do they're trying to introduce
their brand to you so this is a good
example of a brand awareness ad single
image ad they're definitely making use
of the added the image itself you know
with a nice close-up shot of that
roasted coffee so that's what makes this
ad so special brand awareness you know
the image is telling us hey this coffee
looks pretty pretty good it looks nice
and roasted it looks pretty fresh and
maybe I'll get Blue Bottle Coffee coffee
a try so that's why they're putting
their domain in there okay so it's a
good brand awareness ad and the hope is
to convert some people over to their
brand okay so tip number 21 include
emojis in your ad copy okay so emojis we
know are popular you use them in text
use them on social media I mean there's
hundreds of emojis nowadays that you
could pick and choose from they are
really specific and so here you can see
in the case of Simply learn hey if
you're taking a digital marketing course
for simply learn it doesn't hurt to have
some emojis support that that message so
you always get the thumbs up so get
emoji you know the image of the
graduation you know that's a good Emoji
so you know you always want to align you
know really fun relevant Emojis with
your messaging it kind of just helps it
stick out a bit and people resonate with
Emojis and so it doesn't hurt to add
those emojis in your ad copy and
especially if your competition is not
using emojis you want every Advantage
you can to have your ad stick out so
emojis is a good way to get your ad to
stick out tip number 22 use UTM
parameters to your ad which can feed
into your Google analytics account and
provide tracking information so I can't
stress this enough if you're using
Google analytics to track your campaigns
then you want to use UTM parameters so
what do we mean by UT and parameters
well let me show you an example so all
you need to do is type in UTM tracking
or URL builder in Google and then you're
going to actually get to this page here
so what this does this is a tool to help
you create UTM tracking so if we're
simply learn and we want to advertise
and drive the audience to a specific
page in this case artificial
intelligence master's program page so
this is going to be the URL but we want
to append that URL with some use ATM
tracking parameters our campaign Source
parameter we're going to put Facebook
because that's the source of what we're
advertising the medium in which we're
driving that traffic to the page from
Facebook is CPC which stands for cost
per click and then we're just going to
put campaign name AI engineer to
identify what it is that campaign is
related to so notice that the only
required parameters campaign Source in
this case we're going to put Facebook
but we can also use campaign content if
we want a different shape the different
ads that we have so you can use campaign
content parameter as well you don't have
to the only required parameters campaign
Source my recommendation go all
lowercase okay and then when you're done
you have a URL that you can use in your
advertising so when somebody actually
goes to that URL notice the URL includes
the UTM tracking and then analytics is
going to be able to pick up that
campaign from where Facebook the medium
is going to be CPC and the campaign in
this case is going to be AI engineer and
that's what you're going to look for in
Google analytics so it helps you track
your ads more closely because if you
don't use UTM tracking for example on
Facebook then analytics might you know
interpret that traffic coming from that
ad as you know organic social so we want
to be able to identify specifically the
campaign you're running by putting in
different variables for those parameters
so that's what UTM tracking is you want
to use it for all your Facebook
advertising okay so it really helps you
you know in analytics identify how your
campaign is performing not only is it
driving traffic but is the campaign
converting for you so if you're trying
to get somebody to sign up for a class
then analytics is going to help us
measure those conversions but with UTM
tracking we can bridge the gap between
how many people Facebook delivered or
drove to our site from the ad and how
many of those people actually converting
so UTM parameters help bridge that Gap
tip 23 use exclusion marketing to
improve your Facebook return on
investment by not including people who
have already taken the action desired by
you okay so this is a very key feature
here so if we've already advertised and
people have reacted to our ad and has
subscribed they have subscribed then we
don't want to Target that person again
so that's what exclusion marketing is we
want to be able to you know Target
people that we're really after so if you
know somebody's looked at our ad and did
not convert or did not go to our website
or to not download something or whatever
it is we wanted them to do then those
are the people we wanted to focus in on
okay so in this case exclusion marketing
we're going to exclude people who have
subscribed in this case we're going to
retarget people meaning advertise again
to people who have not subscribed so
that's what the exclusion marketing
feature does it helps you really hone in
on where you're targeting and
retargeting so that way you're not
hitting the same people over again and
that's only going to lead to poor
performance tip 24 track the right
metrics for your business so keep your
eye on important metrics what are those
metrics you know those are going to be
kpis kpis or key performance indicators
and kpis differentiate from metrics
because kpis are related to business
goals so track the right metrics for
your business what are the right metrics
for your business more than likely it's
going to be conversions or conversion
rate but you could be running a brand
awareness campaign just like uh Blue
Bottle Coffee did and so if you're
running a brand awareness campaign then
maybe your kpi or metric is going to be
a click okay or click-through rate how
many people are actually reacting to our
ad okay so you all always want to align
the right metric with your business okay
it's just very important that you're
measuring against the right metric if
you're not then it's going to be
misaligned in terms of how you judge the
campaign performance another set of
metrics could be reach and frequency so
reach and frequency allow us to measure
how many people saw the ad and post
engagement can determine how many users
are reacting to your ads CPC helps us
determine the cost Effectiveness or how
much we're paying for every click you
could see that information in your
Facebook ad manager for example if I go
to Facebook's ads manager here I'm
looking at some some ads that we're
running here what can I see I could see
my reach how many people I'm actually
reaching the frequency in which they're
seeing my ad notice I can see my
relevancy score I can also see my cost
per result I could see the total clicks
so I have a whole set of metrics
available to me really what I want to do
is pick and choose the metrics that are
most important to the ad I'm running
okay so if it's reached am I reaching
the full amount of people possible if
I'm running a brand awareness campaign
or it could be some other metric like
conversion so we want to be able to
align the right metric with the right ad
tip 25 take advantage of Facebook's
location tracking tool for your
advertisements so Facebook allows us to
advertise at up to 25 countries with
different states provinces cities
districts and zip codes so we can really
hone in location wise on where we want
to Target so Facebook allows us to do
that so basically it could be somebody
in a particular area or people who have
been recently been there or traveling to
that location or actually lived there so
really you can hone in on a specific
location based on certain set of
criteria so with this you could take
your marketing to the next level by
approaching your competitors customers
by offering them better discounts so
that's the whole idea targeting your
advertising on a specific location and
then knowing that your competitors are
there you can really put out some really
good ads with some really good offers to
really convert some of those people in
that audience okay let's take a a look
at another ad okay so grammarly this is
an ad that they've put out there and
again you notice there's no real true
call to action associated with a single
image ad here it's all about messaging
here they're saying hey download it free
today okay and so it's a browser
extension that they're promoting and
really they're trying to get you to
identify or identify with this
particular brand that offers a specific
product so they do have a promotion in
there it's brand awareness hey your life
is about to change I mean the messaging
is pretty you know matter of fact
they're trying to get you to hey I need
this in my browser as an extension so
for me this ad is all about the
messaging here okay so with grammarly
you know if you're in Gmail or in word
you're in Outlook they got you covered
by using their browser expansion it's
free and by using it it's going to make
your life a lot easier so for me the ad
works from a messaging standpoint not
really big on the imagery but it's
really about this is who we are and we
can really rock your world if you use
this browser extension so they're really
putting a lot of emphasis on the
messaging so for me anytime somebody
says my life's about to change they've
got my attention we're going to be
talking about what are YouTube channels
how do you set them up how do you
optimize them and how do you subscribe
to them so what's all this about in
YouTube why is YouTube so popular what
makes it so special and why do you need
a YouTube channel well the numbers they
speak for themselves over two and a half
billion people open YouTube at least
once a month that is one third of the
world's population
YouTube generates around 30 billion
dollars of Revenue in 2021 that is 78
million dollars a day these are
extraordinary amounts and this is
primarily advertising Revenue
now 25 of global mobile usage is for
YouTube it's one of the most popular
mobile apps and YouTube is the main
source of video for 78 of its users look
at the younger generation they don't
watch terrestrial TV they watch TV on
YouTube so on the back of this a whole
community of video creators have emerged
people who go on YouTube to present to
share to discuss to debate to invent to
compare and become famous with posting
their videos we call them YouTubers and
I don't have to mention people like
Gangnam Style Justin Bieber Shawn Mendes
Ariana Grande Dua Lipa and what about
brands that made it big on YouTube the
Dollar Shave Club Blendtec with blend
will it blend and it's the YouTube
channel they use as the social platform
for their videos a YouTube channel
serves as the homepage for a user's
account anyone can view YouTube without
having an account however you need to
create a YouTube channel if you plan to
upload videos add comments or make
playlists but more about how to do this
later
businesses can also have for YouTube
channel these channels are different
from the personal channels because they
can have more than one owner of manager
so how do businesses benefit from
YouTube
well posting on YouTube will help people
find you on Google remember Google owns
YouTube by consistently utilizing
YouTube for your business you can
increase your chances of showing up in
the search results and improving your
own rankings
YouTube will also expose you to a huge
Global audience
YouTube is available in over 80
languages and it receives more than 30
million visitors a day who watch nearly
5 billion videos
it's the second biggest search engine
coming only after Google itself and the
YouTube app again as I said earlier is
one of the most popular apps in the
store
YouTube gives you qualified traffic
people on YouTube often have a question
they search for and if your video can
answer the question they have you will
get a qualified lead it's much like
Google search but then it's visual
also video content is 12 times more
likelier to be watched than text to read
video can evoke emotion they can make
you think they can make you feel and if
they make you think and feel you're not
likely to forget those videos and that's
much more that can be said for most
other types of online marketing
video also helped to humanize your brand
they bring it to life taking your
messages from flat and static to Dynamic
and engaging
videos help your brand build trust and
loyalty in a unique way
you can also use YouTube ads to reach an
even bigger audience YouTube advertising
runs on through the Google ads platform
and has some very powerful features and
more about these ads on YouTube later
videos can also be repurposed across
many other channels so they can help you
drive additional traffic to your website
you can share them on your social media
channels you can embed them on your own
website or you can include them in your
email marketing
to summarize video marketing is a must
for your business and if you're not on
the video train you will miss the next
stop
publishing regular videos is key and
YouTube offers you a YouTube channel as
your YouTube homepage for all your
videos so here's a bit more background
information about YouTube YouTube
ecosystem it's important to know that
there are three players in the YouTube
ecosystem
there's you the viewer there's the
content creator or the people that
upload their videos and there are Brands
Brands who want to reach you to sell
their products
and it's YouTube's challenge to keep
everybody happy in this ecosystem to
keep you happy to show you the best
videos keep content creators Happy by
enabling them to make some money and to
keep Brands Happy by connecting them
with the biggest audience possible so
how do Brands connect with you very
simple through advertising
showing your short video as before or
during the videos you watch in fact 84
of YouTube viewers both from Brands
after watching videos or ads they see on
YouTube
and then how do content creators make
money very simple YouTube enables them
to earn ad revenue from ads that run
before or during their videos every time
an ad shows in front of the or during
the video they get a percentage of the
ad revenue and I'm sure you've seen
those ads while you were watching
YouTube videos
but not every YouTube content creator
qualifies for this you need to have at
least 1 000 subscribers to your channel
and a minimum of 4 000 watch hours on
your Channel
in other words
advertising in YouTube is the oil of the
YouTube ecosystem it keeps everybody
happy
and there are a variety of ads
marketeers can choose from many of them
find pre-roll skippable ads the most
effective you know those ads that you
can skip after a few seconds
just a little side note Here YouTube ads
on mobile are the most effective for the
simple reasons but many people watch
videos on their mobile but also many
peoples have ad blockers on their
desktop so your ads will not be seen on
their desktop
YouTube has recognized the power of
mobile video and mobile ads and has
announced that it will share 45 of AD
revenue on YouTube shorts
now what are YouTube Shorts YouTube
shorts are short vertical videos and
they are YouTube's response to the
phenomenal growth of tick tock and
vertical videos are key these days if
you want to boost engagement consider
using vertical videos
and here's why it has a 90 percent
higher completion rate compared to
Vertical videos
about 80 percent of consumers claim that
the format is more engaging and 65
percent of people find Brands using
vertical videos for their advertising to
be more innovative
so enough of the theory let's look at
the YouTube channels and look at what
you need and how to set up a unit your
YouTube channel
first of all you need a kit to make
videos whether it's your computer your
webcam a camera a smartphone and of
course you need a video editing software
and very important you need an indoor or
outdoor environment to make your videos
and then of course you need to make the
video this will be a topic for another
simply learned video in its own right
but here are a few tips
what make people watch videos
people watch videos when they are
educational
informational
entertaining funny controversial or
shocking
lots of examples in these categories of
videos in YouTube now what type of
videos do people like to watch there's a
whole range of different types of videos
but if you want to look at the most
popular ones you talk about unpacking
videos review videos Challenge videos
whole videos parodies covers live videos
how-to videos it's a whole range of
styles of video of topics or video that
you can create whether it's for Consumer
videos or for business videos
now what type of videos can you make
there's a whole range of different types
there's standard format video which is
horizontal there's the vertical video
which I talked about a little earlier
there are stop-motion videos
yeah there are time lapse videos you
could do 360 videos and the big growth
these days is in art is in augmented
reality and virtual reality
yep and then what do you need to think
about when you shoot your video there
are three very important aspects of
making your video think about light
think about sound and think about having
a stable camera position
your light is very important there's no
better light than outdoor light and if
you haven't got out if you don't shoot
outdoor but indoor make sure you have a
good lighting setup
sound can be very deceiving if you're
interviewing somebody on a video outside
you think there is no wind but then when
you hear the video back on your computer
you hear the wind it's it's quite an
interesting phenomenon but it's effect
so best is to have a high quality
microphone that you use when you
interview or when you record your videos
and think about a tripod as well make
sure your camera is in a stable position
so that's the theory behind all this
let's now look at some YouTube channels
and show you how to make a YouTube
channel and here is the simply learn
YouTube channel
a very clear Channel with lots of
content for people to learn about all
topics in
um in technology so here you see the
banner yeah with some good messaging in
there you have your logo here you see
the number of subscribers yep so you see
it's a verified account by YouTube and
here is the Subscribe button yep and
when you are subscribed to a video or to
a channel then you get
um sort of personalized notifications or
you can switch off the notifications but
the beauty about people subscribing to
your channel is that they will receive a
notification when you publish a new
video
then here you have a menu of things that
people can go to there's the home page
for all your videos there is a list of
all your videos you can organize your
videos in playlists you can look at the
comments that you're getting in the
community section you can set up
different channels and you can group
those channels under your account and
here is the about page where you have
about information about the company yep
and this is you can optimize this with
keywords so Google will Index this for
the for the search as well so let's look
at this home page again and the um The
Branding yeah so here you see a feature
video
and there are two elements in this area
that are important here first of all you
saw just when I got on the page before I
subscribed you saw a different video yep
and then when you come back to the page
you can see another video so basically
you have a video that you can put here
for first-time visitors where you can
promote your company or your channel and
then you can have another video set up
for um returning visitors
and then here you have all your videos
and you can organize them in playlists
and in a minute I'm going to show you
how to set this all up and how to create
your own channel
okay so this is simply learn another
example would be one of my favorites on
social media is social media Examiner
here is the social media examiner
YouTube channel
yeah so here you see the the featured
video here you see The Branding very
good branding with strong messages on
there an industry report that people can
download you see here you can put a few
links to your social media or your
website or where people can download for
instance the industry report here you
see The Branding the logo yeah again I
can subscribe to it and then here you
have the descriptions of the video and
the different channels the different
um playlists
okay so then here you have to group the
different channels that they have under
their um their their main channel the
social media Examiner
okay so you see coming back and I see
another video here so finally the other
one I want to show you is GoPro GoPro
they are very active on YouTube very
active on on having videos having videos
from their users from their subscribers
having very clear playlists
yes so
um and this could be a different
playlists from users the different
products features and what what have you
what you also see here is access to the
store
yeah where they sell products and if I
click on this I can then go to the GoPro
website where I can buy this this
product
so this is an overview of the YouTube
channel on the desktop but as we all
know most people and particularly the
younger generation they watch YouTube
videos on their mobile device so
whatever you do and in The Branding as
well on setting it up you need to make
sure that it looks well and it looks
good on the mobile as well so let's look
at these channels on the mobile device
yeah so here you see the mobile you see
exactly the same elements of it you see
your banner you see your uh your your
logo number of subscribers and your
feature video and then you have your
other videos
yeah so it's a lot easier to navigate
through one thing that you need to be
careful of is that the width of the
banner is not as white as the width on
the on the desktop yeah so in your
design you need to take that into
consideration otherwise half of this
text will be chopped off
yep so this is simply learn if we're
going to social media Examiner
yep so here is the social media examiner
page their Channel again the the banner
and you have subscribed yep and then
here you see a different color yeah with
simply learn it was brownish here it was
greenish you cannot change this color
that is something that YouTube will
decide based on the overall color it can
pick it will pick up on your um on your
desktop on your uh on your YouTube
channel
okay so and again remember the banner
how white you go and then the other one
was the GoPro
yep here is the GoPro Channel
same look and feel here it is grayish
yeah with the banner the logo and then
the um the feature video
right time to have a look at how I
create a YouTube channel and how I
optimize it so I can grow my number of
subscribers to my channel
here you see the overall YouTube
interface and it's very important that
you get into YouTube and that you sign
in with your Google account
and once you have your Google account
set up and you're logged into your
Google account you can create a YouTube
channel
so how do you create a YouTube channel
here you see a your user yeah and here
you see your user icon and for me it's
just why I haven't put any visual there
yet yep and if you haven't done anything
on YouTube yet then this is the screen
that you will see yeah here you see the
videos that you can all access the
subscriptions how you can explore and
you can use YouTube without having
uploaded any video yourself or without
having created a channel
if you want to upload a video on YouTube
you click here on the plus
of course everything I'll show you you
can do on the mobile as well but my
experience if you are in admin mode and
you want to add text you want to add
your about you want to make different
selections then it's much easier to work
on the desktop so for demo purposes I'll
be showing it on the desktop okay so if
I click here on my user icon I get to
the menu of things I can do in my
account my Google account and my YouTube
account here you see create a channel
I can also go to YouTube studio and in
YouTube Studio I can edit all my videos
and optimize them I can check with
another I can switch to another account
I can look at my membership my data I
can look at the device theme I'm using
the language the restricted mode whether
you want a certain video should not to
have presented to you your location
keyboard shortcuts
Etc but what we're going to be looking
at is the create a channel
so I'll just click on create a channel
and here I'm going to add my name and my
name is basically I'm going to call it
Mark
tube yeah so my channel is called Mark
Cube I can upload my picture here I can
also do that at a later stage so let's
create the Channel first and then I'll
show you how to do The Branding so we'll
click on create channel
yep and then you will see that your
channel is ready so what I can do now of
course I can upload my first video I'm
not going to do that yet I'm going to go
straight into customize my channel and
then once my channel has been set up
I'll show you how to upload your first
video so here is customizing your
Channel
and there are three elements to it there
is the layout of your channel there is
The Branding of your channel and there
is the basic info of your Channel
yeah so let's look at the branding first
but before yeah remember we had the
video Spotlight which was your featured
video
so here you can specify which two videos
you want to have in the featured section
whether it is the video for people who
haven't subscribed and then the feature
video for the people who come back and
have subscribed and then here you have
your featured sections
remember you can have the videos you can
have different sections that you can add
here like popular uploads live past live
streams upcoming live stream the
playlists subscriptions feature channels
all in the menu that I showed you
earlier but we'll come back to that in a
little bit
yeah here is your menu on the left
which is also important yes so and we'll
come back to that in a minute as well so
first we're going to do is look at the
branding
yeah and here I can add my logo I can
add my banner image and I can add a
video Watermark which is standard
Watermark that will show in all your
videos so very simple we're going to
upload the images so here you see my
I've created these in advance yeah so
here you see my YouTube logo
yep so very simple icon and I can now
select okay what section will I do I
want and make sure it fits within your
image area and you click done and you
have your icon your picture in setup
here you see the banner image you see at
least 2048 by 1152 pixels and six
megabytes or less if I click upload I
then have my banner image I click open
yeah and here remember what you see on
the desktop and what you see on the
mobile so here it is important that you
look at the text that you have on your
banner and make sure that it is viewable
on all devices I'm happy with this so I
click done
I'm not gonna do the watermark and then
I'm going to click publish
yep so the changes have been published
so if I'm now going to look at my
channel
view the channel on YouTube you now see
I have my banner I have my my banner
here I have my logo but of course
there's still a lot I have to do I have
to look at work on the about I have to
add maybe some other items in the menu
and of course I have to upload a video
so let's go back to the customize the
channel and what I'm going to look now
is to the basic info so first of all I
have my description so in the
description I'm going to tell people
what my channel is all about welcome
to my YouTube channel
a place
to learn everything
there is to know
about digital marketing
yeah and I can make this as big as
possible very I have a thousand
characters available and very important
think keywords here yeah if you follow
digital marketing courses keywords are
the Cornerstone of your digital
marketing strategy I can add a language
and here I have my channel URL and I can
change this if I want to
yeah so it's a standard web address for
your channel it includes your unique
Channel ID yeah but you can change this
as well
yeah so I can say here mark
no actually I cannot change this I will
be able I think to change this let's
have a look
customize a customize URL is a shorter
easy to remember URL that you can share
with your audience and where you have
100 or more subscribers you have at
least 30 days old of your channel you
have uploaded your branding as well yeah
so to have
your number to have your customized URL
you need to have these 100 subscribers
and they have a channel that's at least
30 days old so I can't change this right
now and then here you can add the links
remember the links that you see on your
banner you can add a link
yeah so here I can say the link is Mark
kempman or let's say
simply learn
dot com and I can say https
simply
learn.com yeah and I can add a link I
can say
um Facebook
and I can say https
Facebook
.com forward slash simply learn and I'm
going to add Instagram
and I'm going to say https
instagram.com
forward slash simply learn
okay yep and then here I can say which
links do I want to show on the banner
yeah I can add a whole load of links
here but then I can say just show me the
first three links on the banner here's
the contact info that is marked at
simplylearn.com yep so here is my about
section ready and then here I can click
publish
and now I can go back to my channel
and what you see now my channel is ready
we have the banner we have the home uh
the logo and now here you see
simplylearn.com the website the Facebook
and the Instagram it will automatically
pick up the logos from the Facebook and
the Instagram and the other social
networks that you want to add here
all right so the next thing is that we
need to look here at the the topics that
we want here yeah we have Home Videos
playlists channels and about so I can
add multiple channels if I want but
let's go back to customizing
yeah so we've done the layout we've done
we're going to look at the layout now
we've done The Branding we've done the
basic info so here is the channel
trailer we're going to do in a minute
when we've uploaded our first videos so
let's add a section and that would be
the created playlists
yep and we want to add a section let's
say uh popular uploads okay and then I
can say give me the created playlist I
want to the top
yeah I want the uploaded videos and then
I have the shorts and I have the popular
uploads okay and again I'm going to
click publish I'm going back to my
channel
yep so and now you won't see the order
yet because I haven't put in any any
videos of course but you will see as
soon as we start adding videos then you
will can you can see that we um that you
get the order that we've specified
Okay so
finally before we're going to upload the
video when we go into customizing your
channel you need to be aware here of the
features as well yeah the menu items
that you have so here is your channel
dashboard
so in your channel dashboard you see the
videos that you uploaded and it gives
you basic Channel Analytics
yeah and here you have some news from
YouTube about new features new training
Etc
here you see the content so here you see
a list of the videos that you've
uploaded
their feasibility status is there a
restriction on the video what is the
date that you uploaded and you get some
basic analytics fuse comments and likes
okay here are your playlists that you've
created
here you get your basic YouTube channel
Analytics
yeah you're looking at your comments
that you get so here you can sort of
um review the comments you can set some
moderation guidelines here you can also
add subtitles to your videos now we'll
go into that in more detail when we go
into YouTube and uploading videos and
how to optimize your YouTube videos
but Google will automatically subtitle
your videos and you can edit the um the
Subscribe the subtitles that Google will
will do yeah and very important to
remember if you use the Google
subtitles for your video it will not be
indexed for search for the simple reason
that there may be words that Google
misinterpreted in your video so you
always need to edit the video take the
typos the the words that are
misunderstood by Google change those and
then as soon as you then change the
revised version of the subtitles Google
will then index the um the transcribed
file yeah for search
here is copyright information here is
monetization of your videos it's
important we talked about this earlier
yes so remember where you can have
advertising showing before or during
your videos and that is you will have to
become part of the YouTube Partner
program and once you're a member of the
partner program you'll be eligible to
earn money from your videos but you need
to have a minimum of 1 000 subscribers
and a minimum of 4 000 watch hours on
your videos
you need to set up two-step verification
and you need to agree to the community
guidelines
okay here is customization of your
channel yeah we sort of went through
this earlier and then here is a little
nugget in YouTube that not many people
are aware of and that is the audio
library YouTube holds a huge audio
library of tracks and sound files yeah
and sound effects that you can actually
download and add to your videos you can
search the library so it is a huge
library that you can add for free to add
to all your videos
and then finally there is the settings
of your channel so you can specify the
conversion or the currency for your
channel that you'll be using you can
specify the basic info of your channel
yeah you can have the country of
residence in my case we can set that on
the United Kingdom
yep and it can add keywords which is
digital marketing
yeah and I can say social
media and I can say YouTube
Etc
yep there is upload defaults so for
every video that you upload you can
specify a standard element in the title
standard element in the description the
visibility you can specify and public
private or unlisted so prior unlisted
means it will not show in the Google in
the YouTube search results
there is advanced settings that you can
say you can also in your video specify
chapters
and you can spend those chapters will
then be sort of summarized in the
description of your video and that will
be noted in the timeline of your video
as well so it's really good to structure
your videos
there's permissions yeah and this is
where you can invite other people to
make changes or to edit your channel
there is your community that's where you
can set moderation guidelines and then
there are agreements yeah there's the
subject to the the terms of service
okay so those are your settings so very
important that you understand this menu
right so our channel is ready however we
haven't got any video in our Channel yet
so let's go and add a video so here to
add a video we click Plus
okay and we're going to upload the video
or we can also go live
yeah so that's where we're going to do a
live broadcast or a live stream so
upload a video and here I'm going to
draw drag and drop a video or I can
select a file and here is my about us
short infographic
yep so here is the about us infographic
that is the title of course I can make
it as exciting as possible here I can
tell the uh short introduction
to our company
I can select a thumbnail of course I
have it hasn't selected the thumbnail
yet because it is still uploading and
optimizing the video yep you can then
say what playlist do you want it to be
part of what audience yeah there is an
automatic
catch filter is it made for kids or is
it not made for kids so it's like a
business type of theme yeah here is paid
promotion it's the pay promotion in the
video do you want automatic chapters
allow automatic places you can add text
this is all about optimizing your video
and that is for a different video that
we will be talking about how to optimize
your YouTube videos
okay and then it is going okay so that
is all done we're then clicking next
yeah I can say do I want subtitles do I
want to add an end screen do I want to
add cards remember you see that on
videos where at the end of the video you
see two cards where you can click on uh
to go to another video again I'm not
going to do that for this video and I'm
going to click next
yeah there is some copyright checks on
music and then we click next and here is
the video I can then save and publish I
want it to be public I can schedule the
publication yes so but this is all there
is to it and I'm gonna click publish
so I have now published my video I can
share it straight away on social media
again we're not going to do that I'm
just going to click close And now I see
my video in my content list
yeah I see a thumbnail I see the title I
can see the different details and if I
now go back to my channel
I can see my video in my channel but you
see here I have just put it as an upload
because I haven't added any playlists
yet
yeah so I need to go here to my
customize my channel
and I'm going to click first I'm going
to add the channel trailer and the video
I want to add to this is my about us
infographic and people that subscribed
I'm going to give them the same video
I am now going to add a playlist
so here
are my playlists oh I first need to
publish this
yeah there we go I'm now going to go to
my playlists and I'm going to create a
new playlist and that is sort of info
Graphics or let's say video graphics
all right and I'm gonna create my
playlists
okay so now I'm going back to my uh
content
and I'm now going to say go to edit this
video
yeah let's see if the playlists are here
go to the details thumbnail so here I
now in the video details I'm going to my
playlists and I'm going to select the
video graphics playlist done and I'm
going to click save
so now you see if I go back to my
channel
yeah so I'm back to my channel that my
channel now looks slightly different
foreign
I have my presentation my featured
videos
okay and I have my playlists
and I have my uploads
yep so this is how you can build your
channel how you can optimize your
channel add videos to your channel add
playlist to your channel so
I hope that was a um was a simple uh yet
effective overview for you how to set up
your Channel
so
that is it on the channel so let's
finish today's video with giving you
some tips on how to promote your YouTube
channel
it is very important that you promote
your channel for the simple reason you
want to get
subscribers
yep remember your YouTube channel is
your so your YouTube social media
Network it is where you can develop your
brand it is where you can get people
excited it is where you can build
relationships with people who watch your
videos so it's very important that you
do everything that's possible to promote
your uh your YouTube channel so how do
you go about promoting it first of all
very important in video marketing is the
title of your video
yeah you see here the about us
infographics you see that is the title
of this video is pretty boring if you
look at most titles of videos on YouTube
yeah let's see let's say if I search on
YouTube for let's say social media you
immediately see the titles that are
powerful how social media rewires your
brain is social media hurting your
mental health
yeah like selfies and self-promotion the
hidden dangers of social media five
crazy ways social media is changing your
brain right away
yeah you're a bit more neutral but still
powerful how to develop a social media
strategy step by step these are the type
of things that people like to uh to
watch because those titles are very
engaging
you know hand in hand with the title is
also the thumbnail that you're using for
your videos
yeah so here you see a good example 365
days of journaling that's the thumbnail
that they they use yeah if you go to
social media examiner you see good
examples of thumbnails
yeah and they are all they have the same
color style they have the same bold text
bold titles they still show people yeah
so these are very powerful
thumbnails for your video and look at
yourself if you're doing a search on
YouTube yeah what videos will you most
likely watch videos where you like the
title and videos where you like the
thumbnail when they spring out when they
scream out of the search results
okay so very important that you um that
you look at that
okay next thing how do you optimize your
channel is by making sure that your
videos are optimized
yeah so if I go to my videos your videos
and then here you have your video and I
go to edit the details
I can edit the title the description
remember keywords I can edit the
thumbnail I can edit tags yeah I can
edit
um language lots of stuff that you can
optimize about your videos another
important
factor is make videos that your audience
wants to see
understand your audience yeah in digital
marketing terms we advise our clients to
make customer personas
and customer personas you specify their
pains their needs and everything that
is important for them when they buy your
your product yes so by understanding
what your audience wants
you then can tailor the content of your
videos
to their requirements
the next important aspect of your
YouTube channel is engaging with the
community
it has very important that when people
start adding comments in your videos
that you engage with them
yeah that is one place where you sort of
build your your community you engage
with people but you also engage with
YouTubers in your Market
associated with your Market yeah comment
on other people's videos so start
engaging with other content creators in
building your online YouTube reputation
as it were and start sharing your videos
yeah with them so that is an important
one another important aspect of your
channel is that you need to cross
promote your own videos within your
videos yeah so it's very common if I go
to Simply learn yeah I go to their
Channel and I'm sure they have it on one
of their videos if I go to let's say
here
data analytics
yes so it's a long course but if I go to
the end of the video
I'm sure you see that here at the end
yeah so you see here at the end the next
video that they promote so you cross
promote your other videos within your
video that you're showing it's a very
powerful aspect of
um the growing your YouTube channel
cross-promoting your video
yet another one is very powerful it's
what we call video series
yeah they are very good in driving
traffic to your channel yeah why because
people want to if they like it they will
come back for the second episode
or if they jump in for instance for the
first time in the fourth episode if they
see the episode if they like the episode
then they say hey I want to watch
episode one two and three as well so
very important is to create series of
videos a good example is social media
Examiner
yeah when you go to the social media
examiner YouTube page and you go to the
playlists here you see the journey
and the journey is a uh basically a
series of videos
of the history of the company yeah so
you see episode one episode two episode
three yeah they even have multiple
Seasons yeah of this and this was very
successful in their their marketing
promotion yeah so create YouTube series
okay so back to my channel another way
of promoting your channel and promoting
your videos is to make sure that your
videos are outside YouTube as well so if
I click on the video yeah and I click
share instead of just sharing the code
here yeah the the URL I'm actually going
to take the embed code so the embed code
gives you an iframe which will actually
show the video on your website if you
add this iframe code to your web page
yeah and people will watch can watch the
video on your um your website but it
will count as a few on on YouTube
yep and then when people click on
Youtube it'll take them to your channel
where they can
um where they can subscribe to your
Channel
yeah we talked about playlists very
important to promote your Channel
yeah the playlists are important and
make sure you add calls to action to
your video at the end of the video get
people to do something to buy something
or to sign up or to register for an
event going live always works in
promoting your Channel
yeah doing live broadcast live behind
the scenes when you're at an event new
live broadcasts really good way to
promote your channel you can promote the
event you can announce the event it will
lead to buzz before the broadcast during
the broadcast and after the broadcast
yeah we talked about collaboration with
other creators with other brands and
then of course Very powerful you can
actually promote your own ads by
advertising yeah so I can go to Google
ads I can create a video ad and add a
video ad is my short video and then that
video will show before and during
[Music]
um videos that people watch
yep and that will drive views on your
videos and Views obviously will turn
into subscriptions to your channel as
well
and then last but not least of course is
publishing your videos and your YouTube
content on social media channels as well
yeah Twitter of course is a very obvious
place to promote your videos but use it
on on other social channels as well now
Facebook doesn't necessarily like it
when you link to the YouTube video
because Facebook wants you to upload the
whole video yes so then people will stay
within YouTube within Facebook to watch
the video but there are other social
media channels where you can promote
your videos as well
okay well that concludes the session
on your YouTube channels
I hope you liked this yeah so remember a
YouTube channel is your social media
Network for your videos on Google and on
YouTube
yep and it gives you a fantastic tool to
widen your reach to reach a global
audience and to start building
relationships with your subscribers yep
and help them in the process of
familiarizing themselves with your
products or your services ultimately
leading to them in buying your product
of your service how to rank YouTube
videos today so it's simply learn we
take our videos on YouTube very
seriously meaning that when we create
videos we want people to see them
because we know we make good videos and
we know we have good content and we know
that our audience is going to enjoy it
and so we want our audience to see the
videos that we're creating and so we're
going to give you some tips and tricks
and methodology and ideas on how to get
your videos to rank on YouTube so at
simply learn if I go to YouTube and I
just type in machine learning you could
see we're right here is the first
organic video on YouTube for machine
learning if I jump over to Google and I
type in machine learning Basics you can
see where number or number one for
machine learning Basics under videos if
I click on all we're also ranked here as
well under the video section on organic
search results another example data
science for beginners we ranked number
one for that if I look at another
keyword data science interview questions
okay we'll rank number two for that so
we're ranking for a lot of videos and
why are we ranking for a lot of
different content and videos on Google
Search and on YouTube well we put a lot
of work in behind the scenes of creating
the video and that's what we want to
show you so part of that has a lot to do
with you know how our audience engages
and sees our video so for example we're
looking at a the machine learning Basics
video here and we can see that it has
over 221 000 subscribers for this video
234
000 views we've had over 2 000 people
like the video and we have had over 270
plus comment on the video so when we get
our videos to rank then we can see
there's a lot of Engagement and so
that's the whole idea is when you do a
video and you want to show up on YouTube
you want people to enjoy you want people
to share it you want people to like it
you want people to comment on that and
that's part of the whole ecosystem of
YouTube It's you know we're going to
show you behind the scenes of what it
takes to get your videos to rank and
then we're going to show you some of the
metrics involved with some of these
videos to help you stay ranking so
without further Ado let's go into how to
get your videos to rank on YouTube so
we're going to talk about keyword
research for YouTube we're going to talk
about some ways to create high quality
videos so the importance of user
engagement just as I showed you you with
the machine learning Basics video all
the shares all the commenting all the
views and subscriptions then we're going
to get into how to promote your content
and then we're going to just review a
little checklist for you and sum it all
up so let's get started with keyword
research so basically what we want to do
is Center our keywords just like our
website we want to Center our keywords
around or our content around good
keywords so the videos on YouTube are no
different than the web pages on our
website so if we have somebody who
states YouTube is the world's second
most well well-known engine well it is
because it's right behind Google it's
not a search engine per se it's a video
platform but if it was a search engine
it'd probably be second right behind
Google so YouTube is pretty popular
majority people use YouTube search every
day to watch videos on a number of
different topics so they can find these
videos in Google but because YouTube's
so powerful and so popular people go
directly right into YouTube for their
searches and so the whole idea behind
YouTube being the second most well-known
search engine is centered around
keywords so if you have the right
keywords for your video then the chances
of you ranking higher increases on
YouTube so we're gonna share with you a
few easy ways to do keyword research
this is the most important step in
getting your videos to rank on YouTube
just like for those of you who watched
any of the SEO videos we produced it at
simply learn you know that keyword
research is so essential to getting your
web pages to rank on Google well it's no
different keyword research and choosing
the right keywords is just as important
for your videos as is for your web pages
so we're gonna go into a few things to
do here to find the right keywords so we
have the search suggestion you can look
at your competitors we have different
tools we can use so some other factors
involved in Google itself so let's start
talking about some of these ways to
really hone in and do some good research
on your keywords to align them with your
videos first thing is search suggest so
YouTube has a feature called
autocomplete so if you've done any
searches on Google it's very similar if
you're typing something in to YouTube
search then YouTube is going to suggest
other related popular keywords so let's
take a look at that if we go back to
YouTube for a second and I just type in
machine learning YouTube is going to
populate on the autocomplete in the
search bar some other popular keywords
that we can potentially use or in this
case if I Choose You Know machine
learning tutorial I'm going to see a
video about machine learning tutorial so
here you can see Simply Orange ranked
number one for machine learning tutorial
but there are other videos that show up
in my search results so we want to be
able to use the search suggestion box in
the search box field so when we're
typing in something you know YouTube
just like on Google is going to give us
those suggestions so if we're focusing a
video on machine learning then you know
we have some ideas of some other
keywords that we could center around
because these are are popular keywords
these are key words that people are
using to search on YouTube so that's one
suggestion looking at competitors is
another suggestion so we could search
for keywords used by our competitors in
their video title and description so let
me talk a little bit about that what you
want to do is you want to go to that
particular channel of your competitor so
when you go to your particular
competitors YouTube channel you want to
be able to click on the videos tab when
you click on the videos tab then you're
going to sort by most popular and then
what you could do is see a list of
videos and then when you look at a list
of videos you're going to choose a video
and then what you're going to do then is
take a look at the keywords to use than
the title description and then once you
do that you're going to have a list of
keywords that you can use yourself for
that video so for example let's go back
to YouTube so if I go to type in simply
learn here's their Channel page just by
clicking on simply learn I click on
videos ever wonder if there's so now I
can see all the videos ever wonder if
there's an easier way go back so here I
can see all the videos sort by most
popular once they do that then I can
choose a video this is the most popular
video right now for simply learn if I
click on that video it's automatically
going to start playing but what I could
do is simply just look at you know the
content description so just by clicking
show more I can see all the content that
align with this video that's one way to
do it is simply by looking at your
competitors now what you could also do
is look at the tags associated with the
particular video and so what you want to
do is you want to look at the HTML and
so that means looking at the page source
so just like web pages what YouTube does
is they look at meta tags so if you call
from SEO in order to get your pages to
rank you need to have a title tag and a
meta tag description so videos are no
different what we're doing for YouTube
is aligning certain keywords with the
video so if you take a look and do a
search for keywords by viewing the page
Source you're going to see all the
keywords associated with a particular
video so for example if I go back to
YouTube and I look at the page source of
a video Let's just say this video here
Facebook's ad tutorial I'm going to pull
up the page source and all I need to do
is control F and type in keywords and
now for that Facebook video I can see
all the keywords associated with the
video so you can see there's a lot of
different keywords we're aligning with
this video and so why do we want to do
that because we want you know our video
to show up for keywords that people may
type in and so if you use that YouTube
autocomplete it's going to give you
those ideas this most popular keywords
so if they're related align those
keywords with the video so here you can
see Facebook marketing Facebook ad
strategy Facebook ads for beginners so
forth and so on so there's a lot of
keywords we've aligned here with that
particular video and again all you need
to do is look at the page source so
right click in view page Source do a
control F for keywords and you'll be
able to see the keywords aligned so you
could do that for your competitors
videos as well so you can see what
keywords your competitors using for a
video that's most popular for their
Channel and is also ranking on YouTube
and on Google so using the autocomplete
gives you those keyword ideas looking at
your competitors videos also gives you
some other ideas for keywords that you
can align with a video that's relevant
that you want to rank for so let's look
at some other ideas here so you can
install plugins and there are plenty of
plugins available on the Chrome browser
that will help you see the video tags
associated with a particular video so a
couple of examples are vid IQ and
tubebuddy those are extensions that work
in Chrome and what they do is they give
you the exact tags that a particular
video is using so for example if I go
back here and I look at a video on
YouTube let's just say the machine
learning Basics video I have vid IQ
installed on my Chrome browser so just
by clicking on that vid IQ is going to
give me a lot of information about that
video you're just going to give me an
overview of their particular metrics
they're going to give me some other
information associated with Facebook
some engagement metrics really what I'm
interested in is those keywords so if I
scroll down a bit here I can see the
video tags associated with the machine
learning Basics video so vid IQ is
telling me is these keywords are
associated with this video and not only
does it show me what keywords are
associated I can also see where they
rank so for machine learning Basics this
particular video ranks number one if I
go down I could see what is machine
learning and how does it work I can see
it's rank number two here I could see
machine learning algorithms it's ranked
number nine so I can get some ideas of
the types of keywords that are being
used as tags for that video further down
I can also see some Channel tags but
really this is the video tags or the
idea place I want to be able to look to
get an idea of the types of keywords
that are associated with the video that
are also ranking or not ranking so
that's another way for you to really get
an understanding of what keywords to use
at the particular video so autocomplete
you can look at the page source of a
competitors video or you can use a
Chrome extension in this case I'm using
vid IQ to give me some information about
the video tags for a particular video so
according to an industry study using
keywords and video tags will help you
rank well on YouTube so you have to use
keywords and video tags if you want your
video to rank there's been a lot of
studies YouTube is so popular and videos
are so prominent in today's world where
if you have videos and you're going to
upload them to YouTube then associate
the right keywords with those videos so
some important factors when we look at
keywords what we want to do is look at
search volume we want to look at
competition we want to look at relevancy
we want to look at the primary and
secondary keywords that we want to use
so well chosen keywords will help you
rank so we just gave you some ideas on
how to do some keyword research again
those ideas were really to use the
autocomplete on YouTube or Google
they're going to give you some popular
keywords you can look what your
competitors are doing by looking at the
page source and just looking at the
keywords that are aligned with that
video or you can use a third-party
extension in Chrome in my example I use
vid IQ that gave me the keywords
associated with that video so you have
ways to get the keywords so what we want
to do is we want to make sure we choose
keywords with high search volume they're
going to drive more traffic to your
video however we want to balance it out
with keywords that have load difficulty
and are easier to rank for so you don't
want to choose something very broad
that's just going to be very difficult
to rank for and of course we always want
to go with relevancy so if we're talking
about machine learning Basics then we
want to choose keywords associated with
that and that's where that autocomplete
comes in handy because what Google's
going to do and YouTube's going to do is
give us keywords that are very closely
related to the video that we're trying
to optimize for and so we have a number
of different keywords at our disposal
that are relevant that we can look to
see if they have good volume in the
competition and so the whole idea is we
want to choose a keyword that defines
the nature of the content and then what
we want to do is support that with
secondary keywords so we want keywords
that are highly relevant to the primary
keyword so that's the way to go about
aligning your keywords you want keywords
that are high volume low competition or
relevant and you want to choose that one
keyword that is really what the
content's about and then those secondary
keywords that support the primary so if
you have a machine learning video you
could choose your primary keyword as in
this case the machine learning Basics
video so well chosen keywords help you
rank well on YouTube just like the
machine learning Basics so if I go back
to our video our machine learning Basics
video if I just type in machine learning
basics I'll be able to pull it up and so
here it is if I click on it I'm going to
go to YouTube and so here I can see this
keyword we know humans learn from is
well aligned because it's in the title
it's in the copy and it's a line is a
keyword tagged with the video so we know
that that keyword has good volume low
competition is relevant because that's
what the video is about the basics of
machine learning it's an introduction to
machine learning so instead of honing in
on just introduction and machine
learning primary keyword is machine
learning Basics and then we supported
that video with those secondary keywords
what is machine learning because
somebody who doesn't know machine
learning is probably going to type in
that keyword and then introduction to
machine learning is a good secondary
keyword because it's explaining the
basics of what machine learning is all
about so primary keyword machine
learning basic secondary keywords what
is machine learning and introduction to
machine learning so that's the whole
idea behind and choosing keywords you
want that keyword that really is going
to define the content and then support
that with those secondary keywords so
remember when you're performing your
keyword research choose keywords for
your videos that Google shows on the
video results page so what I mean by
that is your video can get more views if
you rank on Google as well so the whole
idea is not necessarily to be found on
YouTube it's also to be found on Google
so if I go back to Google and I just
type in data science for beginners and I
type in videos then you can see we're
ranked number one so even if you're not
looking at the videos clicking on the
videos link on Google search you can
always just when you do a search what
Google's going to do is also put in the
videos here on par as part of the search
results so what they're going to show
you is the top videos that are ranking
for that particular keyword and so we
may not rank overall for data science
for beginners but we're ranked number
one in the videos category and so
somebody's looking for a video that's
important and you can see here that
these first two are ads so what Google
is doing is they're saying hey this is
so relevant this particular video for
the keyword query data science for
beginners that we're going to show it
above the organic listings even though
it's a video so the whole idea is to be
found on YouTube and Google because
you're increasing your visibility you're
increasing your chances of getting found
on both search platforms so according to
backlinko google Ranks videos with
keywords like how to tutorials so you
know a lot of the videos that you find
on YouTube are going to be instructional
based and so what Google's doing is
they're saying hey if somebody types in
how to or tutorial or an introduction to
anything that's going to signal to
Google that it's instructional it's
going to help you rank so when you
search for machine learning tutorial or
how to become a machine learning
engineer you're going to get results
related to that because if you look at
these examples we have machine learning
tutorial in our title or how to become a
machine learning engineer so keep that
in mind if you're creating a video and
it's educational in nature you know use
those key terms like how to and
tutorials in the video title because
that will help you rank so let's move
over now to video title so we want to
use our Target keyword in the title of
the video and again we want to make sure
if it's educational to include that
keyword tutorial or how to so for every
video title YouTube has a limit of 100
characters so we really have to pick and
choose really wisely so if we look at
the video that we were focusing on a
couple of minutes ago so machine
learning Basics here we could see under
100 characters we have machine learning
Basics what is machine learning
introduction machine learning and then
the brand name so that is the title of
this particular video so takes into
account the primary keyword the
secondary keywords and the title and it
also includes that really the key
termite really Google and YouTube like
and that's what is machine learning so
it's helping us Rank by having our
keywords in the title with that key
phrase what is okay so that's a good
tidbit on creating a good video title is
to align it with the right keywords your
primary and your secondary and so we
want to use those catchy words and
numbers to gain High click-through rates
just like you would on the title tag of
your web page we want to do the same
with our video title because the video
titles what's going to show up in search
so if I go back to you know search here
we could see you know data science
tutorial data science for beginners so
we want to make sure in this case you
can see data signs in five minutes so
that that was purposely done so that hey
I don't have time to watch a video I
only have a couple minutes data science
in five minutes okay great I'm gonna
click on the video and now I have an
opportunity to watch something and learn
something under five minutes so choosing
the right words in your video title is
going to help you get that click-through
rate up remember click the rate is
clicks divided by Impressions and an
impression is how many times your video
shows up and the search results on
YouTube or Google so we want to keep our
click-through rate high and in order to
do that we want to be able to write some
really good title tags for our video so
use catchy words like a number or how to
or what is because that's going to
resonate with people when they're
searching now for the description what
we want to do is we want to use the
target word at the beginning of the
description the title and the tags
itself so if I go back to my video here
machine learning Basics we know it's in
the video title and right off the bat if
I look at the description of the video
here I can see this machine learning
Basics video will help you understand
what is machine learning so our primary
keyword is in the first sentence right
in the introductory of the description
and so that's going to bode well for
optimizing our video the description
length is 5 000 characters so we have a
lot of characters to work with so if I
go back to my video I click show more we
have a lot of characters to really
describe what the video is about okay
there's no shortage no shortage of
including keywords into the content so
you have 5 000 characters go ahead and
see if you can work in naturally your
keywords but one of the key tips here is
just make sure that first sentence
starts out with that keyword that's a
good tip of course you always want to
make it sound natural as possible you
don't want to stuff it with keywords at
the same time work them in naturally
work in your keywords naturally and then
include hashtags in your description to
help the audience find your video is
easily so if I go back here you know we
want to be able to include hashtags so
hashtags it's like anything else you
would use on social media it just
signals to the end user hey this is what
the video is all about and if I go ahead
and type in that keyword then it's our
video has a better chance because it's a
line with that hashtag and then there's
Target keywords and LSI keywords latent
semantic indexing keywords we want to be
able to use those keywords as Target
keywords with our video so if you recall
the example I gave a few minutes ago we
used the Facebook ads tutorial as our
example here I could see all the target
keywords associated with that particular
video so don't be afraid to use those
LSI related keywords meaning keywords
that are related to the content use them
as Target keywords with the video so
between your LSI keywords Target
keywords and then using our primary and
secondary keyword in the title tag using
our primary and secondary keyword in the
description and then using hashtags in
the description the combination of all
of that if we chose the right keyword
then we should find that our video will
eventually rank on YouTube so just doing
these small tidbits with our keywords
really help get our video to rank so at
the end of the day we want to be able to
use the tools available to Us YouTube
Itself by looking at our competitors
those extensions like vid IQ the
autocomplete to really find our good
keywords and then incorporating those
keywords into you know the title tag the
description as Target keywords hashtags
we should really be off and running with
our video on YouTube that's our turn our
attention to creating High quality
videos and some of the best practices
around that so along with everything we
mentioned about choosing the right
keywords we always need to keep in mind
that the videos we create need to be of
high quality so the content itself in
addition to the keywords is a primary
factor in ranking so in order to have
keywords we need to have content and in
order to rank we need to have you know
good content so let's talk a little bit
about creating content and what's
involved with that and what we really
mean by high quality videos so if you
have a video content that is not
informative or irrelevant to the topic
it won't rank so that's just common
sense so you need to create content
that's aligned with the topic obviously
and then that way you have keywords that
are aligned with the content so but if
you have content it really isn't aligned
with the topic then you're not going to
rank no matter how much you've optimized
that video so just keep that in mind so
there's a couple of things we want to
look at here so high quality content is
determined by really two metrics so
we're not sure about how good our
content is and how good of high quality
video we created we want to look at
audience retention and user engagement
so audience retention and simply the
percentage length of your video that the
audience has watched It's the percentage
your audience has watched so focusing on
audience retention is important for
people who want their videos to rank
high so if you want to rank you need to
optimize for the keywords but got to
keep in mind content so content is
related to audience retention and user
engagement so audience retention
percentage length your video of your
video that the audience has watched and
for example it can be both absolute in
minutes or percentages so audience
retention can be the average view
duration or percentage of the audience
that watched then we have user
engagement so yours engagement viewers
who are engaged with your content and so
that means they're either sharing it
subscribing commenting or liking so
those are all forms of Engagement so the
percentage of users who watched or how
long they watched versus engagement or
in combination with engagement are two
factors for ranking so let's talk about
some tips for creating high quality
videos so we want to publish longer
videos and so what do we mean behind
longer videos so what's the reason for
longer videos let's just suppose we have
two videos one shorter in length and one
longer in length first video is 15
minutes long the second video is seven
minutes long so on average if viewers
watch about 40 of both videos then video
x which is 15 minutes long will have
more than twice the watch time of the
video that's seven minutes long so
remember duration we want you know
people to watch our videos longer so if
the video is longer in length if it's 40
then it's going to have a longer
audience engagement audience retention
so that's one of the reasons you know
from a metric standpoint so even when
viewers watch you know both videos the
time is going to differ so we want to
take into account longer videos for
primarily that reason is because you
know it gives an end user an opportunity
to watch the video longer and then it's
going to help us rank our videos longer
so when we talk about watch time so if
one video has higher watch time than the
other watch time is just the number of
views times the average view duration so
another tip is we want to plan our video
script so we want to keep the content
organized my recognition is you know
create an outline first and once you
create an outline of how the video is
going to flow then start populating with
content and so to me that's how you can
keep the flow organized okay is really
with an outline starting out with an
on-pound it's no videos are no different
than say a presentation if you've done a
PowerPoint presentation you always want
to start out doing an outline and then
we want to upload a high resolution
videos high resolution we don't want to
create videos that you know are small
resolution like say you know 400 by 400
resolution or something you know
something really small we want to create
something a very high res so according
to back or link Oaks more than 50
percent of videos on the first page of
YouTube are high definition so high
definition videos of higher quality are
going to be shown on the first page of
YouTube more often than not so high
resolution videos organizing the content
publishing longer videos are examples of
creating high quality video we also want
to make sure that content is relevant to
the title so if we're talking about
machine learning based six you know
obviously the content is going to be
about you know intro to machine learning
or what is machine learning and then the
title should reflect that content so
aligning the title sets the expectation
for the end user so when they see a
title what is machine learning then when
they watch the video they're expecting
to learn about machine learning and what
it is so if it meets expectations then
the chances are that person who's
watching the video is going to watch it
longer and that means it's going to
fulfill the viewers requirements and
when you align everything accordingly
keywords titles content then at the end
of the day the user is going to watch it
and the more they watch it the higher
the engagement the higher the engagement
the better chance you have to rank some
other tips that you could use to create
high quality videos so we want to be
able to you know use examples to clarify
our content so you don't be afraid to go
into another screen like I am I want to
I'm talking about videos jump into the
machine learning Basics video which I've
done throughout this session I can
simply do that by keeping the user
engaged here this video is about machine
learning Basics well the titles online
with the video we made sure that we have
a nice description about what the video
is about and we're aligning the
expectations so not only that I'm
showing you example within the video
itself so we want to use examples
throughout your video to keep the user
engaged it will also help clarify what
you're trying to express in the video
itself so we want to make it visually
appealing so visually appealing means
imagery or examples in the video and
then when we talk about imagery you know
you want to use good images in your
video so use public domain sites that
are available to you like Shutterstock
or flat icon I mean there are plenty of
those sites out there so feel free to
use any one of those sites to use high
quality images in your video give more
information to your audience okay giving
maximum relevant information can help
gain more views and so when we talk
about more information again it goes
back to you know the examples you use
there's no should be no shortage of
examples here description use all 5 000
characters at your disposal imagery we
want to build up as much information as
you can in the video itself to keep the
end user the viewer engaged we also want
to create original content so always
create original content you could
certainly get ideas from YouTube if you
want to create a video about machine
learning see what else has already been
done do searches on YouTube itself but
you know when you're going to create a
video yeah you can create another video
about what is machine learning but just
make sure it has your own take on it
you're the subject matter expert when
creating the video create it with your
own original content have high audio
quality and video effects so just like
you see here on this video we have
effects in it and the audio is of high
quality meaning no background noise no
Distortion and we want to be able to
speak clearly in the video so you want
to speak clearly loudly concise just as
I'm trying to do now so that you can
understand what I'm trying to say or
what the viewer is trying to to
understand when they're watching the
video so watching and listening are two
of the components and you want to make
sure both of our high quality avoid
distractions we don't want to pause you
don't want to ramble on a particular
Point too long we want to keep users
engaged so you always want to move from
one point to the other intermix it with
examples those are ways to keep the
users engaged we want to include
transcripts or subtitles for your video
so transcripts is just more content
that's aligned with the video and the
search engines will be able to pick up
that content and help your video rank so
to me that's a key component to creating
a good video is having the necessary
content that go along with the video
that outline I referenced earlier in
terms of organization you always want to
have a Content outline so what topics
are you going to cover in the video
that's why you need the outline to point
that out confirm that before you
actually start creating the video okay
focus on the initial 15 seconds so
that's key you know somebody's going to
click the play button of your video and
if you don't catch them in the first 15
seconds then they're likely going to
pause the video or just go ahead and
close it out altogether so you want to
be able to capture somebody's attention
right off the bat and even before they
click on that play button you want to
make sure again you're exceeding
expectations that title is aligned with
the content so in your first 15 seconds
it basically needs to be catchy but also
setting the expectation of what the user
is expecting so in this example here we
want to pay close attention to the first
15 seconds that's when viewer are most
likely to drop off so we can look at
audience retention in YouTube so use the
options above the graph to view absolute
audience retention or relative audience
retention so audience retention is
basically how many views a video
received and the percentage of the total
number of video views and that includes
every moment of the video as a
percentage so we'll show you an example
of what that looks like so here if we go
to the machine learning Basics video we
can look at the audience retention
report and this is since it's been
uploaded the lifetime audience retention
so here we can see a nice graph the
percentage of people who viewed it and
how long they viewed it so in percentage
so here for example I can see you know
43 44 watch the video for at least two
minutes here I can see
28.6 percent wash it for six minutes
plus so that's the audience retention it
gives us an idea in terms of percentage
how many people or percent millions of
people watch the video at what length so
that's audience retention so we want to
keep that number high at the very
initial stage of the video and we want
to keep it high throughout and that's
why you always want to create high
quality content using those examples
using imagery making it organized
content not pausing you know going from
one point to the other those are all
best practices to keep the viewer
engaged and then we want to add
resources from well-known sites so
throughout this video we've used
backlinko there are other sources we've
used so if you have a source go ahead
and put it in your video to add
credibility and then we want to use
cards to your videos so this cards is
basically a feature that recommends
relevant videos to your audience so in
addition to machine learning Basics
there could be other videos about
machine learning that we can recommend
or you two can recommend to the audience
to set up end screens you want to make
sure that with end screens you can use
relevant video goes to your audience
towards the end of your video so you can
recommend relevant videos towards the
end of your video you can also create
playlists so this is a feature that
keeps your audience engaged with
relevant content by Auto playing the
next video so if you enable this feature
it's going to go from one video to
another pattern interrupts keep the
audience engaged so basically it allows
for your audience to stay within one
video without having any interruptions
involved and so going back to the did
you know audience retention report helps
you analyze how well your videos are
engaging to the audience so what do we
mean by that well if I go back again to
my audience retention report how
engaging was it well I could see 42
percent 43 percent watched it on average
of 3 minutes and 21 seconds so to me
that's pretty good of course we always
want a hundred percent of the video the
video is seven minutes long if almost
half of our audience saw over half of
the video then I would say that's pretty
good people were engaged so audience
retention just is a good report to start
looking at to help you understand how
engaging is my video and if your video
is not engaging you know you can always
go back and edit it or fix it or tweak
it so remember the average view duration
for all videos and top performing videos
listed by all time we can look at that
information as well in addition we can
look at demographics so we can get an
overview of the age gender and location
and we can look at playback locations
report and what the playback locations
report does is it helps us determine the
platforms where our videos are being
streamed from within YouTube look at the
traffic sources where did the viewers
come from devices did they look on
mobile or tablet and so if there's any
doubts you know if you have any
questions please drop a comment below
but especially if you have any doubts on
the metrics so if we go back into
YouTube we can look at analytics and if
we're looking at analytics we can see
more and then this is going to show us
everything we need to see from device
type so if I click on more I can see my
playback location so this will show me
where the video is watched it was on a
watch page or a channel page I could see
the traffic sources I could see the
gender and age so if I click on the
viewer age report I can see the
percentage of views by age so I can get
a lot of information
about my video and how it's performed
who's watched it what they've done with
it where they come from all the
information they need to know and so
it's all within YouTube analytics so
again if you have any questions about
that you know just drop a comment below
especially if you're new to YouTube you
may have some questions but just know
that every video you publish to YouTube
high quality align with your keywords
you're going to be able to view the
metrics by looking at YouTube analytics
so let's talk about the importance of
user engagement so engagement is as we
mentioned important because basically we
can't rank without engagement our videos
won't rank unless we have engagement so
that's why it's important so engagement
is somebody liking the video commenting
sharing it or subscribing each one of
these is important to ranking so yes you
need to line keywords yes you need to
have high quality content so when you do
both of those and you upload your video
then it's up to the viewer and so the
hard work that you put out for the video
is hopefully going to pay dividends with
engagement so you want people to do one
of these four okay so let's talk about
what that means so how do I get
engagement so we already talked about
creating engaging content so there are a
lot of tips to creating engaging content
and so according to wordstream if your
content is entertaining the than over
three quarters of the users are going to
share it so that's part of keeping uh
users engaged is keeping it entertaining
is part of getting a high quality video
so remember on that high quality video
when we say entertaining the audio
portion has a lot to do with it examples
has a lot to do with it quality of the
video itself has a lot to do with it so
there's a lot of components so all those
components on a high quality video are
going to lead to engagement so parts of
what you could do in your videos is
conduct a quiz so meaning the quiz
itself is a way to keep people engaged
in your video so that also help you get
some more comments so according to
backlinku video comments help and rank
in your video higher so just as I
mentioned the last segment about YouTube
analytics and all the different reports
available on YouTube hey if you have
questions in those just go ahead and add
a comment so that's a way to entice your
users or your viewers to add comments is
if they have questions because you know
with videos you're not going to be able
to cover every detail or every minute
detail about a particular topic you can
only cover in some cases the topic at a
high level so users are going to have
comments or questions naturally and so
the comments section is a good way to
remind viewers hey if you have a
question or comment go ahead and put in
the comment section because that will
lend to engagement as well so we want to
add sources from high quality websites
that'll help with engagement okay use
humor in your video we want to be able
to basically you know make it human
based we don't want to be robots so we
want to be able to sound like you know
we know what we're talking about but at
the same time talk to the viewer not
necessarily at the viewer or looking the
other way and just going through the
motions so adding humor adding
personality to never hearts at the end
of the day we are all human adding that
clear call to action at the end of the
video will also lead to engagement so if
we win the video with hey leave your
comments on this video or hey feel free
to share this video with colleagues who
are interested then that's a call to
action that's likely going to lead to
more engagement reply to your comments
as well so if you have comments we
always want to reply to them likely
those comments are going to be questions
because again as I mentioned even in
this video about how to rank your videos
on YouTube okay there's a lot of
information and a lot of information
sometimes doesn't get covered in its
entirety and so we want to make sure
that if we miss something because we're
only human that we're able to respond in
the form of an answer to a question that
somebody leaves in the comments section
so more comments also lead to higher
rankings because it's engagement so when
you're getting high engagement and your
video starts to rank well you know
you're going to start feeling really
good and what is that gonna do look at
that feel good is going to lead to
confidence which in turn is going to
probably lead to more videos and that's
exactly what we do at simply learn I
mean we're in the education business but
we're in it to not only educate but
making sure that our videos are shown to
as many people as possible so that we
can educate as many people as possible
so it's all it's contagious so getting
ranked feels good and then once you get
ranked then you know you probably have
good engagement okay let's talk about
how to promote your content so once
you've done all the hard work getting
your video done high quality content
optimized with keywords and then publish
to YouTube we want to let everybody in
the world know about it right so we want
to promote it we've done all the work we
want to promote it now so is it
necessary to promote it I would say yes
because once your video is published you
want to reach out you want to reach out
to your audience not necessarily on
YouTube but on different platforms so if
you're are active on Facebook or Twitter
that's an opportunity for you to post or
tweet something about the new video so
when we say different platforms I am
talking about you know social media
platforms so it depends on what you're
active on so if you're active on
Facebook yeah go ahead and post some of
you're active on Twitter go ahead and
tweet something it could be you know on
LinkedIn group if you're part of a
LinkedIn group about you know machine
learning then go ahead and post
something to that group to promote the
video so that's going to help Drive
traffic to the video and then help with
engagement so we want to engage with our
audience on those social media sites so
it really depends on what you're active
on so if you have a large following on
Twitter then go ahead and you know share
that YouTube video link on Twitter with
the Tweet that's going to drive traffic
from Twitter to YouTube Remember You
know you're going to be able to see
audience engagement or retention by
getting people to watch the video so
you're going to be able to to see right
away by promoting the video and driving
traffic to the video how engaging it is
remember the more people you have
watched the video the more engaging it
becomes the better it's going to rain so
it's an ecosystem and promoting your
content is part of that ecosystem so it
all starts with social media if you're
active on whatever platform that is go
ahead and promote it so you can also
look at you know content based social
media sites or social media content
based platforms like Reddit or Flickr
for example so you can participate in a
forum discussion on Reddit so in this
example here it's about machine learning
so we want to be able to post something
about machine learning with the link to
our video so we can also go to
content-based sites that are q a uh
related like quora for example Cora is a
really good site where you know if you
go there post information about machine
learning or the basics of machine
learning with the link back to the video
oh it's going to help because not only
is it going to drive traffic but it's
going to signal to Google hey you get a
lot of traffic coming from Cora this is
going to bode well for this video in
terms of ranking so here's an example
you know if you find a question that you
can post on core then you're gonna get
people to click on your video and
respond accordingly on quora or you can
act as the person responding to a
question that's already there so
somebody already asked a question about
what is machine learning you can respond
with your video as the answer so you can
just simply embed your video URL as part
of your answer that'll help Drive
traffic so you can also create your own
blog and embed your video so in the case
of machine learning here we have an
example machine learning what is it and
why it matters so this goes nicely with
the video so here you can see the person
the author of this blog went ahead and
embedded the relevant video in the blog
post so they play off one another nicely
you can also opt opt-in for influencer
marketing meaning hey you can reach out
to somebody in this example here you
know Katie nuggets posted information
about machine learning so in this case
why choose machine learning as a career
well they get information and then what
do they do they went ahead and embedded
the video about machine learning Basics
and so working with you know influencers
in a particular category or topic will
help Drive traffic to the video you can
also create a YouTube playlist so
playlists tend to rank high in YouTube
searches so if you find yourself doing a
lot of videos we'll go ahead and you
know go to your channel and simply on
your channel you can go ahead and create
playlists so when you create playlists
basically what you're doing is you're
organizing the content into different
playlists no different than say the
music you have set up on your you know
your iPhone or iPad or or iPod whatever
it is you're using so you're just
creating different videos in a
particular category and it YouTube likes
it it's organized it's going to help you
get your videos found quicker and easier
on YouTube Itself by putting your videos
in a playlist so here you could see we
have entire playlist on machine learning
trending Technologies cloud computing
Big Data digital marketing project
management so a lot of different
playlists very organized if somebody
goes to the channel they're going to be
able to go to the playlist that's
interesting to them and see all the
videos there so it allows not only the
end user to find what they're looking
for but it's good for YouTube because
YouTube likes those playlists so we want
to engage our Audience by posting your
video link on a community page so you
could do that within YouTube and you can
prefer to link your YouTube channel in
your email so you can also do that so
for example if I go back to YouTube and
I'm looking at a YouTube video you know
I can always Click Share so here I'm
gonna get a particular URL that's
associated with a video and I can just
embed that so I can embed the whole
thing in my email I can embed it on a
web page or a blog post so just by
clicking share I can also immediately
share it onto the social media platforms
that we mentioned Facebook LinkedIn
Reddit okay Tumblr so there's a lot of
ways to embed the video not just not a
blog post or influencer blog posts but
in our email and on social media as well
so here's an example of what we can do
with the YouTube discussion so we can
also bookmark the video on a popular
bookmarking site you know like stumbled
upon or Reddit or you know there's lots
of other ones out there so there's
plenty of sites that you'll be able to
go to and bookmark that content so that
people can find it and you can always
opt for backlinks so that means that hey
if there's a blogger out there that
blogs about machine learning you can
always you know ask that blogger to
create a link back to the video and you
could reciprocate do the same thing so
that helps increase the authority of the
video so a lot of things you could do to
promote your video so let's do a quick
review on everything we talked about in
terms of ranking your video on YouTube
it all starts with the keywords so we
want to identify a list of keywords that
are relevant to the video so we can use
tools to choose our keywords but
remember we want to choose keywords that
have high volume and low competition and
so where can we go to choose those
keywords well we can use the
autocomplete on YouTube we could check
out our own competitors videos or you
know we could use vid IQ or tubebuddy or
any of these extensions in Chrome to
help us look at the keywords that are
tagged with a particular video so
remember we want to have a primary
keyword that's aligned with the content
then we want to choose LSI keywords as
our secondary keyword or keywords that
are related to the primary keyword so we
want to create high retention videos
meaning that first 15 seconds of the
most important but throughout the video
we want to use examples we want to keep
it interacting by adding quizzes imagery
good audio good video quality so we want
to focus on the user experience and we
also want to optimize our video content
what does that mean well those keywords
that we chose we want to use them in the
title we want to use them in the
description we want to use them as
hashtags we want to use them and tag
them with the video themselves so we can
add keywords to our meta tag okay we
don't want to overdo it but we want to
add a handful of keywords that is are
associated with the video so we want to
be able to write eye catchy video titled
and descriptions so remember use some of
those key phrases like a number or a
question like what is machine learning
so we want to use relevant meta tags for
the videos and we want to use popular
YouTube tags so we want to be able to
tag our videos appropriately to watch
the length of your meta tags so there
are links involved remember keywords at
the beginning of the title Target
keywords in the title description and
tags we want to use interesting
thumbnails to increase our click-through
rate ensure that thumbnails are relevant
meaning when I say thumbnails I mean the
actual title tag itself or The Meta
description we want to use hi-res videos
we want to create you know videos with
good high audio quality don't be afraid
to put in video effects like some
animation don't be afraid to use
examples and then you know obviously
look at the draft of the video before
you publish it so does your video follow
an outline is it organized so these are
all the things to take into account and
there's there's plenty more you can do
you know you remember once you create
and optimize that video you want to
promote it you want to make sure that
you're sharing it on social media uh you
create a complimentary blog you know
generate backlinks from say other blog
posts so there are lots of things you
can do to promote your video so before
you promote it you want to organize the
content create good quality content
align it with keywords once you publish
it you know keep organizing it by
creating those playlists and then reach
out on social reach out on different
communities related to the topic and all
those things combined will help you to
get your YouTube video ranked today
we're going to talk about how to
increase YouTube subscribers so with
YouTube It's All About subscribers the
number of subscribers you have on
YouTube it's just one of the key metrics
to measure success so gaining more
subscribers can help you achieve more
view counts on your YouTube video so
it's all about how to get subscribers
and today we're going to talk about how
to get more subscribers and before we
begin let's just show you what we did at
simply learn so if we look at the past
360 55 days on our YouTube channel you
can see we started here back in uh if we
look back at March 9 2018 we had 208 and
you can see just over the course of the
year it kept creeping up creeping up
creeping up and creeping up we've gained
you know a significant number of
subscribers over the last year and
what's our secret well it's posting
videos so you can see we've posted a
number of videos over the course of the
year and then our subscribers have gone
basically 165 percent over the last year
so you can see it's part of it is about
posting videos because when you post
videos you have people who can watch
those videos when you have people watch
those videos you can have engagement and
then when you have engagement you have
shares and people who like it and then
other people will see it so it's kind of
a halo effect so to speak so getting
subscribers it takes a lot more than
just posting videos and today we're
going to talk about some tips to help
you increase the subscriptions so let's
start out with some of those tips we're
going to start with creating engagement
and informative content so engaging in a
formative content that's where we're
going to start talking today about how
to increase subscriptions then we're
going to talk about publishing videos
frequently so simply learn you could see
the past 365 days we were consistent in
publishing videos consistently
throughout the month and the weeks so
another tip we're going to talk about is
how to optimize your YouTube videos so
there's a lot that goes into
optimization but this is a key key tip
to pay attention to because when it
comes to posting publishing videos on
YouTube you need to align certain things
like keywords and content and metadata
so optimize our videos we're going to
talk a lot about that then we're going
to talk about optimizing the YouTube
channel so there's some tips and tricks
here you want to do to optimize your
YouTube channel producing high quality
videos we're going to talk about that
adding a subscriber Watermark to your
videos okay that's another tip we're
going to mention today engage with our
audience okay that's what we want to do
we want to engage with our audience
that's a really key tip we're saving the
best for last promote your videos and
different platforms so all of these tips
we're going to talk about today so let's
get started and talk about create
engaging informative content so that's
the first place we want to start okay so
create engaging and informative content
so if we want to gain more subscribers
on our Channel we have to create highly
engaging and informative content why
because not our audience is not going to
pay attention and they're not going to
watch the video and then the
engagement's not going to be high and
they're not going to share the video and
they're not going to tell their friends
or like it and so this is where it all
starts you have to be able to plan your
content and not only planning your
content but you gotta create it so it's
engaging and informative so how do you
do that well let's talk about that so
the first thing is you have to know your
audience Okay so so when you create a
video who you're creating the video for
I mean that's where it all starts so
when you're creating your content you're
creating your content for your audience
you're not creating it for the entire
world now we know on YouTube there's a
lot of cute videos about kittens and
jokes and you know people playing games
and you know everybody likes positive
things on YouTube but you know when
we're talking about a specific topic you
know we really have to hone in on a
target audience and so if you know who
your audience is then you can really
hone in on your content okay so that's
the first thing ask yourself who is your
audience and then build your content
around that specific audience don't
build it just for the Mass general
population because it's not going to be
engaging and informative so that's the
first place to start then you want to
engage that audience with relevant
content so if you know your audience and
depending on the topic you want to make
sure that whatever the topic is the
content matches the topic don't there
off course if you Veer off course you're
not going to engage your viewers your
viewers are coming to watch the video
for specific reason the reason is the
topic okay so if they're your target
audience and they want to watch the
video that's a specific topic then the
content has to align so plan your video
script so if you know who your audience
is and you know you want to engage them
with relevant content go ahead and plan
the script out so what I normally do is
you know have an outline and then once I
have the outline then I go ahead and
create my slides if I will or my topics
points I want to talk about and then I
write out those points I want to make
sure I get all my points in and that's
what you should be doing you want to
plan it ahead of time so that you can
get all your relevant points across
that's what makes a video informative
okay you want to ensure to give maximum
information to your audience so the key
here is maximum information so you don't
want to overload the audience but then
again you want to cut out information so
you want to make sure that when you're
planning your script and you're writing
the outline that you're making sure you
include all your points that you want to
get across once you include those points
then go ahead and you know write your
script and make sure all the information
for all those points are in the script
that's how you're going to ensure you
give maximum information but you don't
want to overdo it so if you feel like
it's too much information it probably is
too much information back off a little
use the information to create another
video so it's all about knowing your
audience so all of these points play
against one another so be clear and use
more examples in your content just like
we're doing here okay just like at the
beginning of the session I showed you an
example of Simply learn subscribers over
the past 365 days and so that's what we
want to do we want to be clear but use
examples to punctuate the content or the
point we're trying to get across so we
won't include sources from high quality
sites so if you're going to use examples
make sure they're from relevant High
quality sites when I make high quality
meaning does your audience know who that
source is or that site if it's really
specific and your audience may not know
then it's probably not high quality so
just keep that in mind always play to
your audience so you want to start your
video with an interesting hook so again
I get it back to this example if you're
still watching this then the hook worked
we showed you our subscriptions we
showed you how we grew over the course
of a year you could see our growth and
part of it was posting a lot of videos
with relevant and informative content
and so you see how we did it so you're
paying attention you want to know how to
do it and so part of what we did is
exactly what I'm telling you now we know
who our audience is we plan out our
scripts we use good examples and we
start our videos with interesting hooks
now when we do our videos we also create
original content so that goes back to
planning your script okay you always
want to you know come across as original
and informative when you do do that
you're going to be engaging but if
you're leveraging somebody else's
content then the engaging part may not
resonate because it's not your content
to begin with so always always always
use original content okay so keep the
content flow organized so again that
goes back to an outline you know feel
free to change up the outline so the
flow makes sense add visuals to your
content and make it appealing always
include images to me if you can use
images in your videos and play off the
video or the images then it's just gonna
flow and make it a little bit more
engaging and appealing meaning the
content so visuals help guide and Aid in
the points you're trying to make so
don't make it so text Heavy you know
accentuate it balance it with some
images use Simple language and crisp
sentences meaning don't choose jargon
don't come across and talk above your
audience you always want to talk to your
audience and talk in a language that
they're going to understand so it goes
back to point one if you know who you're
audience is you're talking to them as if
they're right in front of you and not
you're above them or they're below you
you want to talk at them so add cards
and screens and pattern interrupts to
engage your audience and so YouTube
cards or just interactive panels that
slide in and out when a video is playing
so it encourages interaction by the
viewer okay so you can add up to five
cards which include images text or
clickable links so feel free to play
around with some of these features that
YouTube has to offer to make your
content more engaging so tip two publish
videos frequently so creating and
uploading videos consistently will help
you increase your YouTube subscribers so
suppose you haven't published videos
from more than say a month or two months
it's likely that that audience not going
to subscribe to your channel so think
about YouTube videos as a popular TV
program that comes on once a week when a
new episode comes on on based on the
regular schedule it's consistency and
that consistency is what helps your
users stay engaged so for example if I
go back to our YouTube channel you know
what helped us gain subscribers was our
consistency in publishing videos you
could see we were persistent in
publishing a couple of videos a week
every couple of weeks and so this helps
users stay engaged they know when the
video is coming out they know that
simply learn is good for two three four
videos a month and the great thing about
publishing videos is that when somebody
does subscribe to your channel they're
gonna get a notification or YouTube has
an option where they can get a
notification via email so I subscribe to
Simply learns Channel I subscribe to
other channels like Google analytics for
example so anytime Google analytics
publishes a video I get an email that
says Hey Google analytics YouTube
channel just published a video and the
great thing is I'm checking my email and
I'm getting this notification in Gmail
so guess what I can watch the video
right then and there just by clicking on
the link in the email I don't even have
to go to the channel but knowing that if
you publish consistently and somebody
does get the email once a week then it's
more likely they're going to engage
especially if the content is original
engaging and informative so frequent
video publishing equals more
subscriptions so according to Social
Media examiner YouTube channels that
publish videos more than once a week are
performing much better so if you can
afford to publish more videos more than
once a week the chances of you gaining
subscribers quicker are going to be
greater so keeping a fixed frequency can
help you quickly gain more subscribers
posting videos is like almost like
blogging I always say start small if you
could do one blog post a month and then
once you get in a routine then you can
ramp up the frequency so from one blog
post you could do two a month then four
times a month and once a week or twice a
week week same with the YouTube videos
you want to get into a rhythm you know
start with once a month and ramp it up
okay you'll find that the more you ramp
it up the more subscribers you're gonna
get so tip three optimize your YouTube
videos so optimizing your videos will
help your content rank higher on YouTube
so this is a give must it's not a given
it's a must you must optimize your
videos if you want people to see them of
course if you don't optimize people
aren't going to see them then people
aren't going to engage and then not
subscribe so it's just kind of a
snowball effect so this is an important
tip so I mentioned it at the beginning
when we were going over all the items
we're going to discuss this is the one
item that is a must and a given to some
degree because if you don't optimize
your videos they're just not going to be
found so you need that audience to watch
your video so audiences who tend to
interact more with your content have
more chance to subscribe to your channel
but they're not going to subscribe if
they don't even watch your video so
there is a snowball effect in play here
if we don't optimize your videos so okay
Rob what are some of the tips to
optimize your YouTube video well let's
go through some of those tips so to
ensure your videos reaches the relevant
audience on YouTube you need to optimize
the title description in the video tag
okay Rob what do you mean by title
description and video tag so let's take
a look at that so when you actually
create your YouTube video you're going
to have an opportunity to put in a title
you're going to have an opportunity to
put in a description and you're going to
have an opportunity to add text so those
are the three key areas okay so once you
put in that what it looks like on the
front end is this so if I go back to
YouTube and here you can see another
video that we did about a month ago you
could see what is SEO so if that's our
topic that's our title uh or of the
content of the video then the title of
the video is going to be what is SEO and
you could see we also added in some
other content for the title so what is
SEO and how does it work SEO tutorial
for beginners and then our brand name so
we have some content to work with for
the title okay and then the description
we have a lot of characters to work with
descriptions so use as much as you can
here to describe what the video is about
here you can see we did that and so it's
always good to include this information
okay and then you can see we have tags
up here seo seo tutorial for beginners
digital marketing so we put in the
necessary information here on this video
to help us rank because if we don't
optimize it we're not going to rank and
so you can see we just put a lot of
relevant content around the description
around the title and around those tags
by doing so we're able to optimize this
video and get found so that's just an
example three of the things you can do
to help optimize your YouTube video so
if you want to watch more on how to
optimize meta tags and I suggest maybe
watching the other video we did on the
subject how to rank YouTube videos so
this goes into more detail about how to
optimize the title The Meta description
and The Meta tags but there's a three
quick fields or areas that you can use
to optimize your video so just something
to keep in mind write a long description
with keywords timestamps and links so
what I mean by time stamps for timestamp
and audience can choose the section of
the video that they want to look for and
then links prefer to include relevant
Links of your other videos so those are
just some additional tips to help keep
your content engaging so remember when
your content is engaging then people are
going to like it people are going to
share it and watch it later so upload a
captivating thumbnail okay so you want
to include a thumbnail that's going to
grab people's attention you want to
upload a transcript of the video so that
goes back to when you're creating your
content when you write your original
content you want to keep a trans script
of the content of the video so that you
can upload that as well and then add a
start screen and end screen to your
YouTube videos so that way you know it's
somebody plays the video they're gonna
see it what it looks like up front and
then the way you finish it they're going
to see an end screen at the end and so
you just don't want to keep it dark and
black and non-descriptive so according
to backlinko using an exact keyword in
your video title can help you with
rankings so high ranking more views more
views more subscribers so that's what
I've been saying all along you need to
get these videos optimized so again use
an exact keyword in your video title so
let's go back again to that video I just
showed you a couple minutes ago what is
SEO so here we started out with a
question what is SEO that's the name of
the title that's one our exact title of
the video that's our exact keyword okay
so what is SEO and how does it work and
then SEO tutorial for beginners so what
is SEO is our exact keyword and that's
part of the video video that's the
content of the video that's in the title
and we use it throughout the description
as well so using that exact keyword in
your video title can help with the
ranking so whatever your topic is your
title of the video or the topic of the
video included in the title so backlinko
also mentions that there is a moderate
correlation between a Channel's total
subscribers and rankings and so for some
of you this may be common sense it's
just like organic search if you're not
ranking you're not going to get traffic
on YouTube if you're not ranking you're
not going to get eyeballs on your videos
and you're not going to get subscribers
so higher rankings can help you to get
more subscribers but you can't get those
rankings unless you optimize and so
again just for the sake of Simplicity
going back focus in on your title make
sure your title matches the title of the
video itself when you're publishing your
description use all the amount of
content available to you so you can see
it this entire description has a lot of
content maximize the content and then
use tags using those three Fields those
three areas can help you optimize your
video and gain the necessary ranking you
need to get viewers which will turn into
subscribers so tip four optimize your
YouTube channel so we just talked about
optimizing our videos now we're going to
turn our attention to our YouTube
channel so one of the easiest ways to
ask your viewers to subscribe to your
channel is really by creating a good not
even a good a great YouTube channel
trailer you also want to add Channel
keywords a description and some good
artwork and then having sections and
playlists to keep your videos organized
these are all good tips to creating a
good YouTube channel so let's talk about
some of these these tips here so we want
to give your audience a preview what
your channel is offering so this is by
hooking your audience with the trailer
so you can create a trailer to you know
just give your audience an idea of who
you are as a brand what kind of videos
you're going to be posting and give them
kind of a taste of what the future
videos are going to be like okay you can
even tell them your release schedule in
the trailer so you can start off by
saying hey hey guys we're new to this
we're going to be posting one video a
month but as we get rolling maybe two
per month and you know one per week you
know just being honest and open and
talking to your audience and get them
excited about future videos that's what
the trailer is all about so you also
want to keep it that the channel
description's short interesting so in
your channel you want to have a
description of what the channel is all
about what kind of videos you're going
to be posting so in addition to the
trailer you want to write something
short and interesting then we want to
use keywords in our Channel descriptions
just like in the videos with what is SEO
we included what is SEO and the title we
included you know what is SEO in the
description and so we want to be true to
what our channel is so pick Q words not
only include those keywords in the
videos but include them in the channel
description pay attention to the first
100 to 150 characters I have your
channel description because that's
what's shown next your channel on the
search results so for example here you
can see we have a description here
simply learn is one of the world's
leading certification training providers
we partner with companies and
individuals to address and so you can
see those characters 100 to 150 or what
shows up in the channel description when
somebody's trying to understand hey
simply learn just uploaded this video
who is simply learn so you want to write
short interesting Channel description so
that when somebody's first introduced to
your video they could see what your
Brand's all about so end your
description with an appropriate call to
action so short and interesting good
call to action at the end of the video a
good call to action would be hey check
out our next video or check out our
latest video something that's gonna gain
somebody and get them to watch one of
your videos so you want to pick
interesting channel art so let's turn
our attention to the simply learn
Channel page and here you can see we
recently had reached a milestone so
recently reached the 200 000 K
subscribers so 200 000 subscribers is a
big achievement for simply learn we went
ahead and updated our channel art and
I'm sure we will reach 500k we'll update
the artwork then too but the point is
you want to keep your channel art kind
of interesting hip and cool and feel
free to change it out every once in a
while so you have that option in YouTube
to do I mean so it's very simple so here
you can see simply learns Channel if we
go home we got all our videos listed
here we got the about us you know
something very short and interesting
about us here's our call to action for
more information visit simply learn so
you want to make sure when you create
your channel get some good artwork in
there put your description in play and
create your first videos and get them
posted up there and optimize them
accordingly okay so this is the other
tips to go with that channel art and
description is a profile picture
relevant to your brand so you always
want to maybe put out the the company
logo up there okay so here you can see
we have the company logo at Accurate
relevant Channel keywords so if we go
back to who we are who are we we're the
world's leading certification training
provider okay that's who we are okay we
partner with companies and individuals
so we're all about training and training
is one of our keywords so you can see
let's simply learn we provide online
training and machine learning AWS Amazon
web services devops Big Data digital
marketing project management a lot of
different topics so make sure that's
included in the channel description
feature the playlist on your home page
so if we go back to the home page we can
see here we have our channels so you can
see we have ai machine learning trending
Technologies cloud computing tutorials
devops tutorials popular videos big data
we have a lot of different channels so
you want to organize your videos into
different playlists so those playlists
are going to feature on the home page of
your channel so how you organize the
playlist is totally up to you but I
would certainly create a playlist for
different sections so depending on your
product your services think about how
you want to organize don't just stick
all your videos in one playlist then
optimize the playlist titles and
descriptions for search rankings so just
like the videos themselves just like the
channel description you have an
opportunity to optimize the playlist
titles and descriptions so be very keen
on aligning the right keyword with the
playlist title so here you can see
programming language tutorials project
management tutorials digital marketing
tutorials so we're very clear on how we
go about choosing our title because we
want to optimize those playlist titles
okay we can rearrange our videos in a
playlist so we want to rearrange the
videos in a way that we're maybe putting
the freshest the most newest the video
that's been published last first so
almost in descending order if you will
so we want our users to see what video
has the latest in that particular
playlist so they're seeing the most
recent first but you can rearrange your
videos any way you want feel free to
play around with it of course you can
also take the video that's the most
popular and put that up front so people
could see that first vice versa you
could take a video that maybe hasn't
gotten a lot of views or is it ranked
particularly High maybe put that video
up so it can get some views and some
shares and likes so how you rearrange
your videos is totally up to you just
have some rationale behind that so
choose a playlist thumbnail from a top
performing video so for example if I go
back to our YouTube page you could say
the top performing videos here you know
for example this one we got a nice
thumbnail here what is machine learning
so if I click on that okay most popular
videos so 3 000 likes on this video a
lot of views 250 000 plus views so have
a thumbnail to go along with that
particular video so according to
backlinko YouTube SEO ranking Factor
study discovered that channel keywords
have a small yet significant correlation
with Higher YouTube search rankings so
Channel keywords so when you're
optimizing your channel and you want to
include keywords start with your
description so if I go back to our
Channel okay if I go back about us make
sure your description has those relevant
keywords in it that's where it all
starts so in case you have any doubts if
you're not sure about everything we
talked about on optimizing the channel
go ahead and drop a comment below
because we do respond to every comment
event that gets posted on our videos so
if you're not sure how to go about
optimizing your channel when you say
align keywords with the channel what
does that really mean so if you want
some clarity on that go ahead and drop
us a channel if you're not sure about
the trailer video drop us a comment
we're more than happy to expand upon the
explanation of how to best optimize your
channel okay tip number five produce
high quality videos so we need to get in
the habit of producing high quality
videos because viewers don't prefer to
watch videos that have poor audio and
video quality it's just that simple you
need to know what it takes to produce
high quality videos if you don't you're
just going to discredit you're not going
to come across as relevant you know I'm
going to come across as qualified
professional there's a lot of things
attached to poor quality videos so we
need to create high quality videos for
the end users so let's talk about some
ways in which you can create create high
quality videos and so the first is to
avoid any noise in the background so you
want to have a nice quiet atmosphere no
distractions so people can hear you
clearly and only you clearly you want to
use good audio recording equipment
there's plenty of options available on
the internet usually I would recommend
going with something paid not overly
expensive because you get what you pay
for so if you use something free it
might not be of good quality and you
might not have all the features and
bells and whistles with a free option so
you know use good audio recording
equipment again it can be online or it
could be some software just make sure
that you're able to produce good high
quality video and audio so when you do
purchase that audio recording equipment
you want to have something similar to an
input volume meter that way you can see
whether your audio is coming across or
not so if you're not seeing green lights
then you're audio is not coming across
if it's red it might be distorted and so
you want something that's going to
signify that you're really pushing out
good quality audio you want to create
your videos in 1080 pixel size okay
that's HD and so you want to have at
least minimum 1080. so anything less
than that it's probably going to come
across as not so good maybe staticky
blurry not professional not high def so
you want to create a high def video and
1080 is about the minimum you want to go
and then you want to plan your video
script before filming so it goes back to
some of the other points I made earlier
you always want to have a video script
available so you know what you're saying
when you're recording your audio that
way you're not doing something on the
Fly then you want to use good lighting
for video recording so you don't want to
be in a dark place you want some nice
lighting so your video comes across well
lit people could see you they're not
struggling to strain their eyes on what
it is you're trying to show and appear
because of poor lighting again it just
comes across as professionals so if you
can you know shoot a high def video with
good audio speaking clearly having a
professional script with some good
lighting then people are going to take
you serious and they're going to start
to listen and engage and see the video
as good quality and very relevant and
informative and share it so use slow
motion and jump Cuts wisely so there's
some features you could do with your
video you know using slow motion and
jump cuts are some of the features you
can use to accentuate your points and
then set up a green background for
recording again this is for you know
making sure that the video part of it
comes across in good quality and then
stabilize your video recordings with a
tripod that way you're not moving your
video camera all around and and again
it's coming across the shaky and poor
quality shoot horizontal videos you
don't want to go vertical it tends to
cut the screen so you want to stay
horizontal also that people can see
everything that should be included in
the video okay you want to capture a
wider shot using a clip-on lens again a
good feature a good tip to use use that
wider shot okay so you could do that
using a clip-on lens and then choose
good video editing software I can't stay
this enough because you're putting all
this time and effort into a video you
need to be able to edit it to cut out
you know some of the things you didn't
want to say or maybe some poor quality
or or you know you just want to have a
smooth professional output for your
video and so you gotta have good video
editing software there's plenty of
options available on the internet again
I would go with something low cost but
paid usually free isn't exactly the way
you want to go if you're trying to
create a high def good quality video at
the very least review your work before
publishing I just said it a minute ago
I'll say it again you want to be able to
have a really professional video in high
def when you have a good professional
video in high def with good audio
horizontal shots you know nice green
background image nice well lit it's
going to come across as professional and
if you have a professional video then
people are going to take you seriously
they're going to see you as a
professional and then share or subscribe
and like and then they're gonna watch
more videos and and that's how you start
to build up a reputation as being a very
professional organization so just
following these simple tips on producing
high quality videos so you want to
review your work because if you don't
you put all that effort into it and then
you're going to realize hey your video
is low quality and then you're gonna
have to do it all over again so follow
these tips get a high quality video and
you should be on your way to ranking in
fact according to backlinko YouTube
preferably ranks HD videos so you gotta
have that 1080 uh pixel size that way
you know your video is going to come
across crisp and clear and YouTube
prefers that tip six I had a subscriber
Watermark to your videos so this is a
great feature in YouTube so it's a
feature that allows you to add a
watermark that can be shown on all your
videos the reason why you want that
Watermark because you want to keep
reminding your audience to subscribe to
your Channel The Watermark can be
whatever you want but normally it's
going to be some type of logo or brand
and a call to action and so how do you
add a watermark to your video well you
log into your YouTube account it's it's
pretty simple at the top right corner
you're going to select your creator
Studio icon and then you're going to go
to channel select branding and then add
a watermark to your video so if we look
at that in YouTube so here Creator
Studio on the left side navigation I'm
just going to click Channel then I'm
going to click branding and then once
you click brand name you have the
ability to add your watermark and then
you can add it to the entire video at
the end of the video at a specific start
time and then just click update and
that's pretty much it it so you want to
be able to add this so that you can
brand your videos with an image and then
add that CTA so this is a good good
feature for YouTube it allows you to be
consistent with all your videos by
branding and adding that call to action
tip 7 engage with your audience so you
want to be able to interact with your
audience as much as possible just
because of the video and you can't see
people doesn't mean you can't engage
with them so when you interact with your
viewers especially when you interact
with them immediately there's
gratification you know everybody likes
to be responded to nobody likes to be
ignored and so when somebody is
responded to there's a higher chance
that your viewers are likely to gonna
become customers it's just customer
service is how you really want to look
at this okay so when you engage you're
creating a service for your customers so
here are some tips on how to engage with
your audience so first is at the end of
every video convey and thank you message
to your viewers you know thank you for
spending the time out of every busy day
to watch this video you know some of our
videos go an hour plus long and so when
somebody's taking an hour to watch a
video it's only the least you can do is
thank them now you can thank them and
give them some information about where
to go for more information because if
they watch the whole video they're
already engaged and they're probably
going to want to learn more so you
always want to follow up to thank you
with where to go for more information
just like our videos always convey at
the end okay you always want to ask your
audience for their feedback or ideas on
the video so with YouTube there's a
comment section and you always want to
encourage comments so comments can be in
the form of feedback so as you're
watching this video feel free to leave
feedback on other ways to engage with
your audience or some other tips to
increase your subscribers on YouTube so
we're always looking for those ideas we
want to keep it engaging so somebody may
have some other ideas that we didn't
think about and so we always appreciate
that from our audience so we very much
appreciate the feedback that our
audience gives us so not all the
feedback there's always going to be
positive some of the feedback could be
less than positive or even negative
there could be mistakes so the idea
behind getting feedback is you want to
look at it you want to read it and you
want to react to it you want to react to
it positively in the form of you know
what thank you for the feedback and
looking at the feedback weighing it and
incorporating the feedback so you don't
always want to make the same mistake
twice in a video so if there's something
definitely wrong with the video that
we're doing for example and somebody
looked at it and gave us feedback on it
we'd certainly definitely take a deep
look into that and try not to do the
same mistake twice because likely that
user is going to watch the video again
so you always want to learn from your
mistakes and you want to turn those
mistakes or turn those comments into
future videos okay so create videos
based on your commenter's request the
audience has given us feedback we should
take that as positive and sometimes
that's creative sometimes those ideas
for more videos okay you always want to
ask questions to your audience and
reward excellent commenters so we try to
ask questions in our videos and when
users respond with their answer if
there's an excellent comment or
excellent answer you know we can reward
them you know reward them in the form of
say some type of gift card or gift
certificate or promotion or something
there's always some way to incentivize
somebody who provides excellent feedback
you can always give Emoji Hearts there's
so many emojis out there that you can
use emojis just to engage with your
audience based on the feedback that
they're giving the point is if your
audience is taking the time to give
feedback you always want to respond to
it and you want to respond to a pause so
emojis tend to have a positive
connotation to them and so responding
with an emoji especially to a favorite
comment goes a long way so you can
reward your community both on and off
YouTube for their engagement and support
and that's just being creative you can
reward in many ways many ways not
necessarily monetarily but by
recognition you could do promotions you
could do something fun there's always
ways to reward and prefer to host live
streams and interact with your audience
so you don't always have to do a
pre-recorded video there's certainly
YouTube has them other platforms like
Facebook have them Instagram so you can
certainly reach out to your audience
with a live stream and that's talking
directly to your audience right there in
the flash so when you can have an
opportunity to talk to your audience and
engage with them that's always going to
work because they can see personality
they can see what you're all about and
there's two-way conversation and so that
will lend to more of a you know
relationship so to speak with your
audience so you want to create videos
for subscribers subscribers can get
impressed when a channel dedicates a
video for them so you know take the time
out to create a video just for your
subscribers subscribers are the ones who
are most likely going to engage with you
okay they're your loyal fan base so if
you create something for them that's a
form of a reward so you can Captivate
your viewers by uploading interesting
YouTube stories as well you can also
hear from your audience and and get
their videos and use their videos and
upload them to your channel so according
to backlinko video comments of a very
strong correlation with rankings so as
you create a video feel free to talk to
your audience and ask them hey do you
have any comments feel free to put them
in the comment section right below this
video I see that a lot now with a lot of
videos and I'm gonna ask my audience
right now to do the same thing if
there's anything you see about rewarding
the audience or engaging with the
audience feel free to comment we'd love
to get your suggestions because if you
can engage with the audience even more
then that's only going to net positive
results not only in rankings but with
your subscriber base so comments are the
way to go solicit comments respond to
the comments reward the comments tip
number eight promote your videos on
different platforms so promoting your
videos on different platforms has been
around for many years it's a good
strategy once you create your video on
YouTube you want people to see it you
want to get it out there so if you want
to increase your YouTube subscribers
this is a strategy you have to perform
so let's take a look at all the ways you
can use and leverage different platforms
to increase your subscribers so before
you do that you want to research
discover how you can use different
platforms so the first thing you want to
do is look at the platforms you're
already using if you're using Facebook
and Instagram that's probably a good
place to start but there's other
platforms you can also leverage and
we're going to talk about those so
social media most companies most
individuals are on in some form or
fashion amongst the most popular like
Facebook and Instagram so so you could
start there so with Facebook you can
post something include the link of your
YouTube video with Facebook if you're a
business you have a business page you're
communicating with your community and
that's a great way to get started by
promoting your YouTube video you can
also do the same on Twitter or Instagram
or whatever platform you're on go ahead
and post something or tweet something
and include that link to YouTube you can
participate in forums and blog
discussions so there's plenty of forums
and blogs out there where you can
participate in discussion and include a
link to the YouTube video if it's
relevant and natural so for example here
there's a Blog about machine learning
you can include if you have a video
about machine learning and the response
to that conversation in this example
we've done that on Reddit you can list
your video in relevant and reputable
directories there's plenty of
directories out there there's plenty of
video directories okay that you can just
go ahead and publish your video on you
can use test ammonia link building okay
so somebody can provide a testimony and
include the link of your video you can
opt for influencer marketing so if
there's somebody that is associated that
likes your brand or product and has a
large following you can ask them to post
a video on your behalf it's a great way
to reach an audience fairly quickly okay
you can earn backlinks from relative
relevant and authoritative websites so
for example if you look at this website
here touchgenics okay there's a article
here about you know certificate of
achievements okay for AWS so if you
scroll down we could see our video is
included here in this particular web
page so this is a high quality web page
okay that's generating a backlink for us
not only is it generating a backlink
it's also generating traffic and
awareness for the video go ahead and and
find out if there's any websites that
are relevant to your video topic and see
if you can collaborate with them on
producing a web page to include that
video you can also take advantage of
email marketing by adding your YouTube
link in the email signature for example
it's a simple email any email client
like Gmail or Yahoo or even Hotmail or
Outlook is going to have an ability to
or give you the ability to add a
signature in the signature you could
simply just include a link to the video
or to your YouTube channel it doesn't
have to be to a specific video but it's
a way to get people to your YouTube page
or to that video so the whole idea is
more eyeballs more potential subscribers
engage your Audience by posting your
video links on community pages so for
example you know we're promoting
something here on a community pitch and
that's going to get some additional
traffic over to us you can always
bookmark your videos on bookmarking
sites like stumbledupon.com again this
is free very little time to do this but
it's a chance for you to get the video
out there and even generate a backlink
you can collaborate operate with other
YouTube channels this is always a good
strategy if you're creating a video on a
particular topic on YouTube chances are
there's probably somebody else out there
doing the same thing it doesn't have to
be necessarily a competitor it can be a
complimentary product or service and if
you offer that then go ahead and
collaborate with them and see if you can
exchange your videos on their Channel
and you could take their video and put
it on your channel in a particular
playlist okay so that's a way to
collaborate with other YouTube channels
is swap videos you could join High PR QA
sites and post answers to the questions
related to your video like core is
always a good example or ehab okay so
core there's always a question of being
posted and if you have the answer to
that question in the form of your video
then go ahead and post a response with a
link to the video on YouTube it's a
great way to get the video noticed and
it's relevant and natural okay you can
embed add videos in your blog posts or
if you're using a platform like
WordPress for example very easy to go
ahead and just take that video you can
even just put the link in the blog post
I like this option I think blog posts
are always good because you don't have
to be text Heavy with a blog post you
want to create a blog post that's nice
and balanced with an image and text but
if you put a video to support your blog
post that goes even further and blog
posts themselves can be engaging and
interactive with your audience so having
a video in your blog post always goes
well in my opinion okay so you can
promote other videos in your end screen
for example at the end of your video you
can always promote something related
like we've done here in this example so
lots of ideas get your video out there
use them in email use them in your blog
post go to free bookmarking sites like
stumble upon you know collaborate with
other people on YouTube you know go to
core respond to a question use social
media to your advantage there's lots of
opportunities to get your video out
there the more you can get your video
out there the more traffic you're going
to get the more traffic you get to the
video the more subscribers you're going
to get so that's how the game is played
in order to get your video out there but
these are relatively you know low time
consuming ideas to get your video so
with Twitter it's all about tweets it's
actually a verb now uh when you do
something on Twitter you actually tweet
and there are a lot of people out there
tweeting in fact Twitter has over 1.3
billion accounts so a lot of tweets
going on in the world of Twitter so as
of the third quarter in 2018 last year
Twitter had 326 million Global monthly
active users okay so active meaning
every day using the platform on a daily
basis so a lot of people using Twitter
it's very easy to use as you'll find out
and what you're going to find out today
is how how to increase followers on your
Twitter account so they can see more of
your tweets okay a little bit more about
Twitter there are 500 million tweets
posted every single day that's a lot of
tweets so you can imagine with every
tweet is a hashtag that accompanies that
tweet so a lot of information be
disseminated across the platform so
tweets with videos so Twitter does allow
videos as well as images attracts 10
times more engagement than other forms
of content so if you watched our YouTube
videos and some of the other videos we
had out there regarding Facebook or
Instagram you'll know that videos do
perform better Twitter is no exception
so if you have a video even if it's done
on YouTube or if it's not unpublished on
YouTube use it with Twitter you're going
to get more engagement so Twitter has 75
percent of its users use the platform
for news Okay so people go to Twitter to
get their news that's where they they go
they don't go to a regular website
content-based website they get their
news via Twitter it's just very easy to
digest because it's so few characters 75
percent of B2B businesses Market on
Twitter so not only is it a b2c or
business to consume or platform it's a
B2B business to business platform so a
lot of businesses are on Twitter
basically promoting either a product
service or trying to establish
themselves in the industry using the
platform so let's take a look at Twitter
and let's take a look at some of the
ways in which you can increase your
followers it all starts with your
profile you always want to make sure you
have a complete profile your name
obviously the Twitter platform that you
have is going to have a handle okay in
this example here it's a totally real
person at totally real person is the
Twitter handle and that's what you're
going to want to use to disseminate your
Twitter profile to others so you want to
make sure that you have a good image you
have a real name and a good handle that
people can associate with and remember
so you want to be able to set up this
profile with a key word friendly bio
okay a link to your website and a
picture that represents your brand
always helps so make sure it's complete
you can even take a step further by
customizing the color scheme of your
profile you can add a header image that
sticks to your theme that will help your
profile stand out and so let's take a
look at an example here so if I go to
Twitter here if we go to Simply learn
Twitter account okay their handle is
simply at simply learn okay they've
customized the header they use their
logo now if you're an individual you
probably want to use a nice profile pic
here where they're based a little bit
about them so just uh you know customize
complete profile goes a long way you
don't have to go overboard within a lab
elaborate design so to speak but just
make it stand out make it associate with
who you are as a person and a brand
those are best practices in getting that
profile up and running you don't want to
use something Bland and generic you know
take the extra step create something
unique make sure your profile is unique
you have a good image okay make sure
it's complete with you know telling
people who you are and what you're all
about that's really the first step on
really any social media platform so you
want to promote your Twitter profile to
drive users from other social media
platforms so when you actually get that
Twitter account set up and you actually
do have your handle go ahead and share
it that's the first step in getting
followers if you're already on Facebook
if you're already on Instagram then use
those platforms to announce that you're
on Twitter you can also take that a step
further and you know send out an email
to friends or family or like I said if
you're on Facebook go ahead and set up a
post say hey guys I'm on Twitter you
know come follow me so you can also so
use business cards advertisements
marketing materials and events to put
that Twitter profile on okay so it
doesn't have to be within the social
media sphere it could be even on your
website it can be even in email so you
can basically promote that profile again
you want to make that profile that
handle easy to remember so totally real
person is the profile in this example
we're going to use that profile
everywhere we can whether that be
offline or online you don't don't be
afraid to use it on a business card
especially if it's easy I can just
simply go to Twitter and type in that
handle so you want to stay active on
Twitter with regular retweets replies
and favorites and that's just it's just
so easy to retweet and reply and add
favorites so let's take a look at that
on Twitter so you can just simply I'm
logged in as me and if I want to retweet
something that simply learned it I can
just simply click on the retweet button
and I can add a comment if I want to and
then I'm going to reach week that simple
so now that tweet is going to show up on
my profile my handle and I could simply
like it if I scroll down here okay top
10 it Trends shaping 2019 notice a
simple tweet supported with an image so
I'm just gonna like that so I can even
comment on it I can click on the comment
and click a reply here okay and that's
going to show up in this tweet here just
like if I click on this I'll be able to
see what other people have written and
so it's that simple if I want I can just
click on the email button and even send
a message to somebody right from that
tweet the point is I can do everything I
need to do right in the platform but to
get started if you don't have any tweets
you know go and find other companies
similar to you look at their tweeting
and you can always retweet that that's a
good way to get going with tweaks that's
what I started doing when I started on
Twitter in 2008 I didn't know what to
write particularly and I didn't know how
to write it particularly well so I
looked at what other people wrote and
and tweeted and just retweeted those
that's a good way to get your Twitter
account started okay so engaging with
users is a great way to get more
followers so on simply learn I retweeted
one of their tweets I liked another one
of their tweets and it's probably gonna
get their attention somebody at simply
learned is gonna say okay Rob Sanders
went ahead and liked us and you know
what we're gonna go follow this guy he
seems to be somebody who's an audience
member who likes what we have to do
likes what we have to say like what
we're tweeting let's go ahead and follow
him and so that's a good way to get
going with your Twitter account is to
really start retweeting and liking other
tweets from other users so you can find
an appropriate time to post your tweets
to increase exposure retweets and
followers and you want to do this you
could do it within Twitter or as I'll
mention later you can do it in a social
media platform like Sprout social or
HootSuite or later or buffer and there's
plenty of social media platforms out
there for you to schedule tweets point
is you want to be able to schedule those
tweets when it's the appropriate time so
you don't want to do it in the middle of
the evening because what's going to
happen is likely by the morning other
tweets are going to bury your Tweet so
you want to be able to find the
appropriate time to post your tweets so
according to a survey conducted by
HubSpot the best time to post is between
12 and 3 P.M and why is that well most
people are usually on lunch checking
their phones yes Twitter has an app and
in fact most people use the app just
like on Instagram just like on YouTube
the app is very popular on Twitter so
it's very easy for somebody to check
tweets especially during the lunch hour
and then from 5 to 6 p.m that that in
between time when when people are
wrapping up work or heading home okay so
weekdays have shown to have the maximum
amount of Engagement so during the week
when people are working highly engaged
with whatever they're doing depending on
what industry you're in they're likely
going to check the Twitter and react
during those times okay so that was a
survey conducted by hotspot but really
what you want to do is you want to be
able to use one of these social media
platforms like a HootSuite or later and
find out exactly when are people
engaging with your tweets when I what
time of the day what day of the week are
you getting the most retweets or the
most likes okay that's what you want to
do so you can use this as a starting
point as a best practice but eventually
you're going to have to cater to your
audience based on when you're getting
your tweets engaged so you want to
increase followers by following more
people it's that simple and so it really
is that simple let me rephrase that so
it really is that simple so if I go back
to Twitter you know Twitter's always
going to recommend somebody for me to
follow and normally those are people
that are similar similar as myself okay
so they're not just going to choose
random people they're going to choose
people who are following people you're
following so there's going to be a
connection to some degree or they could
be people who use similar hashtags
tweeting the same content so you want to
go ahead and follow people the rule of
thumb on Twitter is if you follow
somebody on Twitter chances are they're
going to follow you back you know I was
once told when I was using Twitter that
hey you want to give somebody about
three days to follow you back so that's
always what the rule I stuck to you know
wait about three days start following
people you can see here 833 people that
or accounts Twitter accounts that simply
learns following and over ten thousand
nine hundred followers to Simply learns
Twitter account so for me I don't mind
having a nice balance myself I have just
as many followers as I do following and
that's a good thing so because because
you want to be able to keep up with what
people are tweeting and so you can
retweet at the same time you want to be
following people as well because they're
going to follow you back okay and that's
how you can build up your Twitter
followers by following people and it's
as simple as clicking on a follow link
so the key here is to follow people who
follow your content people who are
followers of your followers and you can
use Twitter's who to follow list and
upload your email contacts to Twitter
okay since they know you they're more
likely to follow you back okay so you
can use Twitter's who to follow list and
so if we go back to Twitter here's the
who to follow list and so this is what
Twitter is going to recommend but you
can click on this link here find people
you know okay so if I click on find
people I know then I can upload my
contacts from Outlook or Gmail and
they're going to find people who are
already on Twitter based on who I'm
connected with so generally that's how
it works that's a quick way to get more
followers is to connect with people you
know by the way I'm going to follow
simply learn because I wasn't following
them prior so now I just clicked on the
follow button now I am following so now
I'm going to see simply learns Tweets in
my feed so let's take a second to look
at a brand okay so it's time for a brand
watch let's have a look at some of the
best Tweets of 2018. now remember there
are a lot of active users millions of
active users that's a lot of tweets so
what we did was we scoured Twitter from
2018 and we went ahead and picked out
some tweets that we thought were pretty
good and so the first one is Wendy's now
I don't know if any of you have actually
eaten at Wendy's I used to eat at
Wendy's a while ago I know their
frosties are pretty good so what they've
done is they Incorporated that Frosty as
part of a giveaway okay so basically
they're saying hey grab yourself a free
Frosty with any purchase in our app so
they're encouraging able to use our app
and then they're following that up by
saying hey and then join us on Twitch
from two to five eastern as we unlock
all that Frosty goodness so they're
promoting something that's going to
happen on a specific point in time this
is last January they're encouraging
people to use their app and they're
using that Frosty as kind of a carrot if
you will okay it's a catch it's a
giveaway so they were able to you know
basically wrap a bunch of things into
one so get encourage people to take part
and I'm sure a lot of people went ahead
and took part of this but we could
definitely see that 206 retweeted this
tweet 302 basically commented on it and
over 3 000 liked the Tweet so the Tweet
was good and it basically engaged with
users who doesn't like a free giveaway
especially free frosting so that's why
this particular tweet really does some
justice for the target audience Their
audience they're they're giving
something away to Their audience just by
allowing them to you you know user app
okay so this tweet combines a lot into
one and I like it apparently a lot more
people than I did 3000 plus also like
this tweet and so moving on to how to
increase your followers on Twitter you
want to mention other people in your
tweets to increase engagement so what do
we mean by that so let's look at Twitter
so go back if we look at simply learn
just take a look at some of their tweets
what they're doing if we scroll down
here they have hashtags so they are
mentioning specific hatch tags but you
can also mention handles as well so the
hashtag is always going to start with
either the pound sign but if we scroll
down here if you use the at symbol
you're actually mentioning somebody so
in this case we're mentioning Matt
Bailey so Matt Bailey says is Matt
Bailey's handle and so if you get a
shout out to somebody they're gonna pick
up on that and then they're going to
probably follow you okay who doesn't
appreciate getting recognized for
something especially something as small
as a tweet okay notice I can go ahead
and click follow if I want to follow my
bailey but it's not a bad idea to add
people into your Tweet and you simply do
that by just using the at symbol and
using their Twitter handle it's a good
way to get recognized by that Twitter
follower it also increases engagement
because it's adding validity to the
tweet and it definitely catches the
attention of the person mentioned
remember if you use that person's handle
they're going to see that that you
mention them okay and what it's likely
going to do is start some type of
Twitter relationship okay they're gonna
then follow you you're gonna follow them
and chances of them retweeting you in
the future or mentioning you in the
future is probably going to increase and
overall that increases engagement so
another important thing you want to do
is finding use hashtags that are
relevant to your brand and audience so
this is a must this is mandatory on
Twitter you need to use hashtags
Twitter's all about hashtags every tweet
that goes out should have a hashtag okay
so what you can do is figure out what
hashtags are trending so here what
Twitter does is they trends for you so
these are all specific hashtags that are
trending it's Mother's Day Happy Mother
hey Sunday morning whatever works for
you these are trends that happen to be
moving meaning a lot of people are using
them clicking on them okay so you can
use a popular hashtag what I would also
recommend is you use a unique hashtag
the rule of thumb is usually about two
hashtags in a tweet but that's a rule of
thumb but rules are made to be broken do
what's best for you if you want to
include more than two hashtags go for it
the only thing I'm recommending is
include a hashtag so find out what's
trending you could just look right in
Twitter or you could just create your
own unique hashtag it works both ways
but when you have a hashtag in your
Tweet and somebody clicks on it then
they're going to go go to that
particular handle that hashtag and so
when they look at the hashtag you're
going to see all the tweets with that
hashtag in it so that's the idea behind
hashtags you want to have hashtags okay
so if somebody clicks on a hashtag that
you used then they're likely going to
see your Tweet in that hashtags feed
okay so that's how hashtags work you
want to use hashtags okay but you want
to use hashtags that are relevant to
your branded audience that's really the
key so hashtags help your tweets to be
found through Twitter search thus
improving your reach and increase the
visibility of your post so that's
another benefit Twitter has search
functionality so somebody can simply go
in and start searching on Twitter so if
I go back to Twitter I can just do a
hashtag and start typing in something
like Spanish and I'm gonna get some of
the most popular Spanish hashtags or
Hashtags with the word Spanish in it and
so this is an idea for me that if I
wanted to use a hashtag tag with Spanish
in it these are some ideas but they're
certainly searchable on Twitter okay so
if I just click on Spanish okay I'm
gonna be able to see all the Hashtags
with the word Spanish in the hashtag so
definitely use hashtags it's the most
beneficial feature of Twitter Bar None
So some reasons why using hashtags also
a good idea well you're gonna get more
engagement and you're likely to get
retweeted as well so when you get
retweeted then that means more eyeballs
because if somebody sees your Tweet and
retweets it they're retweeting it for
Their audience and so it could go viral
so to speak on Twitter and that's where
the engagement comes in so if you're
using a hashtag that's trendy well
somebody might like that okay if you're
behind a specific movement or you're
following a specific baseball or
football team or cricket team or
whatever team you're following then if
you use that team and the hashtag that
could also get you some some likes so
don't be afraid use hashtags mix it up
play around a little use something
unique use something that's trending
just use something but make sure it's
relevant to the Tweet find out what
works for your competition what works
for them might work for you too so you
know I work with simply learn but you
know simply learn has a good Twitter
account you know they have lots of
followers they're doing a lot of
tweeting so if I wanted to be just like
simply learn well I could simply just go
to their Twitter account and see what
they're doing okay see what they're
using as hashtag so what kind of tweets
they're implementing and see who's
following them so I can simply just
click on the 10 900 followers that they
have and what I can do is I can go
through and start following the people
that are following them so just mimic
your competition to some degree or mimic
others in the industry you know look at
what they're tweeting again start out by
retweeting some of the stuff they're
retweeting if it's good stuff if it's a
good tweet it don't be afraid to retweet
even your competitors tweets okay use
unique hashtags use the hashtags they're
using look at who's following their
brand so you can really learn a lot from
others in your industry including your
competition because what works for them
again might work for you especially when
it comes to hashtags or people who's
following them again people who are
following them would likely follow you
if you're in the same industry so it's
as simple as looking at who's following
them and following those same people
remember the rule of thumb is if you're
following somebody they're likely to
follow you back so again you can analyze
things like the number of followers they
have the frequency of their tweets what
their profile looks like how they
respond to the competition of customers
okay what are they tweeting about what
types of content brings them more
engagement meaning of all the tweets
which one is getting the most likes or
retweets gets some sense of what they're
doing and again when I say mimic I mean
whatever what I'm saying is pull best
practices from that Twitter this will
give you an idea what you need to do to
get more followers so it's always a good
form of flattery when you can mimic what
somebody else is doing just like every
other social media platform following
Twitter influencers who belong in your
industry is always a good idea so if
you're in the food industry and there's
these star chefs out there probably not
a bad idea to follow those star chefs
you know if you're in the technology
industry well probably not a bad idea to
you know follow Bill Gates or Elon Musk
or Richard Branson or somebody else and
that's a big influencer who has an
influence on a lot of people okay but
make sure they're in your industry
that's the key if you can make sure
they're in your industry and you follow
them chances are if they look at your
Twitter account and see you're posting
or maybe retweeting some of their tweets
they're likely to follow you and if
they're following you your tweets are
going to show up on their handle on
their feed and so don't be afraid to go
out and connect and follow those
influencers it's a good way to boost up
your followers so again this will help
you gain followers since you can
replicate what they've done with their
profile so again just like the
competition mimic what your influencers
are doing okay so people tend to follow
people who follow influencers so you're
all of one like mine so to speak okay
influencers might retweet or share your
post if they find you retweeting
favorites and replying to their posts so
remember if you're following a retweeter
or excuse me an influencer and you
retweet their post chances are they
might retweet one of your posts and
again put you in front of a large number
of people since they're influencers so
all of these are good valid reasons to
follow influencers because if you're out
to increase your reach and exposure it's
hard to ignore influencers in your
industry okay you want to use images and
videos while tweeting remember videos
get multiple multiple times more
engagement than not using them at the
very least please use images but you use
images don't use stock Photography use
images that are relevant so one of these
tweets caught my eye here from Simply
learn so if I click on you know here it
was further down here it looked like you
know these are people who are engaging
in a conference and it might have been
one that Matt Bailey was at so it was a
retweet from Matt Bailey as a matter of
fact but you could see what simply
learns doing is they're including either
a video or they're including an image in
every tweet and so that's likely to
boost up engagement so according to
buffer which is a another social media
platform adding a relevant high quality
image in your tweets can help you gain
more than a hundred and fifty percent
engagement okay videos are six times
more likely to be retweeted so if you
have an Arsenal video or even one video
don't be afraid to use it my
recommendation is trying to use images
as much as you can in almost every tweet
images go a long way a and again it's
going to help improve engagement meaning
more retweets more followers okay more
followers more eyeballs so it's a
Snowball Effect just by using images
Okay so let's take a look at another
brand from 2018 okay Pizza always my
good example to use on these webinars I
like pizza here this just says it all
you know they're talking about art and
they're using Pizza in the form of art
so they didn't really have to say much
else here this pretty much says it all
and they did get some retweets they get
some just some likes so sometimes you
don't have to say a lot to make your
point sometimes just the image itself
will do the job this was actually not
from 2018 this goes all the way back to
2016. so still holds true if you use an
image that image is going to get
engagement okay so on Twitter just like
most other social media platforms you
can promote your Tweet so you can use
Twitter ads to do that so you can
promote your Tweet and What You Do by
promoting it is putting it up above so
that most people will be able to see it
okay so see if we can find an example if
I go here I could see this person is
promoting their handle but if I go down
here I can see a promoted tweet by
Constant Contact so they're promoting
their tweet here so it's not a bad idea
if you have some Media budget to go
ahead and either promote your Tweet or
advertise on Twitter so what that's
going to do is put you in a more
prominent position and get your tweets
out there and the whole idea for that is
to get people to engage here you can see
a call to action from Constant Contact
so if I click on that I'm going to go to
probably a landing page on their website
and so the whole idea when you advertise
on Twitter is really just like any other
social media platform you want to put
yourself in front of the Right audience
and so Twitter's no exception so with
Twitter you could put yourself in front
of the right audience so what you could
do is you could promote a tweet you know
do promoted Trends or you could do
promoted accounts so you have a number
of different advertising options on
Twitter what we just looked at was you
know looking at promoted accounts and a
promoted tweet so when you do advertise
there are advantages you have to pay
only after achieving your marketing
objective so that's a benefit of Twitter
the cost per click it's a cost per click
model so it tends to be fairly low you
could tail your audience so again you're
picking and choosing who you want your
promoted tweet or Trend or account to be
in front of and it's targeting is based
on either engagement or it's based on
keywords I.E hashtags so really you
could tailor who you want your Tweet or
your handle to be in front of and so
that's the really the benefit of Twitter
if you have a lot of active users on
Twitter you can really put yourself in
front of those active users if they're
irrelevant audience at a low cost per
click so it's definitely worth the test
so you want to offer Twitter support to
your users okay so I can't stress this
enough okay so what you want to do is
when users have questions about your
product they're more likely to tweet you
for support hence they're likely to
follow your account so don't be afraid
to use the messaging option as well so
if we go back to Twitter okay chances
are somebody might have a question for
you here you can look at big ads it's
great connecting with PPC experts can't
believe tax season is here we've got
some great insights so what they're
doing is they're using the messaging app
but they're offering that messaging app
in the form of customer service so don't
be afraid to use you know direct
messages to reach out to people in the
form of support what you don't want to
do is buy Twitter followers chances are
you're going to get the wrong followers
so even though it may boost your Twitter
follow account these Bots cannot use or
buy your your products or services so
stay away from all sorts of buying of
Twitter followers you want to build your
Twitter following naturally Twitter is
also cracking down on bot followers so a
lot of Bot accounts that were paid to
follow users were shuts down shut down
by Twitter so just my point is
everything we've mentioned today is what
you want to take advantage of okay if
you want to pay for something pay for a
promoted tweet reach out to influencers
look at what your competition is doing
use hashtags okay these are all best
practices in organic ways to build
followers so don't get involved with
anything that's going to involve Bots
and adding thousands of followers to
Twitter account because chances are it's
just going to lead to no engagement so
create useful and relevant content so
what we started out by saying is hey if
you're not sure what to do retweet
retweet which somebody else is doing you
know look at your competition's Twitter
account see what they're tweeting get
some ideas as to what you want want to
tweet so you want it to be useful and
relevant to your industry okay you want
somebody to engage that's the whole idea
behind Twitter the whole idea is if
you're going to Tweet something you want
to get somebody to engage with it so use
Twitter polls your old recent blog post
brand news industry news and events and
highlight customer stories I mean all of
those are ideas that you can do to put
content out there okay so for me one of
the things I do is I'm definitely one
for industry news so if I'm in the
industry of digital marketing if Google
did a recent algorithm update I'm going
to likely tweet about it or retweet it I
also am a blogger so on my particular
website if I blog I'm gonna make sure
that blog gets over to Twitter so those
are some ideas in which you can create
useful and relevant content on your
Twitter account you definitely want to
get that content out there but you want
to make it useful and relevant quality
over quantity because you want people to
engage so bring variety to the type of
content you share so I'm in digital
marketing I deal with pay-per-click SEO
but am I gonna just do pay-per-click and
SEO no I know that analytics I know that
you know Google tag manager I know that
they'd be testing all of those are
elements of digital marketing so I'm
going to Branch out and talk about some
of those things that support digital
marketing so that's an example of
bringing variety to the type of content
you share so don't just stick to one
thing you know feel free to reach out a
little bit shake things up by sharing
other forms of updates like engaging
quotes and questions these work best
when complemented by an image and an act
as a great discussion starter so good
point here even if you want to Branch
out of your industry and just throw in a
nice useful quote it's always a good way
to gain some attention and get some
engagement okay let's look at another
brand and see what they've tweeted about
so we're looking at Forester here so
think about emotional qualities and
their implications so here you can see
customers that feel surprised or
grateful or appreciated they're sharing
that Insight with you and so this was
interesting when I saw this so what I
did was I simply you see the hashtag
here for digital basically if you want
to look at this particular study I just
went to Twitter and I typed in that
hashtag and now I'm going to be able to
see you know some of the other studies
that they've done here you can see top
10 it Trends shaping 2019. so I'm just
following the Twitter handle that they
used so Forester does a lot of good
research a lot of good insights and so
what they've done here that makes this
tweet look so good is they've actually
put an image of the results in the Tweet
so they used an image to help gain
engagement or increase engagement notice
they also gave a shout out to somebody
as well as use some good hashtagging so
so good tweet this was back in 2016 but
again good use of the image with the
Tweet so you want to organize tweet
chats to interact with your users and
bring in new followers so you know you
basically want to be organized when
you're dealing with with chats so tweet
chats enable you send out tweets on a
particular topic using a designated
hashtag so during a certain time to
interact with your your followers and
other users so you could do it at a
specific time to really get out a
specific topic but you want to be able
to stay organized so that you know you
what you're chatting about is reaching
the wide audience and you're getting the
right following and the right engagement
okay you can also pin your best updates
and tweets to your profile so you can
just use that pin and what that's going
to do is pin it to the top and keep it
there so that you know people who go to
your Twitter handle are going to be able
to see that best tweet that you've done
so what you want to do here is use the
one that's most engaging so pinning your
best update or tweet meaning the one
that's really had a lot of Engagement
meaning retweets and followers and likes
you want to do that you want to pin that
to your profile and that will enable
first-time visitors to see it and if
they could see something that other
people engaged with and that's going to
encourage them to share and probably
follow you so and and that's always what
you want to do you always want to put
your best foot forward so pin your best
tweet to your profile so I mentioned
this earlier use tools to schedule when
to publish your tweets so here are some
of the most popular platforms you know
I.E Sprout social so if we take a look
at Sprout social here I'm Inspire social
I'm connected to my Twitter account I
can simply just start tweeting about
something here so you can see it's going
to let me know how many characters I
have remaining so 280 to start out with
when I'm done tweeting notice I can add
an emoji I can upload media I can tag a
specific location okay I can even you
know call out a specific Twitter profile
now I can schedule this myself or I can
use the schedule below I can pick and
choose a time to schedule the Tweet now
again you want to be able to use the
Sprout social whatever social media tool
you're using to figure out when the best
time of day and the day of the week to
actually tweet when are you getting the
best engagement so ideally that's what
you want to do you want to tweet when
you're likely to get the best engagement
when those eyeballs are actually going
to look at that tweet okay but you also
want to separate out your tweets so
they're not on one on top of another
because if you actually Tweet back to
back then those tweets are just going to
get buried so if you spread them out a
little bit then you're likely to
maximize your number of Impressions or
eyeballs on that tweet so if you
schedule a tweet multiple Tweets in the
same day then post them a few hours
apart or an hour apart so that way way
you're always going to get that maximum
visibility so these social media
platforms really help you and not only
scheduling but figuring out what tweets
got the best engagement and when and
then that way you can replicate that
success so again it's not just Sprout
social HootSuite buffer they'll help you
determine the exact time your audience
is most active and schedule posts to
increase traction so you know most of
these social media platforms do the same
thing so really what you want to do is
you really want to nail down that exact
time your audience is going to be most
active Okay that's the whole idea behind
using it and when you actually do tweet
you are going to get results and these
social media platforms are going to
share those results with you and then
when you understand based on your
audience behavior when they're engaging
when they're not engaging that's when
you're going to fine tune your
scheduling so what you also want to do
as you're doing these tweets as we
looked at earlier with Wendy's is run
contests or giveaways remember Randy's
gave away that free Frosty you know be
afraid to give away something if it
means more engagement more eyeballs
which could lead to basically future
customers so contests can help increase
your reach and exposure and each new
participant can be considered as a
potential follower so it also gives your
followers an opportunity to tag their
friends who would be interested in
participating so really come up this is
a great way to be creative come up with
a good idea to get your your audience
involved because what's likely going to
happen is your audience is going to
share this contest with others that
aren't following you and so what's going
to happen is when they share it you're
going to get more followers you're going
to get more eyeballs and again
potentially more customers so embed your
Twitter updates on your website you
could simply do that uh it's very simple
but when you do then people to your
website will be able to see your tweets
so if I just go to my website here if I
scroll down we actually have you know
Twitter and embedded on our website as
well because we want you know people to
see what we're tweeting about and you
can see I just retweeted the simply
learned tweet at the beginning of this
particular webinar and it's showing up
in my feed here so that's when people
actually go to my website they'll be
able to see what I retweeted and that's
going to help simply learn out because
simply learn is likely to get some
clicks on this particular tweet from my
website so it's also a good way to keep
your website fresh and updated because
if you're an active Twitter user and
you're tweeting a lot then hey that's
going to show up on your website and
it's going to show that hey you're fresh
you're engaging you keep up to date it's
just gonna make it look good and make
your website feel fresh and not stale so
embedding your Twitter updates will help
you add new followers as well because
it's people who are coming to your
website that may not even know you have
a Twitter account so you can also do
this in a blog post and a newsletter and
other forms of communication media so it
doesn't necessarily have to be just your
website but I would definitely recommend
it because it will give a boost to your
Twitter account so now let's take a look
at the final brand watch let's take a
look at another tweet that caught our
attention and this is from PlayStation
so PlayStation is mentioning hey we got
a multi-view on Apple TV today with
support for up to four live channels on
one screen okay so you know they're
promoting a new feature that they have
with PlayStation and you can see they
supported that with an image and they
got some really good engagement here so
they're basically saying hey look what
happened to us today you know check out
this new feature that got supported on
Apple TV so you never know what's going
to happen with a tweet when you tweet
good things are likely going to happen
whether that be somebody liking it
retweeting it or somebody adding you as
a follower something good is going to
come out of tweeting Twitter is an easy
platform to use and if you take into
account all these best price practices
you are going to increase your Twitter
followers today we're going to talk
about how to increase Instagram
followers today's webinar we're gonna
have some tips and and best practices
for you to take advantage of to increase
Instagram followers so let's get started
and talk a little bit about Instagram so
Instagram is not really an up and coming
platform it is already up and coming a
lot of users in fact 500 million daily
active Instagram users 500 million daily
May the user base growth of more than
300 percent year over year so it's
growing and growing and growing it's
become more and more popular ever since
it's launched back in 2010 and then
there's more than 100 million photos
uploaded daily so it's a platform where
you can upload photos tag those photos
even use and Implement videos and photos
have become very popular with the Advent
of mobile technology that the Instagram
app makes it easy for you to post your
photo so there's no surprise there's a
growth there's no surprise there's a lot
of users there's no surprise that
there's a hundred million photos plus
uploaded daily and then there are 400
million stories posted daily so when you
post something you can create a story
out of it and there's 400 million of
those per day and then there's more than
50 billion photos shared to date so
since 2010 platform Nat which is now
owned by Facebook has become really
really popular a good place for you if
you have your own company if you have
your own brand if you have your own
product it's a good place for you to
really showcase that service that
product that brand because of the user
base how easy it is to use and the wide
reach it has for you in which to tell
your story so imagine there are lots of
photos shared today close to seven
billion dollars revenue generated
through Instagram mobile so on top of
everything I just said and there's a lot
of e-commerce going on here too so
Instagram is a platform in which there's
e-commerce integrated within the
platform so as a business who offers a
products you can actually generate
revenue for yourself on the flip side
Instagram which is owned by Facebook has
an opportunity to sell advertising space
Instagram so Instagram is an e-commerce
platform to say the least in fact
Instagram is because it's so popular
because it's part of Facebook's
advertising platform they're more than
two million advertisers on Instagram so
amongst all those stories videos and
photos and hashtags you'll see some ads
and then because you'll see ads because
you'll see users you're going to see
businesses it's just good place to
really set up shop and really tell your
story through the world of photos and
videos so 25 million plus businesses
have already migrated over to Instagram
and that's growing and growing and
growing so it's an opportunity for you
to work with other businesses so the
arrow is definitely pointing up on
Instagram there's a lot going on here
easy to use application especially when
it comes to photos and videos so we're
going to go through some tips and tricks
today and we're going to talk about
everything there is to know about
Instagram and how to increase your
followers so let's take a look at tip
one here so because Instagram is an
application everything you do on it is
through the application now you could
certainly view a web page version on it
but you really can't do much out of that
so if I go to my Instagram accounts for
example using my desktop I could see my
profile and I can edit my profile to a
degree but everything you're doing is
through the application so when it comes
to that tip one here is take advantage
of your bio so regardless of what
industry you are you're in who you are
you really want to have a clear and
concise and compelling bio why because
this is your end introduction to the
world you want people to know who you
are and because if you don't really
become very clear to people they're not
going to follow you so this is where it
all starts you need to take advantage of
your bio have a clear and concise bio
and have a link to your website or some
contact information so to me this is
where it all starts you gotta have a bio
because that's what people are going to
look at and they're going to decide
whether to follow you or not based on
primarily that bio that's where it all
starts so make sure you have a good bio
that's tip number one so you'll have to
make sure that your landing page is also
mobile optimized since most Instagram
users are on mobile so if you're going
to put a link to your website and
somebody's on the Instagram app and they
see your bio and they like it and you
have a link to your website make sure
that Lanny page they go to is mobile
optimized so tip number two everything
you do on Instagram when it comes to
posting evolves around hashtags so
that's the backbone of the platform form
just like most platforms out there
social media platforms like Twitter or
Facebook Pinterest you're gonna have
hashtags accompany those posts so
Instagram's no different but in this
case you really really want to take
advantage of the hashtag so hashtags are
there to help users find your content so
you want to start out by using hashtags
that are relevant to your business so if
you're in the food industry you're gonna
post something related to food do the
appropriate amount of research to find
hashtags to describe your brand and also
or be in searched on Instagram so what
does that mean that means do a little
bit of homework on Instagram you know
see what searches or see what other
brands in your industry are using for
hashtags don't be afraid to use the same
hashtag but mix it up hashtags are
important so don't be afraid to put a
hashtag in there that really defines
what your business is about but if it's
relevant use other hashtags that are
popular or people are using to find
information so mix it up but the key
here is relevancy you want to make sure
you align your Hashtags with your
content and making sure the connection
between the hashtag and the content is
relevancy so using the popular tags on
your photos or videos might get you some
immediate engagement but it may not help
with future goals like long-term
engagement new interested fires and
sales so here really what I'm trying to
say is look pick and choose your
hashtags carefully because if you use
something broad or something
non-relevant yeah you may get that click
to your Instagram page but that doesn't
necessarily mean somebody's going to
follow you or that doesn't really mean
somebody's going to be interested in
what you have to offer so if you use
something really popular and Broad yes
you're going to get short-term
gratification but not long-term interest
tip number three post your content at
the right time so according to
sproutsocial which is a social media
scheduling platform among other things
so they deal deal with a lot of people
using their platform and posting content
via their platform they have data and
they're telling us based on the data
they've collected that the best time to
post this between 2 and 3 P.M and the
best day to post is Thursday now that
may be all fine and true according to a
sprout social study and so you may want
to go with this 2 to 3 P.M and this is
probably local in case you're wondering
what time zone you're referring to so
this is all local to you so go ahead and
try that out try two to three p.m on
Thursday the thing is what you're gonna
have to do eventually is figure out what
the best time to post is okay so if
you're pointing out a lot of content and
you're putting out content throughout
the week at certain times of the day or
throughout the day you're gonna have to
determine which time of day and what day
is generating the best engagement for
you who's looking at your post at what
point of the day what day of the week
and so you're gonna really have to lean
on a social media platform to help you
determine that because they're going to
have the data that you need to determine
what the best time of day to post is
okay so we'll talk about social media
platforms here shortly we just know that
when you post post with some rationale
in mind ask yourself before you even
push that publish button or before you
even schedule that post this time of day
in this day of the week makes sense so
you always want to post at the right
time because you could be missing your
audience so remember when you do this
you're going to be working with some
platform and Instagram also has some
analytics for business accounts so
Instagram will also give you some
feedback as to how you're supposed to
perform it and we're going to talk about
that here shortly as well so let's move
over to tip four here so steal followers
from your competitors okay so if you're
dealing in a very competitive industry
and your competitors have a lot of
followers it's very very easy to see who
following them so the easiest way to do
this is just interact with your
competitors followers you could follow a
user like or comment on their photos and
so the more you engage with people the
more you stand to gain from them so you
could see who your competitors followers
are and you can add them as a follower
just by following them so start engaging
with them if they're liking your
competitors brand then what the chance
of them liking your brand could be great
so check out who your competitors
followers are if they seem like somebody
who you would want to be following your
brand then go ahead and interact with
them and how you interact is again you
can like something that they post or you
can comment on something that they
posted okay engage with them okay it
doesn't take that much time it's a good
way to gain followers so if we're on
Instagram we can simply just click on
the Brand's followers so here I can see
this brand has 127 followers and here I
can see all the followers and what I
could do is simply just click on one of
the followers and I can go to their
profile and from there I could see what
they've posted in terms of videos and
images and I can like or comment so just
doing something as simple as this gets
you an opportunity to engage with
somebody who can then turn around and
follow you so tip five pay for sponsored
posts and product reviews so a number of
ways you could do this here so pay for a
sponsored post so you can find an
influer who satisfies a couple of
requirements they have large following
and an email address in the profile so
you can connect with them and ask them
for sponsored post pricing so it's as
simple as that as reaching out to
somebody who has a large following okay
so if you do this then it's going to put
shoe in front of a large number of
people and so by doing this it'll help
expose your brand to that larger
audience and help build your credibility
because you're connecting with somebody
who has a large audience as well so do a
little bit of homework find people out
there in your industry who has a large
following and make sure they have that
email address in their profile so you
can contact them and when you contact
them you know ask them for sponsored
post pricing so if the influencer has an
email address then they're open to
sponsored post or shout out so that's
the key so they gotta have that email
address and when they do then it's all
about asking them and connecting with
them on being a sponsor to one of your
posts okay you want to get yourself out
there in front of people this is the
quickest way to do that okay so tip six
we want to use geotags for easier
discoverability okay so tag your images
videos or stories by tagging the
location City or venue where it was
posted from so very easy to do as you're
posting just go ahead and and there's an
option in there to say hey where are you
located or what city are you located in
so locations have their own feed and
stories which you can contribute to so
go ahead and add that extra element to
your tags so if somebody's in that
location the chance of them engaging are
going to be great and it's good for
local businesses because if you're local
and you're posting your location then
again somebody in that location is
likely to engage with you tip seven use
Instagram stories to attract followers
and grow your user base So Stories a
really big feature on Instagram so what
stories could be used for is just show
footage of an environment so it could be
your office it could be your home it
could be you know the playground it
could be the golf course it could be
anywhere that you want to show vintage
of so you want to post new relevant to
your industry so if you're in the food
industry hey why not go in the back into
the kitchen and post a story about how a
particular bread or cake is made okay
show off your products so if you are in
that food industry and say you're in the
pizza making business perfect
opportunity to show people via on
Instagram Story how to make that pizza
and how you make that pizza what
ingredients you use how unique is your
particular product and that's really
what you want to get across when you do
a story you want to show something
unique and relevant that's going to
grasp people's attention you can promote
a company event so if you're celebrating
say 200 000 subscribers create a YouTube
video or you can create an Instagram
story it works just as well so you can
endorse your company's blog posts you
can post positive user reviews so these
are all features of a story increased
interactivity with polls sliders Etc and
then you can also mention other
companies that work with or follow you
so great use of Instagram stories is do
a shout out to somebody else so
Instagram stories is a really big
feature with Instagram check it out you
know you just do a search for Instagram
stories in fact let's get some of you
users involved what best practices do
you have when creating Instagram stories
why don't you go ahead and share your
answer story with us by putting that
Instagram story in the comments section
below so we want to get everybody
involved here because there's a
thousands upon thousands of great
Instagram stories out there to be shown
and viewed and engaged with so go ahead
and share your Instagram story if you
have any other tips or tricks then go
ahead and put those in the comments
section so that everybody can benefit
from them so the only thing to keep in
mind when you're creating these stories
is what are your followers interested in
seeing so your stories could teach or
promote something to your user base so
always keep that in the back of your
mind you know for me I always go back to
what industry are you in if you're in
the food industry hey you know people
who are following you or interested in
food if you're a pizza company you know
show off that pizza if you're a bakery
show off how you make your Breads and
goods baked goods whatever it is you
have show it off because if somebody's
following you that's what they're
interested in so tip number eight
highlight important stories so you want
to highlight highlights serve as the
easiest way to create a first impression
for a potential follower so with
highlights can be used to tease what
your content's about create a trailer
for what your brand offers promote and
promote your product so highlights are
there it's a good feature it's a first
impression for potential follower so it
teases what the content's about it
creates a trailer so to speak for your
brand and promote your product so use
highlights and again any users out there
who have good examples of highlights go
ahead and put those in the content
section or comment section uh right
below this video so remember stories
have only a 24-hour lifespan so
highlights can be used to give them a
second wind okay so highlights serve a
purpose it teases what the content's
about it promotes the product and it
really kind of accentuates that story
tip number nine ask for followers so
sometimes people need a little push
before they can follow you on Instagram
even if they enjoy your content so you
can ask users to become your followers
in the caption the comment section don't
even work it into your content so in
other words when you're posting
something don't be afraid to say hey
follow me you know I got some good stuff
here be confident you don't want to do
it for every post of course but you know
pick and choose if you feel you have a
really good post you know really good
image that you think is going to gain a
lot of followers and engagers then you
don't necessarily need to put a caption
in there but if if it is popular then go
ahead and say hey this is a popular post
you know think about following me or put
something in the comment section you
want to do it kind of succinctly you
don't want to be begging but just
working into some degree okay but don't
be afraid have some confidence and
asking for followers so when you do this
it's very similar to how we do it on
YouTube so you can ask viewers to
subscribe to their channels at the end
of the video so it's if on YouTube
basically you're saying hey if you like
what we have go ahead and subscribe it's
no different on Instagram if you have
something you've posted just go and said
hey you like this you know go ahead and
follow us that simple so tip number 10
take on the latest trends to get more
followers so align your content to cater
to trendy topics or hashtags to improve
engagement and discoverability so really
what we're trying to say here's your
competitors follow influencers what are
the latest trends and you can get an
idea of the latest trends by you looking
at hashtags so what hashtags are
trending which ones are people using the
most so really what you want to do is
whatever's trending in your industry you
know ride that wave so to speak now it
doesn't have to take on your entire
profile but there's nothing wrong with
one or two posts if something's really
taking on popularity then go ahead and
post about it as well you know for
example in the wine industry if there's
a new wine that really came out that's
really gaining some popularity go ahead
and post about it with the same hashtag
and with the unique hashtag so don't be
afraid to you know ride the wave of
popularity so to speak because it shows
that you know you know what you're
talking about it adds some credibility
and it's going to get some you know
viewers over to your Instagram profile
so keep in mind you need to keep your
content relevant because if your
audience is interested in what you have
to offer then they're going to be
engaged however you know if you're
joining the discussion in a relevant
manner keep it in mind whether your
audience would interact or not is
important but just always keep in mind
you always want to stay within your
industry and relevancy for your target
audience so tip number 11 run contests
and giveaways and so just like on
YouTube just like on Facebook I mean
Instagram is no different you can
increase reach and exposure by running
contests since most followers would tag
their friends to let them know about it
it's a good idea to run contests and so
what's an idea of a contest well again
if you're running a pizza parlor you
know you could say hey what's your
favorite pizza or give me your favorite
pizza ideas and you can run contest and
you know you can have people even create
their own pizza and post an image of it
you can have people create stories on
the best ways in which they create pizza
or their experience in another pizza
parlor there's lots of things you can do
to create a contest and you don't always
have to give something away you could
just do something for fun especially if
you have a lot of followers if you have
a lot of followers then somebody's going
to take part in it so don't be afraid to
run contests just to make it fun and
light it up a little bit so each tag can
bring you a new audience member who
could be a potential follower so anytime
you run a contest people are gonna tag
their friends to let them know about
that contest so those friends are gonna
come over and likely engage so that's
the beauty of running a contest or
giveaway is chances are words gonna
spread and it's going to get you some
new followers so that's the the end
benefits so to speak but the real
benefit is keeping your audience engaged
so tip number 12 we want to stay
consistent with posts so having a
consistent pace and theme for your post
can have a huge impact to convert
visitors so when we say consistent you
know if you're again that pizza parlor
stay within Pizza you could Branch out a
little maybe and talk about salads or
talk about beverages to you know as a
complimentary factor to the pizza okay
but don't talk about hamburgers if
you're focused in on pizza so we wanted
to stay consistent with your theme this
method involves less effort with a
faster production of Instagram content
so that mean what we're really trying to
say here is focus stay focused on who
you are if you do that if you're
consistent and you're gaining some
followers and that's what people are
coming to you for the content that
you're good at for the industry you're
in okay so if you start varying and
branching out then it's gonna muddy the
water supposed so to speak and you're
probably going to get less engagement so
set a theme on Instagram by maintaining
consistency and your personality filters
colors and layouts and really what I'm
referring to is post and when you have
post something you're you're really
creating a personality for yourself okay
so if you're in fashion for example and
you're in the jeans industry well jeans
jeans jeans right that's your
personality accentuate it with different
outfits related to jeans but you know
when you start talking about dresses and
shoes and and that kind of blurs your
your personality a bit so if you stay
consistent within jeans and outfits that
go with jeans then I think people are
going to start to pick up on that
personality so tip 13 keep track of your
Instagram following so you can analyze
the growth of your Channel with tools
like socialblade I could tell you how
many followers you lost over time and
how engaged they are okay so you can use
data gather from here and from Instagram
business account to diagnose where
you're faltering so let's take a look at
socialblade as an example here so if I
go over here I'm gonna go to socialblade
here I can enter in basically any
account after a register and I could see
how that account has performed you know
where they rank you know how many
uploads they have what concert they
focused on one industry and the beauty
here is I could see and I'm looking at
YouTube as an example I could see you
know how my post to perform well you
could do this for Instagram you could do
it for Facebook so you can really get an
idea of how your account's performing so
social Blade's a great platform for
measuring and again you do also have
Instagram business insights so with
Instagram business insights basically
what you're going to do is you're going
to go to your app right and then from
the app you could basically look at your
insights from there so in the app itself
you're going to click on the upper right
three lines and from there you're gonna
see insights and when you go to insights
you're also going to see you know what
your reach is how many Impressions and
some engagement metrics terms of your
audience where they're located the age
range okay you're gonna also see some
content related information so there's a
lot you could see from the the Instagram
insights analytics insights but you can
also see additional information from
socialblade so the key here is when
you're looking at your data you want to
look for patterns in post what posts
receive the most amount of Engagement so
if you see something working obviously
replicate it you know you don't want to
replicate it immediately but make note
of it and use it for future content so
tip 14 use Instagram ads so Instagram
ads give you complete control over
advertisements so how they appear and
who sees them so with Instagram ads you
can run photos you can run videos
carousels slideshows stories so we
mentioned this on other webinars for
Facebook advertising it's worth
repeating so if I go back into say a
Facebook ads manager I can pick and
choose my placements and really what I
want to do is pick and choose for
example Instagram and so I have
Instagram feed I have Instagram stories
so and I could see with the video
requirement or the media requirement is
for running on Instagram so with
Instagram you can run stories you can
run videos single image ads you can run
Carousel Sue really you could put your
best forward meaning take the post
that's performing well and maybe you
want to advertise that promote it so
you're going to run this through
Facebook ads manager and it's going to
tell you you know what your audience
size is your potential reach okay what
your daily results would be so you're
going to get all that information when
you run your ads on Facebook ads manager
but it's a great opportunity for you to
really push forward if you're running a
promotion it's really an opportunity for
you to push forward that promotion other
advantages scalable pricing self-serve
and instant robust report reporting and
highly refined audience retargeting so
all of that is in the Facebook ads
manager you can get all the reporting
you need you need meaning you know who
saw the ad did they click on it okay you
can refine that target audience you can
go back into Facebook ads manager and
refine who your audience is so lots of
flexibility here on advertising on
Instagram but the key here is if you
want to run advertising on Instagram you
know think about what it is you're
trying to promote if you feel something
needs to get promoted then go ahead and
you know you can either again reach out
to somebody and have them sponsor it or
you can run it as an advertisement so
let's move on to tip 15. so we want to
create visually attractive and
eye-catching ads so if you are going to
run ads you know here's some things to
keep in mind okay you want to use images
that are natural and seem native okay
you don't want to use any stock
photography first off you want to use
something that you've done okay you want
to minimize the amount of text so let
the m image do the talking you want to
ensure your caption relates to the image
and resonates with your audience okay so
you have an opportunity to add some text
below the image okay so make sure it
resonates and then of course use
hashtags to show your ads to Target your
audience but a wider relevant audience
so hashtags do play a role here as well
so these are some tips if you're going
to create ads you want to take these
into account the whole point of the ad
is to get people over to either web page
or to your profile page okay so that
they can engage and take action so
Instagram ads will help showcase your
product service or brand in a way that's
memorable and unique so if you really
want to get your vision your brand your
product out there in front of a lot of
people then advertising on Instagram is
a good way to do that so since we've
been talking about pizza throughout this
webinar this is a good Instagram a
profile here about pizza you know I'm
getting hungry just looking out this
hopefully this is an example for all veg
and non-veg pizza consumers I mean you
can see this profile here they got the
website you know they got the handle
okay so they have a lot of followers so
you know if I'm in the pizza industry I
can go ahead and you know click on their
followers and see who who's following
them who they're following so some
really good shots of pizza here it looks
like you know a lot of people are
wearing were involved in this you could
see lots of different examples here some
cute ones you know some funny ones some
humorous ones so you know just taking a
look at something like pizza which you
know most people enjoy you know most and
you can kind of appreciate you know how
much of an advantage Instagram can be
because it really you can accentuate
photos you can have fun with it you can
really run some contests here you know
give us your best pizza photo so here
you know you could say use daily Pizza
as a hashtag tag for feature okay so
they're even encouraging you to use a
specific hashtag so you can really do a
lot here on Instagram this is just a
good example of what you can do and have
fun with you know with an example like
pizza just to give you some ideas so
let's move on to tip 16 take advantage
of Instagram tools so you can use
scheduling tools like later HootSuite
and buffer so I can't stress this enough
you know when it comes to measuring the
engagement of your Instagram post you're
definitely going to need a social media
tool so you're also going to need it if
you do a lot of you know posting on
Instagram so let's take a look at an
example we'll use later.com so if I go
to later here I could see you know I can
use this to upload my images to my
profile so here you can see it's
scheduled throughout the day of the week
so that way we're not overlapping you
know we're scheduling based on the times
of the day that people are going to look
at at this so you know here I could see
you know particular stories if any
stories are posted okay I can look at it
from a weekly or monthly preview I could
see what's been posted okay and more
importantly as a schedule tool I can
also see the analytics I could see you
know how many were posted how many
followers so this is really important
because you know if my profile is
growing I want to be able to see what
post performed best what the audience
was like you know by gender by age by
location so again I can look at it by
post-performance story or hashtag
analytics as well so later really goes
into details about you know what's
driving engagement so here you can see
some hashtags that this become
particular company is using on Instagram
so here you can see how many posts with
this hashtag you know and what and kind
of Engagement did they receive do they
receive likes comments Impressions how
much reach do they get how many saves
and it really just does go into detail
so later does a good job I like this
platform especially for Instagram it's
great for scheduling but more important
you know in addition to the Instagram
analytics you can really lean on you
know this particular platform to get a
really good idea as to you know how a
particular posts are performing remember
if a post is performing you want to
reuse it at a certain point in time okay
learn from Best Practices learn from
what's working learn from what's not
working if something's not working then
don't do it again so you can really get
a good breakdown in here and later.com
so remember these tools place an
emphasis on automation okay enabling you
to automatically post at a scheduled
time so you want to lock it in at a
certain period of time and not have to
worry about it so it allows you to
really hone in on that particular time
of the day and day of the week so that
you're really maximizing your chances of
getting good engagement it's develop
your own signature your style so set up
a style and content theme so that you're
able to stand out amongst the various
competitors so you know again just going
back to our pizza example lots of good
photos of pizza you know but this is
their style this is who they are you
know they're not a particular brand
they're just you know people who like
pizza okay and they're having fun with
it okay so that's their style you know
they're probably seeing really good
shots of all this different types of
pizza different styles different
toppings and just to give you an idea of
how popular pizza is and what you can do
with it okay so again this is a good
basic example
um of what you can do with something as
simple as pizza so don't be afraid to
experiment you know try something
different with your profile you know do
something different you don't always
have to follow what everybody else is
doing that's the great thing about
Instagram it allows you to be free and
creative in fact if anybody has any
styles that have worked for them you
know feel free to put something in the
comment section we'd love to hear your
thoughts so today 18 use user engagement
to your advantage so I just mentioned
that using the later example so we want
to be able to learn from what's working
and not working so user generated
content shows off your brand to be
authentic and improves your relationship
with your followers so you know you want
to be unique with the content that
you're posting so if you do that you're
likely to build that relationship and
you know increase your followers and you
want to be able to see of that user
generated content that ugc which is
performing which is not performing okay
so basically your followers and your
audience are telling you what's working
and not working so take advantage of
that remember going back to hashtags you
can set up your own unique hashtag and
ask your users to post images or videos
relating to that which you can post in
your Brand's account so just like the
whole pizza thing they're saying hey
look you know use daily pizza for a
feature okay that's a good exam example
something you can do as well so you
could set up a unique hashtag and say
hey use this hashtag and that'll help
you gain some followers that'll help you
gain some notoriety and some visibility
on your platform tip 19 use high quality
images and videos just like on YouTube
just like on Facebook Instagram's no
different images must be of high quality
authentic and original I mean again one
more time going back to the pizza these
images look to be pretty high quality I
mean if you have a decent mobile phone
that's all it takes a mobile phone with
a camera that is that's all it usually
takes you know you want to be able to
get that that right shot you don't want
to use anything that's of low quality
because it really is going to take away
from you know the story you're trying to
tell so you don't have to be
professional per se just make sure what
you're posting whether it be video or
whether it be an image is of high
quality and remember videos needs to be
fun and informational about causing the
user to lose is interest so you know if
you're going to create a video you know
go ahead and you know make you can make
it short make it fun okay you can see
here these guys are just showing you how
pizza's made doesn't take a long time
they're just going through the motions
they're not boring you with details
they're not talking really quick and
easy just to give you an idea it doesn't
have to be as serious it could be fun so
video content needs to be fun and
informational without causing users to
lose interest that's the key short sweet
unique authentic and fun have fun with
it so worth repeating don't use stock
images on Instagram because you know
they don't really bode well for your
particular brand you know it's Instagram
it allows you to post original content
that's the whole purpose of it okay and
on the video side be concise high
quality and informational enough okay so
you have to hold the user's attention
here so when we say concise you know
don't make it a five minute video
obviously make it high quality relevant
to what you're trying to offer and if
you could do that you're likely going to
hold the user's attention so tip 20
promote your Instagram page and other
social media channels so Facebook and
Instagram are part of the same family so
this seems like a natural but you know
don't be afraid to promote it on other
channels like Pinterest or or YouTube
The whole idea is to get users to your
Instagram page and encourage them to
follow it so you know you can always put
that URL in you know other platforms
like YouTube nothing wrong with that at
all okay you can also promote your page
offline with print ads and during other
relevant events and then I would even
take that as to further as you probably
see you know an Instagram logo on a web
page along with other social media icons
so you always want to help promote
Instagram on your web page as well but
you can do it for offline with print ads
so you can simply just put you know
whatever your your slug is for Instagram
and whatever your ID is whatever you're
using on Instagram that's what you can
use don't be afraid to promote it
offline or online social media marketing
tools social media always a great topic
to talk about so we're gonna finish up
all our digital marketing tools with
social media we talked about SEO paid
competition affiliate email you know web
analytics it's just appropriate to
finish up with social media because
social media has so many tools available
so many okay the first one I can think
about here is HootSuite HootSuite is a
great social media marketing tool to use
okay it's a freemium okay you can set up
a free trial here you you basically a
base account and then uh you can use
HootSuite to do a lot of things anything
from setting up landing pages to
actually publishing content to listening
HootSuite to me is one of the most
powerful social media marketing tools
available you got buffer buffer is a
paid version but you can actually set up
a low cost or free account actually on
Buffer and then move to a paid account
okay you got tweetdex been around a long
time that is actually free and I would
recommend sweet Tech and we're going to
take a look at that here in a couple
minutes okay and then you got Sprout
social Sprout social is another social
marketing platform similar to HootSuite
do a lot of reporting a lot of
publishing you can a lot of listening
and so we're going to take a look at
Sprout social today as well before we do
that let's go over why these tools are
important to us from a social media
perspective you're pumping out a lot of
content so you need to be able to
smartly efficiently you know schedule
and manage your post okay so you're not
just working likely with just one
platform like Facebook you're probably
on a number of different platforms
depending on your business depending on
your bandwidth depending on what you're
selling in your products Etc your
audience obviously has a lot to do with
it you know it could be Instagram
Pinterest you want to be able to
consolidate all that and manage it in
one place and that's what social media
marketing tools do they allow you to
manage everything in one place so if you
can manage everything in one place then
the social media marketing platforms
need to be able to make it easy for you
to add and manage different accounts
okay so a lot of them have the ability
for you to add you know not just one
Twitter account but multiple Twitter
accounts and not just one social media
platform but multiple social media
platforms and a good social media
marketing so worth its weight will help
you monitor the results so monitor
social media posts that help Drive leads
and sales in other words you're going to
have a lot of different metrics
associated with each social media
marketing platform okay which one is
actually doing its job okay so you want
to be able to easily manage these
platforms applications and websites very
efficiently okay so instead of having to
log into each platform is log into one
place get a sense of what's been posted
what the engagement is did they purchase
Etc and what you want to do is be able
to individually customize every social
media post across different platforms so
it just makes it a lot easier to do that
in these social media marketing tools
okay you don't want to send out a
blanket message across different
platforms you want to be able to go
ahead and customize a post depending on
what that post is depending what the
product is what time of day what target
market what target audience so
customization is a lot easier using
these social media marketing tools you
want to be able to engage with brand
Advocates so listening is a good thing
with social media marketing tools using
the listening functionality so you can
actually see who is a brand Advocate
who's not a brand Advocate who's an
influencer who's not an influencer and
then of course you want to analyze the
behavior of your audience and optimize
individual posts on real-time data so if
for example you post something using one
of these social media marketing
platforms and you see it go viral then
you want to be able to react to that in
real time so you're going to be able to
see that in real time on these social
media marketing tools these platforms
like Sprouts social and HootSuite and
then you're going to be able to react to
that behavior and then of course
monitoring website traffic and
conversion rates that's key we always
want to monitor conversions based on our
kpis our business goals so there are
also a few important digital marketing
tools that can help you in different
ways okay so without further Ado let's
jump in and take a look at what's
available in terms of social media
marketing so just a quick reminder if
you are running ads on Facebook or
you're posting on Facebook as an example
or any platform in general that
platform's going to have its own metrics
if you will so for example Facebook has
something called Facebook insights
you'll be able to actually see you know
what's been posted based on you know the
last seven days in this example how many
page views you're getting engagements
recent posts so just to let you know yes
you can go into any one of these
platforms on its own and look at metrics
just like you can do if you're running
Facebook ads okay you can go right into
Facebook ads manager and view data there
okay so the whole point here though on
using a social media tool is that you
can measure all that in one place so if
we log into sproutsocial I can set up
these accounts right into Sprout social
so I don't have to log into Twitter
individually or Facebook individually I
can link them up all within Sprout
social and then I can go to reports just
like I can with Facebook insights and
then once I'm in Facebook excuse me once
I'm in Sprout social reporting then I
can go ahead just like I can in Facebook
insights except it's all right here for
me I can jump into you know Facebook and
dig a little bit deeper as to what's
going on with my account so I don't have
to log into Facebook directly I can see
you know the Impressions the engagement
the clicks over a period of time I can
see my audience growth I can see my
publishing Behavior how often my
publishing I can see the top post
individually I could see Impressions by
day you know a lot of this same material
same information is already in Facebook
insights so if it's available on
Facebook insights you know you're
definitely going to have it available in
a tool like Sprout social so you want to
be able to just efficiently log in and
jump from one platform to the other so
here you know I can go to Instagram you
know and look at Instagram data or I can
look at Twitter information so you want
to be able to efficiently jump from one
platform to the other using in this
example Sprout social now as I mentioned
as part of one of the benefits of a
social media tool is that you can
publish content you want to be able to
publish content because you want to be
able to organize and schedule
accordingly you don't want to be
submitting and Publishing content right
after one another okay you want to be
able to spread it out efficiently and
effectively and so here we could see you
know we could publish and schedule
content accordingly so all we have to do
is Click compose select a profile write
whatever we need to do you can schedule
it for tomorrow at a specific time and
there you go voila schedule so this is
on Twitter okay so you know we could
choose another platform here it's just
that easy to schedule so you want to be
able to schedule accordingly because
again when you schedule something then
you want to look at the behavior of it
so it's just as simple as going from
publishing to reporting and then based
on when something got published you
could see the reaction of it and react
to it so another thing here that I like
about it's about social heat Suite A lot
of these other platforms do it really
well you got listening tools so you can
listen in on conversations that are
being had for example uh mail delivery
you know if we do mail delivery and
Twitter search we'll be able to see
what's been tweeted about mail
deliveries you know if that's the
business we're in we can refine our
search and choose a specific location a
radius to hone in if we're local okay so
this is Sprout socials example of
listening here let's take a look at
another example I'm in later.com so
later very similar to sprout social in
that it does a lot of the same same
things you can actually schedule content
on a particular platform and one thing I
like about later here you can actually
see it visually you can see a calendar
and what's been scheduled so I could see
today I have scheduled something
scheduled at 1 15 local time and again I
have five profiles set up for this
account so I can pick and choose the
profile that I want to publish to so it
just makes it that much easier and I can
visually see it and that's important so
here I can click on media library so the
one thing about later.com is that you
know you have a library of images that
potentially you can reuse so if I click
on this image here okay I can get a
sense of when it was used and I can view
it on a calendar I can add label for it
so that's another benefit to later is
that they have this media library here
they have conversations so I can
actually connect to a platform and
listen in on conversation that are being
had similar to The Listening tool in
Sprout social and they have analytics so
you can actually see right in later.com
how your particular social media
platform is performing so I could see
here over seven days I can see the
number of followers have increased I
could see the growth rate I can see the
number of Impressions that I've received
okay so I want to be able to see how my
particular platforms performing over a
period of time so I can look at reach
the law profile views website clicks
okay so I can get a lot of good insights
here right in the analytics platform
later you can look at specific post
performance so if we posted something I
could see basically how many likes it
received how many comments Impressions
the reach and then if I wanted to I can
click on details and get more specific
information on it engagement rate okay
Discovery actions comments save
Etc so later.com goes into some nice
detail about post performance they even
have date on hashtags so if you use an
hashtag you can actually see how many
times the hashtag's been used or saved
how many Impressions it's received okay
so they really go into some nice detail
here about how your post and how your
accounts are performing and here's a
tool I really like I've been using for a
long time and that's tweet Tech so what
tweetdec does is connect with your
Twitter account so you can see in a
different visual so to speak of how your
Twitter account looks in terms of your
feed here I can see this is my feed here
okay I can see some notifications I can
see specific messages then on this
column I can see activity okay so I can
add different columns here if I wanted
to and basically by adding columns you
could see I can look for what's trending
as an example so I'm going to add in a
column that says trending and so now I
can go in and see okay these are all the
different things that are trending on
Twitter uh so you can actually add a
column and pay attention to something
really specific okay so for example
search okay so right now I have men's
health but I could type in let's just
say World Cup okay so I could see the
you got the qriket World Cup you got you
know the soccer football World Cup going
on so you know we could pick a
particular topic to follow if we wanted
to so again here I'm following Men's
Health so I can now see you know
everything that's been posted on men's
health now if I click on for example one
of these hashtags here that's trending I
can actually see who's tagging or using
that hashtag Friday feeling in their
tweets and so the whole idea behind you
know tweetdeck it serves up a
interesting overview so to speak of not
only your account but you know a
specific topic or what's trending or you
know other things that are being said so
if you really want to pay attention to
your brand or something really specific
like you know your competitors or a
specific product then you can just do a
search on that and so that's the great
thing about tweaktag it allows you to
kind of just look and listen in on
everything going on in Twitter thanks
Rob with that we've come to the end of
this complete social media marketing
tutorial I hope you guys enjoyed this do
like and share it thank you for watching
and stay tuned for more from Simply
learn
foreign